PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. FACE
TO FACE COVERING GUIDELINES
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. HOLIER
COMMITTEE HEARINGS IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY THE MEMBER ATTENDING
REMOTELY TODAY'S SENATOR HENRY
STERN CENTER STERN IF YOU HAVE
A STAFF PERSON WITH YOU IN YOUR
OFFICE PLEASE IDENTIFY THAT
STAFFER. SINISTER MISTER
DIRECTORS HERE HE'S IN ANOTHER
ROOM BUT HE'S IN THE OFFICE.
JEREMY WOLF I'M SORRY. THANK
YOU SENATOR STERN CENTERS TURN
AS A REMINDER PLEASE MUTE YOUR
MICROPHONE- ON YOUR PHONE OR
COMPUTER WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING THIS WILL EIGHT
ELIMINATING CUSICK FEEDBACK
ACID EVERY TIME YOU WHICH WE
RECOGNIZE USE THAT RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE ON THE PROGRAM
EACH TIME YOU RECOGNIZE THE
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE SELECT
A MUTE BEFORE BEGINNING TO
SPEAK R. I. T. PERSONAL PUT YOU
BACK IN MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE
LET'S RECOGNIZE THE SPEAK
PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE
SEEN ON SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME
AND THEN YOU'RE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE I THINK
SENATOR STERN YOU'VE BEEN TO
THIS ONE JUST TWICE BEFORE. BOB
WELL THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMIN MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OF
THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
IT WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TESTIFIED TODAY PRO INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
NOW ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. IN THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE ONE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. WHEN WE HAVE WHEN WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN REQUIRE A
SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATE CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT IME
TO BE ON MUTE AND YOU'LL BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND
AVOID ACOUSTIC FOOD FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING OR HEARING OR WATCHING
OR TESTING HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE
IT'S IMPORTANT WE HEAR. FROM
YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED. FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
CONDUCTED HEARINGS IS CLOSED.
THE SAME MERIT MANNERS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
TIME LINES FOR DISPENSED TO
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL OF
PATIENTS SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. ALL
RIGHT- DO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS. AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS AND
COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY. EACH
SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME WHICH IS TO
WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES EACH-
I WILL MAINTAIN. THAT POLICY
FOR ALL BILLS TODAY TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH YOU
DON'T NEED TO TAKE THE FULL TWO
MINUTES BUT THAT'S YOUR MAXIMUM
TIME ALLOWED. OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME THEIR
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. I WANNA MAKE IT CLEAR
UP FRONT THAT I WILL COMMIT
EACH SIDE SUPPORT OPPOSITION TO
TWO PRIMARY WITNESS EACH
PRIMARY WITNESS WILL COMMITTED.
TESTIFIED FOR TWO MINUTES. A
PERMIT EACH SIDE OF A MAXIMUM
OF FIFTEEN MINUTES FR
WITNESSES WHO MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS LET ME STATE THIS
AGAIN TO THE NAME AFFILIATION A
POSITION- BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION THE BILL'S LET'S
ESTABLISH A- QUORUM. AND CHIEFCOUNSEL IF YOU COULD CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS PLEASE SPEAK INTO
YOUR MICROPHONE- FOR PURPOSES
OF ESTABLISHING A FORUM- BURKE.
YEAH I'M BURKE HERE BORJAS.
FORTUS PRESENT COVEY IT'LL- GET
US SO. THE REST SO HERE
GONZALEZ HERE AND SALAS HERE
HERTZBERG. JONES LAYERED HERE
LATE HERE STERN. STERN HERE
REMOTELY WHITE HOUSE SKI HERE
WHY CASKEY HERE WIENER. THERE
WINNER HERE'S A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU MA'AM
CHIEF COUNSEL I WANT TO NOTE
THAT PHYLUM NUMBER THREE SB SIX
SEVEN SIX BY SENATOR BATES
WHICH WAS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
THE HEARING AND WILL NOT BE
HEARD TODAY IT TWENTY NINE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. OF
WHICH ELEVEN ARE ON CONSENT THE
FOLLOWING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE NUMBER TWO S. B.
FOUR FIVE FOUR BY SENATOR BATES
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE
FIVE TWO BY SENATOR EGGMAN WITH
AMENDMENTS FILE NUMBER ELEVEN
SB SIX EIGHT SEVEN BY CENTER
HUESO WITH AMENDMENTS PROBLEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN S. B. 703%
HEARD BOTTLE WITH AMENDMENTS
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN SB
TWO EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR JONES.
WITH AMENDMENTS FILE NUMBER
FIFTEEN SB. SIX FOUR SEVEN BY
CENTER LAYERED. FILE ITEM
NUMBER NAY. S. B. THREE ONE
ZERO BY SENATOR RUBIO WITH
AMENDMENTS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO SB TWO THREE THREE
BY SENATOR UMBERG. FILE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE SB THREE FOUR NINE
BY SENATOR UMBERG WITH
AMENDMENTS FILE NUMBER TWENTY
SIX SB SIX SIX SIX BY SEN
ROBERT AND FINALLY FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT SB SEVEN
SIX TWO BY SENATOR WHAT CAL
SKI. THE MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR I MOVED THE CONSENT
COUNTY. VERY WELL VERY WELL
DONE CENTER LAYERED CENTER
LAYERED MOVES. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MADAM CHIEF COUNSEL
RECALL THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- BURKE- BURKE HI
FORGES ALL. AGES I GOTTA GET A-
COMING AT ALL I THE RUSSELL.
THE ALSO ICONS. GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. JOHN LAYARD. LAYARD
HI STERN. ST STERN HIGHWAY CAL
SKI NINE Y. CASKEY AYE WIENER.
WIENER HI YOU HAVE NINE TWO
ZERO SO FAR. THAT MATTER ON
CALL THANK YOU COUNSEL ALL
RIGHT I SEE SEVERAL OF THE BACK
OF THE CHAMBER OF CENTER ALLEN
IS READY TO GO WE'RE READY TO
GO. SURROUND THANK YOU. WITH US
LET ME ASK YOU IF YOU ACCEPT
THE MEMBERS AS OUTLINED IN
OUNCES ON PAGE NINE COMMENT
NUMBER TWO I DO WITH GREAT
THANKS BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO
IMPROVE OUR BILL IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU- SENATE ALAN. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU SO MUCH- AND
I WAS JUST THE NEW TELLING MY
COLLEAGUE ABOUT WHAT WHAT YOU
WHAT WHAT IS A VERY DIFFICULT-
SERIES OF ISSUESTO THINK ABOUT
THIS IS OUR WASTE MANAGEMENT
AND RECYCLING SYSTEM. NOW AND
THEY'RE A BIG- ISSUES WITH THAT
WITH THAT SYSTEM AND- CERTAINLY
WE'VE GOT LEGISLATION TO TRY TO
FIX. THE SYSTEM WRIT LARGE BUT
THIS IS ACTUALLY A RELATIVELY
IS A PRETTY SIMPLE MEASURE. I
DEALING WITH A COMPLICATED
ISSUE SO CURRENT LAW. PREVENTS
THE MANUFACTURE FOR MAKING AN
UNTRUTHFUL ENVIRONMENTAL CLAIM.
SUCH AS EARTH FRIENDLY OR
RECYCLABLE. IF IT IF IT IS NOT
RECYCLABLE- AND SO NOW HERE'S
THE PROBLEM A LOT OF
MANUFACTURERS WHO ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO SAY THAT THEIR ITEM
IS RECYCLABLE. ARE ALLOWED
UNDER CURRENT LAW TO STAMP THE
RECYCLING SYMBOL. ON THEIR
PRODUCT. SO AND THEY'RE SENDING
A SIGNAL TO A CONSUMER THAT AN
ITEM IS RECYCLABLE EVEN IF IT
REALLY ISN'T. SO HERE'S THE
HERE'S THE SAD TRUTH IN
CALIFORNIA LESS THAN 15% OF
SINGLE USE PLASTIC IS RECYCLED.
RECYCLING COSTS EXCEED THE
SCRAP VALUE OF THE PLASTIC
MATERIAL ITSELF THAT'S PART OF
THAT'S WHEN IT WHEN ENORMOUS
PART OF THE PROBLEM. THE
RECYCLING PROCESS IS EXPENSIVE-
AND ACTUALLY ENVIRONMENTALLY
DAMAGING AS WELL. HI HOWEVER. I
KNOW ALL OF US DUTIFULLY TRIED
TO FILL OUR BLUE BINS WITH
ITEMS THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
RECYCLABLE. BUT DOES JUST
TALKING CENTER PORCHES AND WE
WERE GOING BACK AND FORTH ABOUT
ITEMS THAT THAT ARE THAT WE
COMMONLY BELIEVED TO RECYCLE
BUT THAT BUT THAT IN THE END OF
THE DAY ARE NOT. ACTUALLY
RECYCLE. AND IN THIS IS
ACTUALLY A PROBLEM IT'S WHAT WE
NOW CALL WISH CYCLING WHERE
PEOPLE. PUT ITEMS THAT THEY
BELIEVE TO BE RECYCLABLE INTO
THE BLUE BAND IN THAT IN DOING
SO IT ENDS UP WITH A
CONTAMINATING THE RECYCLING
STREAM MAKING IT MORE COSTLY TO
SORT AND CLEAN THE CHILI
RECYCLE MATERIAL I USED TO DO
THIS MYSELF AND I'M A REGULAR.
I'M ONE OF THESE GUYS WHO LIKE
TO SUBSCRIBE TO THE NEWSPAPER.
OKAY YOU KNOW- SO HI. MY LILY
TIME TO COME IN A LITTLE BAG.
IT WAS A RECYCLING SYMBOL
STAMPED ON THE BACK. AND I
WOULD DUTIFULLY I WOULD
LITERALLY SETTING ASIDE AND PUT
THE BAG INTO MY BLUE BIN.
BECAUSE I THOUGHT HAVING SEEN
THE RECYCLING SYMBOL ON MY BACK
AND THIS WAS A RECYCLE MATERIAL
THE- I. NOW THROUGH THIS JOB I
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
VISIT. AMERSON RECYCLING
CENTERS AND WASTE MANAGEMENT
FACILITIES AND DUMPS. IN THE IT
TURNS OUT OF THOSE LITTLE BAGS
ARE A REAL PROBLEM NOT ONLY DO
THEY END UP COMING UP THE
MACHINES. THAT PLASTIC FILM BUT
THEY ACTUALLY ALSO END UP
CONTAMINATING THE PAPER STREAM
THEY GET. THEY GET INTO OUR
PAPER STREAM. ORDERLY ONE MANY
REASONS WHY CHINA DOESN'T WANT
TO RECYCLE MATERIAL ANYMORE
BECAUSE ALL THIS. OR THE WHY
THE PAPER MILLS AS WELL I THESE
PAPER BILLS SHOW UP WITH TONS
AND TONS. OF PLASTIC FILM STUCK
IT IN THE PAPER BELLS IN IT IT
REALLY BECOMES A PROBLEM WHEN
IT COMES TO TRYING TO RECYCLE
THAT PAPER. SO THE IDEA IS THAT
IF THE MATERIAL IS NOT ACTUALLY
RECYCLABLE. I DON'T REALLY
BELIEVE THE SYSTEM THE WASTE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM HAS TO REMOVE
THE ITEM FROM THE CONVEYOR BELT
AFTER CYCLING FACILITY IS THE-
THING CARTED AWAY TO A
LANDFILL. IT'S EXTRA WORK
INCREASE WASTE RATES. AND COST
OF. A PROCESS TO RECYCLE
MATERIAL- A SURVEY JUST
RELEASED THIS YEAR BY THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
FOUND THAT MORE THAT. IT'S MORE
THAN SEVEN OUT OF TEN CITIES.
SO OVER 70% OF OUR CITY'S
ANTICIPATE INCREASING WASTE
COLLECTION READ BY WAS MUCH AS
TWENTY PERCENT. TO COVER THE
COST OF MANAGING THE ADDITIONAL
WICKS. MEMBERS THIS IS NOT JUST
AN ENVIRONMENTAL PROBLEM IT'S
BECOMING A PART OF THE PROBLEM.
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS IN FACT
THE FOLKS IN SACRAMENTO KNOW
THIS ALL TOO WELL. THAT THIS
COUNTY SACRAMENTO JUST RAISE
ITS RATES BY TEN DOLLARS A
MONTH. EVERY SINGLE MONTH HERE
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY BECAUSE OF
THIS PROBLEM. THE STREET A
LOCAL RECYCLING WE SYSTEMS IS
COMPOUNDED AS CONSUMERS
MISTAKENLY BELIEVE. THE CHASING
ARROW SYMBOL THE SPECIAL
RECYCLING SYMBOL OFTEN IN
CIRCLES THE PLASTIC RESIN
IDENTIFICATION CODE. I THINK WE
JUSTIFICATION BELIEVE THAT
MEANS THE PRODUCT. IS GOING TO
BE RECYCLED IF THEY THROW IN
THEIR BLUE BIN. THIS IS A
SYSTEM AS YOU MAY KNOW THAT
CLASSIFIES ALL TYPES OF
PLASTICS FROM NUMBERS ONE THREE
SEVEN. IT WAS DESIGNED AS A
METHOD FOR WASTE FACILITIES TO
PROPERLY SORT PLASTICS NOT. TO
SUGGEST LIKE ABILITY TO
CONSUMERS. YET AFTER THIRTY
YEARS AND USE THE SYMBOL IS
GOING TO BE STATE AS UNDERSTOOD
AS THE RECYCLING SYMBOL. LET'S
BE HONEST WE DON'T KNOW HOW
CONFUSING. RECYCLING IS IN IN
FACT THE CONSUMER BRANDS.
ASSOCIATION RECENTLY
PERFORMANCE THAN RECYCLING THE
FOUNDER FOR MANY AMERICANS
RECYCLING RANKS AHEAD. OF SO IT
TURNS OUT THAT KNOWING WHAT HOW
TO RECYCLE IS MORE CONFUSING.
THAN BUILDING IKEA FURNITURE.
DOING YOUR TAXES PLAYING THE
STOCK MARKET. OR UNDERSTANDING
SOMEONE FROM THE OTHER SEX. AT
THE TO THE STATE WIDE
COMMISSION ON RECYCLING MARKETS
IN CURBSIDE RECYCLING IS RECENT
REPORT SINCE CONSUMERS A QUITE
THE RECYCLE WORD AND SYMBOL
WITH WHICH IS WHAT IS ACCEPTED
IN. CURBSIDE RECYCLING BINS OF
THE RECYCLE WORD AND SYMBOL
MUST BE RESERVED FOR MATERIALS
WHICH ARE ACCEPTED IN CURBSIDE
BINS AND DO NOT CAUSE
CONTAMINATION. AND IN FACT THE
COMMISSION UNANIMOUSLY
RECOMMENDED PROHIBITING THE USE
OF THE CHASER OF SYMBOL. AND
LESS THE MATERIALS TRULY
RECYCLABLE THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IT TAKES THE
STATEWIDE COMMISSION RECYCLING
MARKET TO CURBSIDE RECYCLING IS
REPORT RECOMMENDATIONS AND
IMPLEMENT THEM SO. STAY IN
FEDERAL LAWMAKER THE PRODUCERS
CAN'T LIE TO CONSUMERS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT A PRODUCT IS
RECYCLABLE. IN IN IN IN ITS
VERBAL FORM RECYCLABLE AT USE
THEY CAN USE THAT WORD
RECYCLABLES IT IS CLARIFIED
THIS TO INCLUDE. THE USE OF THE
CHASING ARROW SYMBOL. WE
REALIZE AN EXISTING CRITERIA TO
DETERMINE WHICH MATERIAL TYPES
ACTUALLY RECYCLABLE CAN DISPLAY
ON THE CHASING HEROES THE
CRITERIA REQUIRES THE MATERIAL
TO BE MORE THAN JUST A
TECHNICALLY RECYCLABLE IN SOME
LAB ACTUALLY. ABLE TO BE
COLLECTED SORTED BALED MEMORY
MANUFACTURED INTO NEW PRODUCTS.
THE BILL ACCOUNTS FOR
MANUFACTURERS USE MATERIALS
MIGHT NOT YET MEET THE CRITERIA.
BUT WHO ARE WORKING TO INCREASE
RECYCLABILITY. LAST CLAMSHELLS
EXAMPLE ARE GETTING THAT'S A
GOOD EXAMPLE SO INSTEAD SIMPLY
TO. THAT THE MATERIAL ARE
PSYCHO THE BILL PROVIDES AN
RAMP. ALLOWING THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ENCOURAGE CONSUMERS TO
RECYCLE THE PROJECT. AS WELL
THEY MAKE THE NECESSARY
INVESTMENTS TO COLLECT AND
EFFECTIVELY SORT AND REPROCESS
IT. BY CLARIFYING THAT ONLY
ACTUALLY RECYCLABLE MATERIAL
AND DISPLAY. THE CHEESY EURO
SYMBOL THE BILL. WILL END
CONSUMER CONFUSION ABOUT WHAT
IS RECYCLABLE IMPROVE RECYCLING
EFFICIENCY AND REDUCE
CONTAMINATION COSTS. AVERAGE
LIKELY FACILITIES SO I GOT IT
TO REALLY GREAT SPEAKERS FIRST
OF ALL HI DECEMBER THE NATIONAL
STEWARDSHIP ACTUALLY COUNSEL.
BUT I ALSO HAVE STATEWIDE VINCI
GINGER THE STATEWIDE RECYCLING
COMMISSION. BUT I'VE ALSO GOT
CHUCK CAL GET. WHOSE WITH
REPUBLIC SERVICES AND IT'S
ULTIMATELY THE FOLKS IN THE
WASTE MANAGEMENT SPACE THE
HOLLERS AND THE COLLECTORS. WHO
I THINK I'VE SEEN HOW
PROBLEMATIC OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
IS UP CLOSE AND PERSONAL NAY.
THEY STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE I WHILE WHILE THE
RECYCLING SYMBOL SYSTEM. BEGAN
FOR WITH GOOD WITH GOOD INTENT.
IT'S TURNED INTO A BIG MASS
WHERE A LOT OF STUFF IS GOING
TO TURN THE SYSTEM. THAT
SHOULDN'T BE. SO LET'S TURN IT
OVER TO YOU MISS SAM ONE. THANK
YOU SEVERAL UP REALLY OF THE
PEOPLE. ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY IF
YOU'RE BUYING TO SEE. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH I MIGHT EXPAND WITH AN
OUT GEORGE FACT COUNCILS AND
I'M ADVOCATE FOR THE KILLER.
FIFTY THREE FOUR THREE
ADDRESSES A PROBLEM WE HAVEN'T
CAL. WE CANNOT ACHIEVE A THIRTY
ECONOMY FOR AND POLLUTANTS CAN
NOT WHAT IS REQUIRED. THE
CONSUMER IS FIRST IN THE
SORTING AND THEIR FEW AS
HIGHLIGHTED IN A RECENT TICKET
BY ALL. IT SHOULD BE A FROM
NINETEEN STATE THAT 90% OF
AMERICA DON'T CONVERSE WHAT THE
INSIDE THE CHASING ARROWS.
ASSEMBLY AND GOES ON TO SAY
THAT 68% OF CONSUMERS ANY
PRODUCT WITH SYMBOL FOR ALL
SEVEN CODE WOULD BE RECYCLABLE
AFTER LEARNING THAT ONLY TWO OF
THE SEVEN RESIDENTS ARE
RECYCLABLE WHICH IS A
PRELIMINARY FINDING OF THE
RECYCLING COMMISSION. 73% OF
CONSUMERS WERE SURPRISED. TO
REDUCE CONFUSION AND THIRTEEN.
S. T. M. REQUIRE ZERO WITH THE-
TRIANGLE. AND TOOK THEM FIVE
YEARS TO DO THAT. HOWEVER MANY
FAIR ARE NOT REQUIRED TO CHANGE
EXISTING MOLD TO RECORD
FINISHED. THANK YOU SEE GREEN
GUY DID NOT GO FAR BECAUSE
THEIR DEFINITION RECYCLED. IS
IT OVER PER OF HOUSEHOLDS HAVE
ACCESS TO COLLECTIONS. THE
QUESTION IS NOT A QUICK
RECYCLING WE ARE COLLECTING
TRASH. THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE
POWER CYCLE TO DETERMINE YOUR
REGULATIONS WHICH MATERIALS ARE
TRULY RECYCLABLE AND COMPARE
THE CHASING ARROW SYMBOL. OUR
RESOURCES WILL THEN BE SPENT ON
SORTING RECYCLABLES NOT TRASH.
THE ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
THEY THEY WANT NATIONAL
LABELING UNIFORMITY BUT ARE NOT
UTILIZING THE NEW ASTM
STANDARDS OF THE. SOLID
EQUILATERAL TRIANGLE. YOU KNOW
WANT YOU TO WERE THE FACT
LABELING. AT ONE THIRTY AND TWO
IN LATE. CAL MUST AND WE STAND
TO HELP ANYONE TO HARMONIZE
THIS TRUTH LABELING. NATIONALLY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
SANBORN. MR HOGAN ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. YES THANK YOU. SURE
MURDERED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON CHECK CALVET
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
REPUBLIC SERVICES THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY TODAY.
WHAT IS RECYCLING. IS ONE OF
THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT RECYCLING SYSTEMS IN
THE WORLD. I TO BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BEING INVESTED INTO THE
SYSTEM AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO
PROVE RECYCLING CONTAMINATION
REMAINS ONE OF OUR MOST
SIGNIFICANT EXPENSIVE
OBSTACLES. SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE AN
EXTENSIVE MANUAL SORT LINES
OPTICAL SORTERS SCREENS
SHREDDER'S FLOORS AND OTHER
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES. BUT THE
TRUTH IS THESE ARE DOLLARS
USING EQUIPMENT ARE FAR MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN CONSUMER
EDUCATION AND EFFECTIVE SOURCE
SEPARATION. OPEN YOUR ATTENTION
AND OR LOCAL HOLLER SPEND
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY EDUCATING OUR
CUSTOMERS ON WHAT IS RECYCLABLE
IN EFFORT TO IMPROVE RECYCLING
RATES REDUCE CONTAMINATION. AND
RECYCLING COSTS. BUT THOSE
DOLLARS ARE WASTED IF THE
PACKAGING OR MATERIALS INCLUDE
MARKINGS THAT FALSELY CLAIMED
THESE PACKAGES OR MATERIALS ARE
RECYCLABLE. IT'S GOING OF
RECYCLABILITY CONFUSE CONSUMERS
WHO ARE ALREADY STRUGGLING TO
IDENTIFY CORRECTLY WHICH SHOULD
BE PLACED IN RECYCLING THEM. SB
FORTY THREE IS FUNDAMENTALLY
ABOUT TRUTH IN ADVERTISING
DON'T CLAIM YOUR PACKAGING OR
MATERIAL IS RECYCLED UNLESS OUR
ACTUAL RECYCLING MARKETS FOR
THE MATERIAL THAT CAN BE
READILY AND EFFICIENTLY REMOVED
FROM THE WASTE STREAM. THAT'S
ANOTHER. UNDER ALLEN'S
TESTIMONY FROM PLASTICS WHILE
OFFERING CONSUMERS RELATIVELY
CHEAP PACKAGING OPTION WEIGHS
VERY LITTLE FOR CYCLING
PURPOSES AND COST TO SOLICIT 5%
OF THE WAY STREET. THESE BAGS
CLOG RECYCLING AND COMPOSTING
MACHINERY CREATE LITTER
PROBLEMS AT OUR FACILITIES ARE
EXPENSIVE TO REMOVE RECYCLING
STREAM. THE SERVER SHOULD NOT
BE LED TO BELIEVE THAT THE
SPECTRAL RECYCLABLE UNLESS
MARKETS EXIST. THESE BAGS CAN
EFFECTIVELY BE REMOVED FROM THE
WAY STREET. SB THREE FOUR THREE
ENJOYS STRONG SUPPORT FROM
STRIKERS BECAUSE IT SETS
EFFECTIVELY CLEAR STANDARDS
RECYCLABILITY THAT WILL
INCREASE RECYCLING EFFICIENCIES
IMPROVE CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
RECYCLING. AND WILL REDUCE
RECYCLING COSTS FROM RAEPAYERS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AND
RECYCLERS. WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MAY
HEALTHCARE RIGHT AT TWO- ARE
THERE ANY OF WITNESS WHO WOULD
TO TEST SO. HERE IN THE GALLERY
SEE TO. INDIVIDUALS NEITHER
WHOM SEEM TO BE INSTINTO SPYING
ON THIS BILL ANYONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. NO ONE IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE MISTER MODERATOR LET'S
GO TO THE PHONES NOW IT IF
THERE'S ANYONE. WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FOUR THREE- PLEASE DIAL IN NOW.
AND WHEN YOU'RE PROMPTED PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL LET'S TURN TO
SUPPORTERS FIRST MISTER
MODERATOR. SURE WE HAVE- ONLINE
AT ONE FIFTY FIVE. GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS BONNIE THEN WE'LL LOOK
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE WE
ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF I.
THREE THREE FORTY THREE
HELPLESS TO REGISTER FIRST OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE QUEEN'S
EVOLVING COLLECTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WE WILL BOTH THE
LINE NUMBER ONE SIXTY SIX THE
IS OPEN. UNION FOR MEMBERS OF
THE CHANGE OUR BEHALF OF LOW
INTEREST THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK NOW WE WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE EIGHT FINALLY. ONE
THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS LAUREN COLUMN ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER. ONE SIXTY ONE
FIFTY ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN
MOFFETT ON BEHALF OF WASTE
MANAGEMENT SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER. ONE FORTY NINE ONE
FORTY NINE. ENGINE MEMBERS
VISITED NEYMAR ON BEHALF OF
OCEAN CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE HAD ONE
NUMBER. ONE FORTY FOUR NINE ONE
FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU DOCTOR
INSURANCE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN K. ON THE APPLE TREE
THING PLEASE. SB THREE FORTY
THREE THANK YOU THINK NOTHING'S
GOING. ON AND WE LINE. THIRTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON HERE
SEVENTY MORE WHILE I MAY HAVE A
AND THE- THANK YOU. WELL TO GET
INTO WE HAVE MY NUMBER ONE OKAY
THAT'S. ONE TEN. YEAH OKAY MY
NUMBER ONE HANG BY NOON OPEN.
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE SEVEN
TWO THAT'S FINE ONE TWO. GOOD
MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
THE LEAD SPONSOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY THREE YOU NEED TO PUSH.
ONE ZERO. HELLO WE HAVE THE
COMING FROM LINE OF ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN I CAN DO ABOUT IT WOULD
COMPUTER BUT NOW I'M ON BOTH
THE- BY NUMBER. ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN. THE PROJECT BECAUSE IT
GETS LIKE THAT THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF LOS IN ORDER
RIGHT. EFFECT SUPPORTING HAD
THANK. IF NOT OKAY THANK YOU TO
OUR AND WE DON'T THE LINE OF
ONE EIGHT SEVEN NINE THAT ONE
SEVEN NINE. FOR NUMBER SHOOTING
US AND I'LL BE OF THE TEAM AND-
THANK YOU. CAN WE ONE NUMBER.
ONE FOUR. THE NEW CHRISTOPHER
TO WITH CORE THIS FOR A WHERE
IS READ AND YOU IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAN WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER. ONE
THREE EIGHT ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
PREFERRED TO TALK ON BEHALF OF
STOP IN CALIFORNIA PRODUKTER
SHIFTER FOR THE PART YEAH.
THANK YOU. HELLO AND AT THE
TIME DO NOT HAVE ANYMORE IN
SUPPORT IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
BUT A MODERATOR NOW THOSE IN
OPPOSITION AS THEY WANT TO GET
IN THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING NONE ON THE PHONE. BUT A
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD QUEUE UP
THOSE WHO ARE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION THERE'S A
LEAD- OPPONENT THE CREATIVE.
YEAH MORE HER GOAL FIRST. OKAY
AND IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
YOU WOULD PUSH ONE ZERO. AND
IT'LL BE JUST ONE MOMENT. WE
DON'T KNOW. SORRY ABOUT A
MODERATOR YOU CUT LINE A. I
VERY ANGRY TO LET THE WHOLE
THING DOWN. BECAUSE I CAN'T GET
TO GO. THE WE DO HAVE AN APP WE
HAVE LINE SEVENTEEN PEOPLE HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON NICOLE KIANA ON
BEHALF THE HEALTH INCOME
PRODUCTS AT THE STEVE. THAT
FOOD IN. AND THE NATIONAL AIR
ASSAULT THE IN AKURE. THANK YOU.
AND WE MY NUMBER ONE PICK SEVEN
PLEASE AHEAD. HI GET OUT MR
CHAIRMAN DON'T CAP WITH MAKE
YOU CAPTAIN THAT SOMEHOW CAL
MANUFACTURES AND- ASSOCIATION.
ALL CONDITIONTHANK YOU THANK
YOU YEAH. HEY WE HAVE A NUMBER
FIFTY FOUR MY ONE FIFTY FOUR.
YOUR ANSWER. CARE ARTISTS
AMOUNT THAT SOMEBODY- OF THE
KEY TO ASSOCIATION A THANK YOU
THANK YOU. FOR CAN WE HAVE A
LINE NUMBER ONE SEVENTY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE. G. THANK YOU
CHAIR THE MORE ARE YOU ARE ARE
WITH AMERICAN THE AMERICAN
INSTITUTE PACKAGE IN THE IN.
AND THE FLEXIBLE PACKAGING
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. I REALLY DON'T CARE
WE DO NOT ANY AFTER IN THE
QUEUE THANK YOU MEMORY LIVE
BRING IT BACK TO THE CHAIN.
QUESTIONS ARE. I SEE NO MICHAEL
REYES- BUT MR WACO CENTER
WORKOUTS HE MOVED THE BILL. A
CASKET MOVES THE BILL SENATE
ALLEN THE CARE TO CLOSE. I JUST
RESPECT RESTAURANT VOTED
REGIONAL SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- BENSHI CANCEL THE
CALL THE ROLL HI THIS IS SB
THREE FORTY THREE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE. AMBER I PURCHASE. FORTY
NOT VOTE COLORADO. GARRIDO I
AIDED US HI THE DRESS SO I WENT
ON. GONZALEZ HERTZBERG. JONES
LAYER HI LAYERED ICE. HE'S
TRYING STERN HI WAKO SKI. OUR
WORK I'D WINNER. WE AYE A SIX
YOU HAVE A EIGHT ZERO SO FAR
ALREADY WHAT WILL KEEP MATTER
ON CALL NEXT- IS CENTER THE
ROSSO'S SB SIXTY TWO. AND ALSO
IF YOU IF YOU CHOOSE TO PRESENT
FROM YOUR DESK THAT'S FINE. SO
THANK YOU SIR THAT ALSO CENTER
ALSO I KNOW YOU WORKED VERY
HARD ON THIS BILL IS A
PASSIONATE ISSUE OF PASSIONATE
CONCERN. SO YOU MAY PROCEED.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AT CAMP YEAH.
SURE SURE SURE REPUBLICAN SEN
RUSSELL ONE SECOND. SHE ALL
RIGHT SO THE REST OF GO AHEAD
THANK YOU I WANT THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS OF SB SIXTY TWO AND
YOUR THOUGHTFUL ENGAGEMENT
RESEARCHER ON THE BILL I ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED ON
PAGE SIXTEEN OF THE ANALYSIS
AND I WANT TO THANK SENATORS
HERTZBERG AND GONZALEZ FROM THE
COMMITTEE FOR BEING CAUGHT
THERE'S- MANY MEN AND WOMEN WHO
DO ESSENTIAL WORK FOR ECONOMY
HAVE NOW BECOME MORE VISIBLE
THEY ARE HIGHLY SKILLED
PROFESSIONALS PRODUCING
PROTECTIVE MASKS ANOTHER PP.
UNFORTUNATELY OFTEN MAKING AS
LITTLE AS FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR
DESTRUCTIONS TO THE GLOBAL
SUPPLY CHAIN FROM THIS PANDEMIC
HAVE ACTUALLY MOTIVATED
COMPANIES TO SET UP SHOP IN LOS
ANGELES FOR THE BENEFIT OF THIS
SKILLED LABOR BRANDS ARE
REALISING ADVANTAGE OF A STRONG
DOMESTIC MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY
IN REDUCING REDUCING RISKS AND
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH INVENTORY
SHIPPING AND OVERSIGHT 65% OF
RETAILERS HAVE DECIDED HAVE
DECIDED THE ANSWER TO THESE
RISKS IS BY ESTABLISHING OR
EXPANDING DOMESTIC
MANUFACTURING YET. IN MANY WAYS
OUR STATE HAS FALLEN BEHIND IN
PROTECTIONS FOR THOSE VERY
WORKERS- GLOBALLY GARMENT
WORKERS AT ONE TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS FROM BRANDS WHO
HAD INITIALLY REFUSED TO PAY
FOR CONTRACTED WORK AS THE
LARGEST INDUSTRY OF ITS KIND IN
THE UNITED STATES THE APPAREL
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY IN L. A.
COUNTY ALONE PRODUCES FOUR
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
OUTPUT. LESS ANGELES HAS THE
HIGHEST CONCENTRATION OF THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY FOR SOME TWO
THOUSAND GARMENT MANUFACTURERS
EMPLOYED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE MOSTLY IMMIGRANT WOMEN.
WHO ARE CUTTING AND SEWING
DYEING CLOTHING FROM DESIGNER
JEANS TO FAST FASHION. RUNWAY
TO FAST MASKS ANOTHER PP IS
MORALLY AND ECONOMICALLY WRONG
FOR CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO
DENY GARMENT WORKERS THERE FOR
A WEEK FAIR WAGES FORCING THEM
TO RELY ON A STATE. RESTITUTION
FUND ON THE BRINK OF INSOLVENCY
IT'S NOT JUST A FEW BAD ACTORS.
IT WILL- THE MORE FOR CEMENT
WILL HELP. IN FACT WHICH THAT
THE SOMEONE TRENCH THROUGHOUT
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY THE
RESTITUTION FUND HAS BEEN
OVERWHELMED WITH CLAIMS. AND
HAS BEEN BACK FILLED WITH
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS JUST TO
KEEP UP. TAXPAYERS SHOULD NOT
BE SUBSIDIZING STOLEN WAGES AND
SWEATSHOP CONDITIONS SB SIXTY
TWO MAKES CLEAR THAT A BUSINESS
CONTRACTING TO HAVE GARMENTS
MADE. IS LIABLE FOR UNPAID
MINIMUM WAGE AND OVERTIME. TO
THE WORKERS WHO MANUFACTURE THE
GARMENTS- THAT'S THE WAY IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE THIS BILL WILL
END THE DE FACTO WAGE CAR ABOUT
IN THE GARMENT INDUSTRY WHICH
ALLOWS WERE- MANUFACTURERS TO
PAY WORKERS. BY THE PEAS OR
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS PIECE RATE-
BASICALLY COLLEAGUES WE ARE
BACK TO THE DAYS OF THE
NINETEEN ELEVEN SURE TRIANGLE
SHIRTWAIST. FIRE CONDITIONS IN
NEW YORK MANUFACTURERS HAVE NO
INCENTIVE TO ENSURE SAFE
CONDITIONS. OR THE PROPER
MINIMUM WAGE PAYMENTS UNLESS
THEY FACE LIABILITY THESE
WORKPLACE FILED OF VIOLATIONS-
DEEPLY AFFECT OUR VULNERABLE
WORKERS AND THE RESILIENCY OF
THE COMMUNITIES THEY LIVE IN.
IS LUKE LEGAL LOOPHOLES HAVE
MANY MAINSTREAM INDUSTRY
ACTUALLY HOSTILE. TO ETHICAL
GARMENT COMPANIES TRYING TO
ELIMINATES WORKSHOPS BUILD AN
INCLUSIVE AND FAIR GARMENT
INDUSTRY ECONOMY AND ENSURE
THAT WHEN WE USE THE TERM MADE
IN THE USA. THAT ACTUALLY
REPRESENTS QUALITY AND JUSTICE
THAT IS WHY THIS PAST YEAR MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED FASHION
ORGANIZATIONS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES. IN THE INDUSTRY
HAVE JOINED OUR EFFORTS TO
PASSED SB SIXTY TWO I AM PROUD
THAT THIS BILL IS A LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS PARTY BILL AS
WELL. TODAY WE HAVE TWO EXPERTS
ON THE WITNESS LINE GARMENT
WORKER ANOTHER LUCILLE'S AND-
AS WELL AS MATTHEW DO CARLESS
FROM BIDS ATTIC TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SENATOR- AND
IT IS HUMAN THAT MISS ON A DE
LOS RIOS IS ON THE PHONE AND
TESTIFYING IN SPANISH WITH MISS
DAISY GONZALEZ TRANSLATING IS
THAT RIGHT. YES ALL RIGHT BOB
MRS BILLS WILL SECURE AVAILABLE.
YOU MAY PROCEED. RIGHT HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- THIS IS ALEX CHANGES
FROM THE GOVERNMENT AND I WILL
BE TRANSLATING BROWN OF BILLS
OR YOUR PARTY THANK YOU SIR NOT.
BUT SHE- SHE- OKAY WHEN I. WE
ARE NOT IN FINAL DEAL WITH THE
WHEN THEY SEE WHY NOT VERY
VALUABLE I DON'T KNOW TO AFTER
THREE THREE DANIEL SAID PRESS
MICHAEL SILVA. THEY ARE NOT.
BED WHAT PEOPLE OF THE DAY. ONE
MILLION THREE MANN ELEVEN UP
FOR ME AND SEE MY THERE'S A LOT.
ARE NOT. AVAILABLE VALUE
ACCORDING TO WATER. FORGET
ABOUT HOW MUCH SPACE BY
RANDOMLY BOOKLET. LOS RIGHT NOW
DEEP UP I LOOKED A WHOLE BUT I
MEAN THAT. NOW YOU CAN GET THE
DONE. SO WHAT DOES- I HAVE
WORKED IN GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DONNA WILL BE AND I'M
FIVE YEARS OLD I'VE WORKED IN
THE GARDEN INDUSTRY THIRTY.
THIRTY YEARS ALL OF CAL GUARD.
WE PRO AND MAKE GOOD SALARIES.
FOR HUNDREDS OF HUNDRED DOLLARS
MORE GET ON YOUR LEVEL I MEAN
WAS ABOUT THE MINIMUM WAGE. BUT
THE CAR OF LIVING WITH AT THE-
TO WORK. ARE FORTY HOURS AT ON
TOP IF YOU WANT WORKS- SIXTY. A
WEEK WAS BOUGHT. BACK THEN. WE
JUST OVER FACTORY WITH ALL THE
PERMITS THIS. FROM THE- AFTER
ABOUT THREE YEARS WE HAD A COLD
TO DO THAT BECAUSE THE BRANDS
OF THE COMPANY. FOR PAYING TOO
LITTLE FOR PRODUCTION. THERE
WERE NO PROFIT AND THERE WASN'T
ENOUGH MONEY TO PAY OUR
EMPLOYEES OR RENT. IT WILL THE
TOTAL CHANGE FOR US. WE CLOSE
DOWN AND STARTED THE POINT
AGAIN. CNN SOME OF THE BEST
SOME OF THE OTHER YOU KNOW THE
MORE CUENTA QUE GET PARA FOR S.
I FEEL THAT I'M BACK. I DON'T
SEE AN APPLE THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE A CRIMINAL LAST THEY DON'T
WANNA PLAY. HELLO THREE TWO
DELIVER A LOT BY LISTEN DOUBLE
DON'T GET. I SAID IF YOU WANT
PS. MARK ON THE ADULT. HI THIS
IS A MESSAGE IN OUR POSTED
MINOR BUT I FORGOT FOR THE LAST.
BUT HE HAD ME THAT BETTER NOT
BE SEE AN FACT THE FUTURE IS
ALREADY. HERE NOT REALLY BUT I
HAD A PEOPLE. YOU CAN ASK ABOUT
HOW TO FIX IT NOTHING. THEY
NEED A LITTLE MONICA VALLEY FOR
MORE OUT. WHAT DOES HE- THINK.
WE'VE NOTICED A PIECE TREE
COULD ARE AND WERE SEVERE IT
WAS LOW IN A SITUATION LIKE
THAT FROM ALITY HI ALL. THE
OVERLOOKED SEWING MACHINE AND
OR HAVE TO TEACH PAINTING
FOURTEEN AND- I GARMENTS DO I
HAVE TO SORT TO MAKE ME WAGE.
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY WHICH
BE PART IN A HOUR WORK. JUST TO
MAKE A HUNDRED TWENTY ALL WHICH
IS THE MINIMUM. IT'S NOW BEEN
FIFTEEN TWENTY YEARS IN THE
SPEECH AND SAME AND THE WAY
HAVE NOT. YOU HAVE TO WORK TO
SEVENTY A WEEK SEVENTY A WEEK
TO MAKE SURE. UP TWO HUNDRED TO
THREE SEVENTY FIVE. OR FOUR
HUNDRED ON YOUR SPEED AND SKILL
LEVEL. BECAUSE CAL IS NOT HIGH
AND NOT A TO WRITE. HE CRISIS.
REAL YEAH GOOD BONTA- I THINK
WE NEXT ARE GOING TO- MATTHEW
DAE CARLENE US IS. THIS MISTER
CARLOS CARL ON THE PHONE. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M UNIQUE SAID
THANK YOU MISTER ON MEMBER.
SIMON ATTORNEY THAT WERE A NON
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATION THAT HAS
REPRESENTED HUNDREDS THE
GARMENT WORKERS OVER THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS WORK PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR SB SIXTY TWO. IN OUR
WORK WE HAVE SEEN OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WHAT IS- THE LOS RIOS
DESCRIBES SO POWERFULLY. AND
ETHICAL BUSINESSES HAVE SEEN IT
TOO WHICH IS WHY AS SENATOR
ALSO MENTIONED SO MANY GARMENT
INDUSTRY BUSINESSES SUPPORT
THIS BILL TO PROTECT WORKERS.
TO ELIMINATE SWEATSHOPS IN TO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD. AS
ACADEMIC RESEARCH AND
GOVERNMENT STUDIES HAVE MADE
CLEAR ABUSE OF THE PIECE RATE
IS ONE THE ROOT CAUSES OF THE
WIDE. WAGE THEFT THAT PLAGUES
THIS INDUSTRY. THE PIECE RATE
DISCUSSES HOW LOW THE PAY IS TO
MAKE SOME FOR SOME MORE
DIFFICULT BY COMPLICATING THE
WAGE CALCULATIONS. IT ALSO
CAUSES HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROBLEMS WHICH ARE ESPECIALLY
ACUTE DURING THIS PANDEMIC IT'S
WORKERS HAVE TO RACE TO
COMPLETE AS MANY ITEMS. AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND THEY DO
NOT GET PAID TIME TO SANITISE
OUR WORKSTATIONS WATER WASHED
THEIR HANDS. IN ADDITION THE UP
CHAIN COMPANIES THAT USE
SUBCONTRACTING HAVE THEIR
CLOTHING MADE AN UNLAWFUL
CONDITIONS ARE NOT HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. THESE BRANDS ARE
INCENTIVIZE TO CONTRACT WITH
THE LOWEST BIDDER. MANY OF WHOM
ARE ONLY ABLE TO BID SO LOW
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT PAYING
WORKERS MINIMUM WAGE. HOW
HOLDING BRANDS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE ROLE THEY PLAY IN THE
PRODUCTION CHAIN WILL
INCENTIVIZE THEM TO PAY FOR
GOODS AT PRICES COMMENSURATE
WITH WORKERS EARNING THE
MINIMUM WAGE. ELIMINATING THE
PIECE RATE SYSTEM WILL PREVENT
MANUFACTURERS FROM SELLING
THEIR PAY SO LOW THAT IT'S-
ESSENTIALLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
WORKERS TO MAKE THE MINIMUM
WAGE. THIS BILL IS TARGETED AND
ONLY IMPACTS COMPANIES THAT
CONTRACT TO HAVE GARMENT
DESIGNED OR MANUFACTURED. AND
AS LONG AS A CURRENT A LOOPHOLE
TO EXISTING PORTION IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO COMBAT THE
ENTRENCHED PATTERN OF
WIDESPREAD WAGE AND HOUR
VIOLATIONS. THE TIMES COME TO
FULLY REALIZE THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF AB SIX THIRTY THREE.
TO CLOSE LOOPHOLES THAT THE
GARMENT INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
HAS EVOLVED TO EXPLOIT FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR BOB DALLAS TURNED
TO THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE WAS
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF IT SB
SIX TO THE GARRULOUS TURNED
ROOM ONE TWELVE NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. SOLD MATAMATA
RAIDER- AS WE QUEUE UP THOSE
WHO ARE WAITING ON THE PHONE TO
TESTIFY LET ME REMIND THOSE ON
THE PHONE. TO KEEP THEIR
DEVICES ON MUTE UNTIL YOU ARE.
ON THE LINE OTHERWISE WE'LL GET
FEEDBACK. SO MATTER MODERATOR
IT IF WE COULD HAVE THOSE WHO
ARE ON THE LINE. IN SUPPORT
BEGIN THE TESTIMONY I REMIND
YOU ALSO NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AND WE WILL GO TO THE
FIRST LINE OF ONE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. APPLE GONNA
FIND A. ONE NINETY THREE. HERE
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CAP AGAIN OFTEN
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IS STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL SB SIX TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT ONE WILL GO TO
THE ONE NINETY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE NUMBERS
CHRISTOPHER SPONSORS WHAT THE
CENTER AMONG PARTY OR TRY TO BE
A LOCAL SPONSORS. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO VOTER LINE OR ONE
NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU RENEE
BAYARDO WITH AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GIVE EXTRA CAROLINE
TO ALL THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
AIR IMPACT FROM THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS OF A LINE OF
TWO OH FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THE
MALLORY BUT WORKING FROM PUBLIC
COUNCIL LAW CENTER IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO TO ALIGN ONE
NINETY EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS DADDY FOR A WHILE
WE GET THE W. WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
A LITTLE LINE ONE SEVENTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS BILL
OR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS OF A LINE OF
ONE NINETY NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR P. CALMLY WITH THE
L. A. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TEXACO
LINE OF ONE THIRTY EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON REFORM COMMON FEAR
CLUB CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIX OF
THE LINE OF TWO ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU FOR
CHAIRED MEMBERS THE SUBJECT
WINDSHIELD ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RELIGIOUS ACTION
CENTER OF REFORM JUDAISM AND
THE JEWISH COALITION INSISTING
REFUGEES AND IMMIGRANTS LOS
ANGELES STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. VOCAL LINE UP
TO SIXTEEN. THAT AFTERNOON THAT
COULD LEAD BEARING WITH THE
PUBLIC LAST CENTER IN ORANGE
COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU THANK
THANKS OF A LINE OF ONE
EIGHTEEN. YES HI THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STEVEN KNIGHT
WITH WORK SAFE HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK UP IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU. IN THE
NEXT OVER THE LINE OF THE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. HI THIS IS DAVID
ANOTHER THE GARMENT WORKER
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
I'VE ALSO SUPPORTED SOME
WORKERS TO CONNECTING GET
PUBLIC COMMENT. HE LEARNED. THE
LONDON. HE WENT. ALIENATING HER
SO REMEMBER WHERE OR ANOTHER
RESIDENTIAL STUDENTS HE. IT
ALSO OF THEM I DON'T. WE HAD
NINETY IF IT IS A NUMBER YOU
DON'T WANT CATCH THANK YOU.
UNDER ON BEHALF OF EQUAL RIGHTS
ADVOCATES AND THE STRONGER
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES NETWORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS OF A LINE OF
ONE SIXTY EIGHT. CHEN MEMBERS
CATALINA SANCHEZ THE CARBON AND
HYDE THERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SIX OF OUR LINE- TWO EIGHTY.
ONE ON ONE OH NINE LOCAL LINE
ONE OH NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MADISON DO COSTS WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK.
THANK. TO FOURTEEN. THE MORNING
THE PRINTER CAL POLY COURAGE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU- MEMORIES IF I COULD%
GET- S. VIN NUMBER OF THOSE WHO
ARE ON THE LINE RIGHT NOW IN
SUPPORT- ERIC. I'M SORRY MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE TWENTY N. Q.
OKAY THANK YOU. WELCOME THANK
YOU ORDER LINE UP TO SEVENTY
THE LINES OPEN I. HI THIS IS
EVAN MEN CAN REPLACE IT FOR
PROGRESS CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
pTHANK YOU. THANK YOU HELLO LINE
OF. TWO TWENTY. TURN ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA INSTRUCT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND LINE. ONE SEVENTY
TWO. NINE ONE SEVEN TWO YOUR
LINES OPEN YOU HAVE A SUMMIT.
THANK YOU ON THE TO THE-
EASTBOUND DIRECT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANKS OF A LINE OF ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS DIRECTOR OF ERA OF
THE CONTAINABLE FASHION LABEL
AIR SUBPOENA I AM A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR A LINE OF ONE SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURGLARY SO YOSHIHARU ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THE LINE UP. TO NINETEEN. HELLO
THIS IS RAY THOMAS I'M THE
PRESIDENT OF THE FIVE COUNTY
CENTRAL LABOR COUNCIL AND WE
WANT TO SHARE OUR STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY TWO. THANK
YOU. THANKS OF A LINE OF TWO
FIFTEEN. HI BETTER ACCESS ON
THE FOUNDER- THE OF THE LOS
ANGELES MADE OUT OF A LUXURY
BRAND. ON THE BOARD AT THE AT
THE VERY IMPORTANT HELP THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR A
LINE OF TWO TEN. NATIONALISTIC
FEELINGS YOU MIGHT EVEN CALLING
FROM LONG BEACH ON BEHALF OF
CASH REVOLUTION USA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY TWO AS WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AN ETHICAL.
PETER FOR FASHION AND THIS IS A
CRITICAL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MEXICANA. ONE NINETY
SEVEN. LINE ONE NINETY SEVEN
YOUR LINES OPEN YOU HAVE A TIME
YOU. MEXICO LINE OF ONE AT
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE BENEFIT OF
THE STATE SENIOR ORGANIZER WITH
LOS ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR YOU
ECONOMY AND WE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU OF A
LINE OF TO ALL ONE. I COULD
BRING HIM POLICY ADVOCATES
BACHELOR TAX REFORM IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO THE LINE OF NINETY
NINE. NOTHING MEANS HERE
MEMBERS BETWEEN A CAR WHICH ON
BEHALF OF REMAKING AT THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER MYSELF I. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THANKS OF THE
LINE UP TO TWENTY FIVE. YES YOU
CAN MEMBERS PANORAMA PERRIN
READING ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING
TO ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEE
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ON THE LINE UP TO TWENTY
EIGHT. UNDER WATER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK LIKE CIRCLE LINE OF TWO
OH NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS LINDSAY METAL THE WAY
TO SHOP IN SUPPORT OF BILL
SIXTY IF YOU WERE A FACTORY IN
FROGTOWN PRODUCING FOR BRANDS
LIKE PATAGONIA AND RENOWNED
CLEVELAND CLINIC AND PEOPLE ARE
ATTACHED. THANK YOU. NEXT ON
THE LINE OF ONE TWENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINES OPEN DO
YOU HAVE A SON YOU. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MEXICO LINE OF- TO
TWENTY THREE. HELLO THIS IS
KEVIN IN SCOPE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
SIX OF THE LINE OF TWO THIRTY
ONE. THEY DROPPED MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO OTHER SUPPORTING
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH LET'S NOT TURN THE
OPPOSITION IS THERE A PRIMARY
WITNESS ON THE PHONE LINE WELL
LET ME ASK ABOUT THOSE IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE OF THE
GALLERIST WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. NOW ROOM ONE
TWELVE. I SEE KNOWN IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHICH INTENSIFIED
OPPOSITION LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES BUT A MODERATOR IF
THERE'S A PRIMARY WITNESS
IDENTIFIED IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE- WITH THEM ON NOW.
AIRLINES ARE OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS SCOTT WILSON ON THE
PRESIDENT USE TRIED
MANUFACTURING I REPRESENT EIGHT
CUTTING SEWING FACILITY
DYTISCIDAE GENUS OF SCREEN
EMBROIDERY FACILITY HERE
LOCATED IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA. BEEN IN BUSINESS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY YEARS I
OPPOSE THIS BILL FOR THE REASON
IS WE ALREADY HAVE. LAWS IN
PLACE THAT- PROTECT THE PEACE
WORKING AT THE MINIMUM WAGE
ALREADY I HAVE EIGHT FACTORY
FULL OF EMPLOYEES HAVE BRAND
NEW CARS DUE TO THE EXISTING
LAWS ALREADY IN PLACE. BACTRIS
WHO ARE ILLEGAL ARE GOING TO
REMAIN ILLEGAL IN THIS WILL
FURTHER DRIVE GETTING INTO THE-
UNDERGROUND THE ETHICAL
FACTORIES EIGHTEEN ALREADY THE
PEACE CORPS THAT EQUALS OR
EXCEEDS THE MINIMUM WAGE FOR
EXAMPLE I HAVE AN OPERATOR
WHO'S VERY SKILLED. AND HE IS
IN HE IS SKILLED AT SINGLE
NEEDLE IN THE SET LIPPER'S FOR
US ON SPECIFIC PROJECTS. THIS
OPERATOR BECAUSE OF HIS SKILL
LEVEL LEVEL MAKES FIVE POINT
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR. IF
WE WERE TO PUT HIM AT- A
FIFTEEN DOLLAR OUR WAGE
ELIMINATE HIS SKILL BASICALLY
TAKES HIS HEEL AND WIPES IT OUT
SO I EITHER HAVE TO REDUCE HIS
HEY OR I HAVE TO BRING UP THE
OTHER WORKERS BECAUSE- IT
HAPPEN EVEN NOW. THAT'S NUMBER
ONE NUMBER TWO IS THERE'S NO
REASON TO TAKE ON WORK THAT
DOESN'T. PAY FOR YOUR FACTORY.
THERE WHEN WE GET IT A CUSTOMER
THE CUSTOMER FOR EXAMPLE I HAVE
A LARGE CHILDREN'S BRAND A
CONTACT AS HE SAID THERE'S A
SAMPLE. WE AGREE ON PRICING WE
COUNTER THAT SAMPLE TO COME OUT
EXACT COSTS WE ALL AGREE ON A
PRICE ONESTEP PRICES SET THE
MANUFACTURERS IF THE PRICES
BELOW AN OPERATING OR A
PROFITABLE MARGIN WE DON'T
ACCEPT THE WORK. THANK YOU SIR
THIS. BACK. THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU. METAMODEL IF THERE'S
ANOTHER WITNESS AND OPPOSITION-
WILL PROVIDE TWO MINUTES. YES
THIS IS ELTON THAT CHECK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FASHIONISTAS THE
ASIAN. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU. AND I ON WHICH TO
BUILD THE MEASURE YES YES YOUR
HONOR. THANK YOU- WE APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT YOU UNDERSTAND
HOW LARGER INDUSTRY AS WE DO
WITH THAT THE CHARACTERIZATION
THAT THE ENTIRE INDUSTRY.
WELCOME. EIGHTY SIX THIRTY
THREE WHICH WE ARE IN SUPPORT-
THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS
APPAREL MAKERS MADE NO USE OF
THE GOVERNMENT ILLEGAL ACTIVITY
AND AS A MATTER OF FACT YOU.
BECAUSE THEY'RE UNFAIR
COMPETITION THEY HAD POINTS OUT
ON YOUR PAGE AT THE END OF LINE
TWENTY. YOU ARE MAKING HISTORY.
AND SPIDER MAN AND- ANYONE ELSE
HAS ANY OF THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMPANIES MAKING MERCHANDISE
HERE LIABLE FOR THE
INFRACTIONS. OF ANY CONTRACTOR.
THAT MAY BE USING THOSE PLANS
INCORRECTLY. YOUR ALSO
INCLUDING THE PEOPLE WHO SIX
MAPLE. PLEASE UNDERSTAND THAT
SOMETIMES THE LABELS ARE SIX
AFTER THE PRODUCT IS MADE FOR
PRIVATE LABEL COMPANIES AND
THEN NOT EVEN MADE OF SIX IN
FACT THEY OPEN DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEMS. MY QUESTION THEN IS.
UNDER OR- THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING INFRACTIONS ARE
CONTRACTING WHAT MAKES YOU
THINK THEY WILL IDEA TO THE NEW
LAW. THE NEW LAW CAN SEARCH A
WIDE NET. TAT OUR MAJOR
RETAILERS AND RETAILERS THAT
NOW I'M LOOKING TO CALIFORNIA
TO MAKE PRODUCT. WILL NOT THEY
ARE GOING TO BE CASH ON THE
DISH NET. WE HAVE A COMPLIANCE
MANUAL THAT WE'VE BEEN PUTTING
OUT FOR FIFTEEN YEARS BY THE
WAY CALIFORNIA'S FASHIONISTAS
NATION IT DIDN'T THERE SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY SIX. AND WHEN I
SAY THANK YOU MISTER. BACTRIM
CONTRACT YOU SHOULD KNOW THE
LAW THANK THERE WAS NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO KNOW
THE LAW. THANK YOU- SO BETTER
MODERATE AND THINK ONE THING
ONE DAY THIS BUDGET HEARING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISMATCH
AND GOVERNMENT JOB THANK YOU ON
THE MENU PLAN A MODERATOR IF WE
NOW TURN TO THE PHONE LINES-
AND IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION-
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME. AS WELL
AS YOUR AFFILIATION. DO YOU
CHOOSE AND YOUR POSITION. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO A
LINE OF TWO THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MEXICO LINE
OF A. TWO TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH LLOYD DATE NOT BE
OUT OF CALIFORNIA MADE BACK TO
THE TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS A LOT OF ONE NINETY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ACTUALLY HOW
OFTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY TO
THE JOB KILLER I'M ALSO CALLING
IT TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WHICH IS IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AND COULD NOT BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU. Q. THANK
YOU. THE NEXT OVER A LINE OF
ONE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS WRANGLING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FOR THE OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THE TIME THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR AND- I REALIZE
THAT THERE ARE OTHERS THAT ARE.
WAITING TO TESTIFY AND OTHER
BILLS JUST A REMINDER THAT EACH
SIDE WILL BE AFFORDED TO
WITNESSES FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
ALL RIGHT LET'S BRING IT BACK
HERE TO THE CHAMBER- I SEE NO
OF SILICON SAID EXHAUSTIVE
QUESTION A COMMON YES I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO SENATOR
THAT ALSO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I KNOW SHE'S BEEN
WORKING ON THIS FOR SOME TIME
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- AND
THEN IF I CAN SAY A FEW THINGS
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO SEE
SOMETHING JUST REAL BRIEFLY IN
SPANISH IF I MAY. I GET OF THE
MATTER IS THAT BOOK BEFORE IT
COULD BE THAT PART OF THAT AS
AN ASSISTANT THE LEVELS THAT
ARE FOR THE LOTUS GANDERBAL
TESTIMONY AND THE OTHER WAY. IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAT GUESSES
COACHING SUCCESS STORY AS A
PRACTICE THAT IS SUBTLE BUT I
LOOK AT ASSET INCOME YOUR DRIVE
IS THE LADY SB SIXTY TWO SYSTEM
BY THOSE. SILLY THAT I SCHOOL
ON A U. THAT'LL EXPLAIN IT
LET'S INCLUDES THE CSX BEEN.
AGGRESSIVE ADDRESSES AS ANOTHER
AT MY DEAL AND I WOULD ALSO YET
THOSE FORCES WILL SO HE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATE GONZALEZ
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS TO
SEE NO OTHER MICROPHONES REYES-
SAID THERE ALSO IS A MOTION.
SET A GOOD. MOVES THE BILL.
SAID ALSO WOULD LIKE CLOSE. IS
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF MANAGE ACCOUNTS YOU CALL
ROLL HI THIS IS A B.SIXTY-
MOVED BY MOTION BYSENATOR
GONZALEZ.THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
THEN REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE.
NUMBER AYE BURGESS. COLORADO
COLORADO I DID ALSO. GET US SO
I GONZALEZ. CLOSE OTHERS AYE
HERTZBERG. JONES AIRED FIVE
LAYERED ICE STERN. STERN AYE A
WEIGHT CAL SKI WORKOUTS SKI I
WIENER WIENER AYE. YOU HAVE
EIGHT ZERO SO FAR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR RUSSELL PUT
THE BILL ON CALL. ALL RIGHT.
NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR EGGMAN. I
SEE THAT- CENTER EGGMAN HAS
BEEN WAITING EXTREMELY
PATIENTLY IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER PRESENT SB FIVE OH
SEVEN LET ME ASK IF YOU ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON- IN
THE NELSON PAGE NINE TEN YES I
DO ALL RIGHT. THE REAGAN THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CARE AND SENATORS I'M
PRESENTING TODAY BUT A BILL SB
FIVE OH SEVEN THAT WILL MAKE
REVISIONS TO LAURA'S LAW BASED
ON THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
STATE AUDITOR'S IN LAST YEAR'S
BILL PS REPORT- AND THIS HAS TO
DO. WITH THE ANNOUNCES TO MAKE
CLEAR A PERSON. THE SUBJECT OF
A HEARING MAINTAINED THE RIGHT
TO APPEAR IN COURT IN PERSON IF
THEY CHOOSE. TWO MINUTES STATE-
FOUND THAT INDIVIDUALS EXITING
INVOLUNTARY HOLDS HAVE NOT BEEN
ENROLLED CONSISTENTLY IN
SUBSEQUENT CARE TO HELP THEM
TRANSITION SAFELY INTO THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND KEEP THEM
CONNECTED TO VITAL RESOURCES.
ROUGHLY ONE IN FOUR PEOPLE
PLACED IN CONSERVATORSHIP CYCLE
BACK TO RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS.
DESPITE HAVING SUCCESSFULLY
RECOVERED THEIR ABILITY TO CARE
FOR THEIR BASIC NEEDS WHEN THEY
EXITED THE CONSERVATORSHIP.
UNDER THE CURRENT LAW TO
QUALIFY FOR A. O. T. A PERSON'S
CONDITION MUST BE SUBSTANTIALLY
DETERIORATING THIS CRITERIA
ESSENTIALLY PROHIBITS THOSE
EXITING MORE REASON RESTRICTIVE
TREATMENT SETTINGS FROM
ACCESSING A. O. T. EVEN WHEN
THEY MAY BENEFIT FROM THE
SERVICES. THIS BILL REVISES
ELIGIBILITY. REQUIREMENTS THAT
APPEARS REASONABLY LIKELY THAT
THEY WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT
RISKS FOR DETERIORATION BASED
ON THEIR TREATMENT HISTORY AND
CURRENT BEHAVIOR WE WANT
COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO OFFER
AND PROVIDE IT WITH T. PROGRAMS
THAT WILL PROVIDE CONTINUED
TREATMENT ACCESS TO RESOURCES
TO KEEP THEM N THEIR
COMMUNITIES. AND NOT HAVE TO GO
BACK INTO CONSERVATORSHIP. THIS
BILL WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE EXAM
OR TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
WHETHER THE DEFENDANT HAS THE
CAPACITY TO GIVE INFORMED
CONSENT REGARDING PSYCHOTROPIC
MEDICATIONS. WE KNOW THAT HE
WANTS TO TAKE MEDICATIONS IS A
CRUCIAL COMPONENT TO AN
INDIVIDUAL'S RECOVERY. AND
CURRENT LAW EXPLICITLY
PROHIBITS AOTI PLANTS FROM
INCLUDING INVOLUNTARY
MEDICATION. ALLOWING THE EXAM
OR TO DISCUSS THE SUBJECT OF
MEDICATIONDURING HEARING IS A
STEP TOWARDS. INITIATING A
DIALOGUE ABOUT THE PATIENT
CAPACITY TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY NEED MEDICATION.
ESTABLISHING THIS CONVERSATION
DURING THE HEARING WILL ALSO
ENSURE THAT IS DOCUMENTED IN
THE PATIENT'S MEDICAL FILE.
WHICH CAN THEN BE REFERENCED
DURING FUTURE MEDICATION
COMPLIANCE CONVERSATIONS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS.
FINALLY THE BILL INCORPORATES A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE AUDITOR
TO ALLOW APPEARANCES. BEFORE
THE COURT FOR TESTIMONY BY BY
THE EXAMINING MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDER BY VIDEO CONFERENCING.
THEY'RE NOT CALLED OUT IN THE
AUDIENCE THE BILL ALSO ALLOWS
FOR THE SUBJECT OF THE PETITION
TO ALSO APPEAR IN THE VIDEO IF
THEY CHOOSE. AND THEY RETAIN
THE RIGHT TO BE PRESENT AT THE
HEARING. SPEND IN THE KITCHEN
IS ALL THAT HAVING THE ABILITY
TO USE TECHNOLOGY TO
COMMUNICATE. IS CRUCIAL WE
WANTED ACCESS TO CONTINUE LONG
AFTER THIS PANDEMIC IS AND- OUR
CRIMINAL HEALTH SYSTEM ISN'T
WORKING YOU ONLY HAVE TO DRIVE
AROUND ANYONE OF OUR MAJOR
CITIES TO UNDERSTAND THIS. I
KNOW THAT MANY OF YOU IN MY
COLLEAGUES IN BOTH HOUSES ARE
WORKING TIRELESSLY ON THIS TO
IMPROVE THE SYSTEM. I TALKED
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
WE ARE EXPERIENCING LAST YEAR
WERE PRESENTING A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX AND WE'RE STILL IN
THAT CRISIS. WITH THE PANDEMIC
IS STILL ONGOING. WE NEED
SOLUTION TO IMPROVE OUR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND RESOURCES.
AOTI WORKS- IT INCREASES THE
OPPORTUNITY IMPROVE ONE'S
QUALITY OF LIFE IT INCREASES
THE CHANCES FOR RECOVERING FOR
THOSE EXPERIENCES SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS. IT SAVES LIVES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE WHEN THE TIME SHOULD
PRESENT ITSELF AND WITH ME
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AS A
SPONSOR RANDALL HAGAR WITH THE
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND KAREN
STANCHFIELD THE DIRECTOR OF A.
O. T. SERVICES HERE TURNING
POINT. IN NORTHERN. NEVADA
COUNTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR EGGMAN- IF MR HAGER IS
ON THE PHONE. WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND TURN THE FLOOR TO HIM. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN SIR. BRANDO USED
ONLINE. HIS SPECIAL TIME YOU
I'M SORRY. RICHARD SHOW MY MIND
HE MIGHT HAVE A TIME YOU. MAYBE
WE SHOULD TURN TO MISS
STANFIELD FIRST OF AND COME
BACK MISTER HAGER. HELLO
ACCORDING TO HAN DYNASTY YOUR
ATTENTION OF THE DIRECTOR DOT
AN AXE SERVICES FOR TURNING
POINT COMMUNITY PROGRAMS THAT
SINCE THEY ARE PATIENT
TREATMENTPROVIDE INTENSIVE
MENTAL HEALTH TREATMENT FOR
PEOPLE WITH SEVERE AND
PERSISTENT PSYCHIATRIC ILLNESS
THAN TIMES REFER TO THOSE
GRANTS MANY. PEOPLE WHO WOULD
NOT OTHERWISE ENGAGE IN
TREATMENT IN THE SECONDARY OF
THEIR ILLNESS. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTIES OBEY OUTCOME
CONSECUTIVELY DEMONSTRATE
REDUCTIONS AND HOSPITALIZATION
QUESTION RATIONS HOMELESSNESS
IN CRISIS CONTACT KIND OF
STEALTH AND NOW THERE'S A GREAT
DISABILITY IN HIS FOR PEOPLE
WHO NEED A NARROW LIST OF
CRITERIA ITSELF THE GAP IN THE
TREATMENT CONTINUUM OF CARE IT
IS PROACTIVE PROVIDING UTILITY
TO MONITOR. JEFF SERVICES
QUICKLY TO PREVENT FURTHER. THE
COMPENSATION. THIS IS THAT WE
TO HIGHER LEVELS. OF RESTRICTED
TO. IN HIS HER DEVELOPMENT LACK
OF IN WITH MINIMAL. TO PHOE.
ENGAGE TREE. THURMOND TERRY
FAIR THERE NOT IN ALTERNATIVE
TO A TEAM AIR RECALL THAT.
THOSE SERVICES HAVE ARE BEEN ON
AND REPEAT REFUSED. I THINK ARE
SIGNIFICANT DIDN'T OF CAR
ASSOCIATED THE STILL- HELLO.
THE UNITED MISTER BILL HAD
COULD DO. OKAY SEE SHORTER LONG
SAY HOSPITAL. THE COST OF THAT
INCARCERATIONS IN AN EMERGENCY
ROOM- UTILIZATION EMERGENCY
CRISIS INTERVENTION ALL OF
THOSE COSTS ARE IN THE NATION
PLEASE NOTE THAT THE ANTI. ANTI
WE CAN SEE WHAT IS POSSIBLE
WHEN WE PROVIDE HELP TO
INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE SUFFERING
AS A RESULT OF UNTREATED SEVERE
PSYCHIATRIC ILLNESS. AOTI WORK
AS THE TRANSITION IT WORKS IN
SUPPORT OF AND SUPPORTING
TREATMENT AS A SAFETY NET IN
TRANSITIONAL- SUPPORT IT SAVES
LIVES IT PROMOTES HOPE AND
RECOVERY WE AND WE SEE. PEOPLE
CAN GET BETTER. ON BEHALF OF
THE FOR MOST VULNERABLE AND
WITH THE NEW HER MENTAL HEALTH
CARE INTERVENTION. I THANK YOU
TODAY THEY GIVE A STANFIELD NOW
IF WE HAVE MISTER HAGER ONLINE.
MISTER HAGER YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WELL IT'S NOT RESPONDING ALL
RIGHT LET'S LOOK LET'S LOOK IN
THE GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY WHICH AND
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ROOM ONE
TWELVE I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE IT MISTER HAGER
APPEARS WILL WILL TAKE HIS
TESTIMONY MOMENT. BUT THE
MEANTIME LET LET'S START WITH
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT HERE
ON THE PHONE LNE IF YOU GIVE
US YOUR NAME AFFILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION. BUT A MODERATE A
FEW OPEN LINES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE OH
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN. ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE UP TO TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
PERSONALLY KEEP US ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANNEX
OF THE LINE OF TWO FORTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JULIE SNYDER
REPRESENTING THE SAME BURKE
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MODERATOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
BECAUSE FOR TO SPELL THANK YOU
THANK CENTER ADMINISTRATOR'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AN EXCELLENT LINE OF ONE OH TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS WILL BE
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORTER SB FIVE OH
SEVEN THANK YOU THEY GIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO MORE SUPPORTING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IS MR HAGER THERE. MR HAGER ARE
YOU WITH US NOW. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NO RESPONSE OUR
INTERCHANGE THAT'S LET'S NOW
TURN TO OPPOSITION- ARE THEIR
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HEARING AND SEEING NONE TURNED
TO THE GALLERY I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THE
GALLERY ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE
NO ONE. SO MANY MODERATE LET'S
TURN TO THE PHONE LINES. THANK
YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE ONE SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE UP TO FORTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER
ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA I WOULD CERTAINLY
OPPOSE THE BILL BUT WE'RE
WORKING WITH A SPONSOR IN
APPRECIATE THE- FEEDBACK THAT
WE'VE RECEIVED SO FAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND ONCE
AGAIN IT'S ONE NINE ZERO FOR
ANY OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE OH
SEVEN. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NUMBER OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER I SEE NO MICROPHONES UP
IN THE CHAMBER- IS THERE A
MOTION. I BELIEVE CENTER WINNER
MOVES THE BILL- SERIGNE YOU%
CARE TO CLOSE I WOULD JUST I
THINK YOU FOR. YOUR ATTENTION
TO THIS- AND ALSO JUST A- MR
HAGAR'S ON BUT APPARENTLY.
CANNOT BE A NEED FOR SOME
REASON TO HOPE OF ANY CAN
RESULT SOME TECHNICAL ISSUES
BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SENATE- ALL RIGHT.
MA'AM SHE CANCELED THE CALL THE
ROLL. A YES FEDERAL MINIMUM.
HOW MUCH MY SENATOR WIENER-
THIS IS SB FIVE A SEVEN MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND THEN RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS I'M
BURKE HI I'M BURKE AYE BURGESS.
AYE WE AT ALL HI CARRIE AT ALL
I DID I SO I DID I SO I
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. JONES LAYERED HI
LAYERED ICE STERN. STERN AYE
STERN AYE A WEIGHT CAL SKI. WHY
CASKEY AYE WIENER. WIENER AYE
YOU HAVE EIGHT. ZERO RIGHT NOW
RT THANK YOU OF. BEFORE WE TURN
THE WHERE TO PUT THE BILL ON
CALL BEFORE WE TURN TO THE NEXT
THE BILL BY SENATOR EGGMAN. LET
ME LET THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING
AND THOSE WHO ARE LISTENING
KNOW THAT SENATE ROTH HIS ****
BECAUSE OF OTHER. COMMITMENTS
THAT WE PLACES BILL LAST SO IF
YOU'RE WAITING TO TESTIFY ON
CENTER ROSS BILL. SB THREE ONE
FIVE SB THREE ONE FIVE. IT'S
GONNA BE QUITE SOME TIME UNTIL
THE BILL'S CALL. ALL RIGHT-
THANK GOODNESS. SERVICE CENTER
EGGMAN NEXT WE'RE GOING TO TURN
TO SB FIVE SIXTEEN. SERIGNE
PLEASURES. I BELIEVE IT'S
WORKING OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- SO IN
FOLLOWING UP FROMTHE OUT
PATIENT BILL THIS KIND OF MOVED
INTO THE INPATIENT SPACE- I'M
PRESENTING AB SB FIVE SIXTEEN A
BILL THAT I THINK IS AN UP TO
ACT AS A NARROW AND VERY
SPECIFIC IMPROVEMENT TO OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM- WELL THE
LAST BILL FOLKS AND OUTPATIENT
THIS IS ABOUT IMPROVING THAT
NEXT LEVEL. UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE PERSON EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS CAN BE
HELD FOR TREATMENT
INVOLUNTARILY IF THEY MEET
CRITERIA TYPICALLY WE THINK
ABOUT THIS AS A FIFTY ONE FIFTY
AND IT'S A FOUR SEVENTY TWO
HOUR HOLD. AND THAT IS OF
SOMEONE BECAUSE OF THEIR DANGER
TO THEMSELVES SOMEBODY ELSE ARE
UNABLE TO PROVIDE FOR BASIC-NEEDS. THEY CAN BE RELEASED OR
HEARING CAN BE HELD TO
DETERMINE WHETHER CONDITION
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL INTENSIVE
CARE THAT INTENSIVE CARE ARE
STILL WHETHER THE PERSON IS
GRAVELY DISABLED OR DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS OR WHETHER
THEY'RE ACCEPTING FURNACES OR
TREATMENT FOR THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITION THIS IS A
CERTIFICATION REVIEW THAT
JUGGLING TYPICALLY HAPPENS.
EITHER BEFORE OR AT LEAST
SEVENTY TWO HOURS. UNDER THIS
BILL HEARING OFFICER WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO CONSIDER
INFORMATION REGARDING A
PERSON'S MEDICAL CONDITION AS
WELL. AND HOW THAT CONDITION
BEARS ON THE CERTIFICATION OF
WHETHER THEIR DANGER TO SELF OR
GRAVELY DISABLED WHEN
DETERMINING. WHETHER TO HOLD
CONTINUE HOLE FOR ADDITIONAL
INTENSIVE TREATMENT. THE BOSTON
PEOPLE ON THE STREET AND VERY
ILL. AND CLEARLY NOT ABLE TO.
THINK RATIONALLY AT THAT POINT-
AND WHILE THEY MAY BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE BASIC NEEDS IF THEY'RE
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION.
PREVENTS THEM FROM BEING ABLE
TO TAKE CARE OF AN ABSCESS OR A
BAD CUT OR- ANY NUMBER OF
THINGS THAT OCCURS TO PEOPLE
WHEN THEY ARE. THEM MENTALLY
ILL AND OFTEN LIVING ON THE
STREETS AND WE SEE EXAMPLES OF
THIS ALL THE TIME. SO THIS
WOULD ADD. A SMALLER ADDITIONAL
CRITERIA NOT EXPANDING THE
AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
INTO THE FIFTY ONE FIFTY. BUT
THOSE THE PEOPLE ARE THERE
BEFORE WE SEND THEM RIGHT BACKOUT AGAIN. PERHAPS WE SHOULD
SEE IF THEY'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE
FOR ALL THEIR NEEDS OR EXTEND
THAT TO A TWO WEEK HOLD- OR-
BEFORE. ANY FURTHER STEPS ARE
TAKEN- CURRENT LAW I WE FEEL
CONTINUES TO ADDRESS PEOPLE
WITH CONSISTENT PERSISTENT
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES THAT ARE.
OFTENTIMES LIVING ON THE
STREETS UNABLE TO PROVIDE FOR
THEMSELVES. AND HAVING RAPID
DETERIORATION OF THEIR HEALTH
CARE OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION- AND IN CONSIDERING.
AND CONTINUING THEN TO GO BACK
INTO HIGHER LEVELS OF CARE INTO
CONSERVATORSHIP OR TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOMS OR OFTENTIMES
INTO OUR JAIL SYSTEMS. WE
HAVEN'T DONE A GOOD JOB OF
HELPING PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LANGUISHED ON OUR STREETS
WITHOUT ADEQUATE. AND ACCESS-
WHO SUFFER FROM ACUTE MEDICAL
CONDITIONS AS WELL PLACING THEM
AT EVEN HIGHER RISK AND I KNOW
THESE ARE HARD ISSUES AND I
KNOW THAT PEOPLE CARE ABOUT
THEM DEEPLY ON ALL SIDES. I
CARE ABOUT THEM DEEPLY PEOPLE
MAY HAVE HEARD. ME TALK ABOUT
MY AUNT WHO SUFFERED FROM A
CHRONIC MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
AND HER FAMILY CONSTANTLY WOULD
GET HER IN FRONT OF A JUDGE AND
SHE WOULD BE LET GO AND
ACTUALLY ENDED UP BEING.
VIOLENTLY RAPED- ENDED UP
DYING- BASED ON THAT BECAUSE
THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO HOLD OR
ANY LONGER HER LIVER FORGET MY
COUSIN SAYING SHE WASN'T SICK
ENOUGH TOKEEP. BUT SHE WAS
SICK ENOUGH TO GET RATE. I'VE
HAD SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE. I WANT
TO THANK THEM FOR THEIR INPUT
AND THEIR HARD WORK. I HAVE
TAKEN AMENDMENTS LAID OUT
ANALYSIS THAT TO CLARIFY WHAT A
MEDICAL CONDITION IS. NOT AND
CANNOT BE SOMETHING THAT JUST
BECAUSE FROM BEING HOMELESS-
AND IT'S BEEN HAS TO BE
SOMETHING THAT WITHIN A PERIOD
OF SIX MONTHS. WOULD LEAD TO
THAT EVEN EVEN FOR THEIR DEATH.
THE PSYCHIATRIST MUST CONSULT
WITH A PHYSICIAN TO CERTIFY
THAT RESPECT TO CONCLUSIONS
ABOUT A PATIENT'S MENTAL HEALTH
AND THAT PAY AND THE PATIENT
WILL BE PROVIDED TREATMENT
PLAN. AND BE DIRECTED TO
SERVICES THAT WILL PROVIDE THE
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT. TO BE
CLEAR NOTHING IN THIS BILL
ALLOWS FOR MANDATED MEDICAL
TREATMENT IT ONLY SEEKS TO
RESTORE AN INDIVIDUAL'S
CAPACITY TO CARE FOR THEIR
SERIOUS MEDICAL NEEDS. AND I
KNOW WE'RE DEALING WITH UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT NOTHING ABOUT
COPING NINETEEN HAS ADDRESSED
OR MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AND HAS
IN FACT. IN MANY GREEK GREEK.
ASPECTS MADE IT WORSE THIS BILL
I BELIEVE CAN HELP PEOPLE AND I
THINK IT STRIKES THAT. BALANCE
SO WE ALWAYS TRY TO BACK THE
STRIKE BETWEEN. PROTECTING
PEOPLE'S PERSONAL RIGHTS. BUT
ALSO PROVIDING PEOPLE WITH THE
DIGNITY OF CARE. WITH ME I HOPE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS IS
RANDALL HAGAR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION AND JIM GROSS.
THANK YOU SIR EGGMAN AND- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PASSION ON THE
SUBJECT ME WORK ON THIS BILL
LET ME ASK YOU IF YOU ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
PROPOSED ON. PAGES EIGHTEEN. TO
TWENTY I DO ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. MR HAGER IF YOU'RE. ON THE
LINE WE'RE GONNA TRY ONE MORE
TIME. I CERTAINLY HOPE THAT I
AM NOT I HOPE YOU CAN HEAR ME
YOU ARE GO AHEAD AND PROCEED.
HELLO OKAY WONDERFUL THANK YOU
AND THAT SORRY ABOUT THE
TECHNICAL ISSUES OLD EARLIER I
AM RANDALL HAGER I DO REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA- SKATERS IN THE
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA- JUST REAL
BRIEFLY AND CENTER EGGMAN JUST
A WONDERFUL EXPOSITION OF WHY
WE HAVE THIS BILL. AND WHAT IT
WOULD DO- WE ARE LOOKING AT-
THREE INTERSECTING ISSUES
REALLY DYING FROM PREVENTABLE
AND TREATABLE HEALTH CONDITIONS
ON OUR STREETS. ARE PEOPLE
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS
BETWEEN FIFTY ONE FIFTIES AND
FIFTY TWO FIFTIES AND
INCONSISTENT. CATIONS IT
TERMINATIONS THAT WOULD ALLOW
IN SOME CIRCUMSTANCES HELP TO
BE CONSIDERED IN THE THERE'S
NOT. MEMBERS JIM GROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE- PSYCHIC
PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA I DIDN'T I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE WORK OF THE
OF THE CHAIR AND MISSION
BECAUSE WE WERE. INSTRUMENTAL
IN US BEING ABLE TO BRING THIS
BILL- TO THE CANADIAN OF
FORMULATING STRIKES THE BALANCE
THAT CENTER EGGMAN SHOCKING
ABOUT BEGIN THIS IS ABOUT A
HEARING OFFICER. BEING
AUTHORIZED BY STATUTE TO
CONSIDER CERTAIN ASPECTS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S MEDICAL CONDITION
RELATIVE TO THEIR PSYCHIATRIC
CONDITION AND THEIR ABILITY TO
CARE FOR THEMSELVES USING
NARROWLY CRAFTED TO ENSURE.
THAT WE ARE NOT TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT EVERY POTENTIAL MEDICAL
CONDITION THAT INDIVIDUAL MAKE
PAGE BUT THOSE THAT HELLO WE
ARE ONES THAT- ARE LIFE
THREATENING AND THAT. A NEW
DIGITAL FOURTEEN DAYS WOULD
GIVE- PSYCHIATRISTS IN ANY
POSITION THE ABILITY TO PUT THE
INDIVIDUAL IN A POSITION TO. BE
ABLE TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS IS ALSO
VERY IMPORTANT- CENTER EGGMAN
MENTIONED IS THAT. THIS IS THE
SECOND STEP IN WHAT THE LAW
PROVIDES A THREE STEP PROCESS A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR HOLD. A
FOURTEEN DAY HOLD AND THEN
ULTIMATELY POTENTIALLY
CONSERVATORSHIP IT IS THE GOAL
OF THE PSYCHIATRIC PSYCHIATRIC
PROFESSION SHOULD NOT HAVE
PEOPLE GO INTO. CONSERVATORSHIP
WE BELIEVE THIS. SKEPTICAL BE
TAKEN WITH WHICH TO THE TO HEAR
OFFICER CONSIDER THE GOING.
THAT OF YOU CAN SEE HER SHE-
AND- POURED NEEDING TO BE AND-
TO CARE FOR THEM. I GET THANK
YOU FOR THE HELP ON- DID MANAGE
I KNOW THAT THERE MAY STILL BE
SUPPOSED TO FEEL LIKE WE
HAVEN'T QUITE STRUCK OUT
BALANCED- WE'RE OBVIOUSLY
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO TALK.
BOB THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
BE RAPIDLYPICKING PLANET THE
RIGHT. POINT- WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER GROSS-
A BELIEVE WE'VE LOOKED ON AND
IN THE GALLERY THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ROOM ONE
TWELVE. NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
MR THE PHONE LINES IF YOU'D
GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION.
MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU'D OPEN
THE LINE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE ONE THANK
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
NOW. ONE ZERO YOUR SUPPORT. WE
WILL GO TO LINE UP TO FORTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS HERE
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
IF THE PATIENT PSYCHIATRIST IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND AGAIN WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE ONE SIX YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
MISTER CARE WE HAVE NO MORE
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S
TURNED OPPOSITION I HAVE NO
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
LISTED HOWEVER MATTER MATTER IF
THERE IS SOMEONE ON THE PHONE
WILL FOR THEM TWO MINUTES.
THERE IS NOT ON THE PHONE ALL
RIGHT BUT IF YOU ARE IN. BUT
LET'S LOOK TO THE GALLERY NON A
ROOM ONE TWELVE THERE WERE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE SO LET'S GO TO PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WITH YOUR IN OPPOSITION.
OF SB FIVE ONE SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE OH TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE- TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HAVE BEEN MEMBERS.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES OKAY SORRY
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
TYLER READY ON BEHALF OF MY
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WITH THE
AND THEN THEN SOME TAKEN IN
COMMITTEE TODAY WE BELIEVE THAT
WE ARE CLOSE TO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHORED
BY OFFICE TO ADDRESS ANY
REMAINING CONCERNS. BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN COME TO AN
AGREEMENT ON THOSE REMAINING
CONCERNS AND SO APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT THE WORK AND THE
CANADIAN THE AUTHORS. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I'LL TAKE THAT AS THE
PART OF THE TWO MINUTE
OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT ANYONE
ELSE ON THE PHONE LINE. THANK
YOU WILL GO LINE UP TO FORTY
FOUR YOU LINES OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREGORY KRAMER ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AN%
OPPOSITION I'D LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH- WHAT TYLER'S
PREVIOUSLY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THEY GIVE OUT A MODERATOR
I SEE NO MICROPHONES RAISED
HERE IN THE CHAMBER- SO. LET'S
GO BACK TO A CENTER EGGMAN IS
THERE A MOTION. SEVEN KILOS THE
BILL THE BILL. ALL RIGHT SAY
SERENA WAS LIKE CLOSE THE
DISTANCE THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS
ISSUE. THIS IS A WHOLE
CONTINUUM OF CARE WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO THE OREGON FROM.
OUTPATIENT TED EARLY AND
PREVENTION AND TO- IMPATIENT
AND WE KNOW WHAT WE STILL HAVE
TO AND I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THIS ROOM ARE WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE AND CREATING MORE
HOUSING MORE BEDS AND MORE
PLACES FOR PEOPLE. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ITEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR EDMUND-
THAT AND SHE CANCERS CALL THE
ROLL THIS SB FIVE ONE SIX BY
SENATOR EGGMAN WITH MOTION BY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE GET THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND THEN RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH. UMBERG. HI AMBERG BY
BURGESS. A BATTLE. THE RUSSELL
YES. THE REST OF US HI DID I
SAY GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. JONES SEES LAYERED
BY LAYERED ICE STERN. STERN
IOWAY. WACO SKI I WINNER WINNER
I HAVE SEVEN TWO ZERO AS OF NOW
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA PUT THAT
BILLING CALL ALL RIGHT NEXT A
WE'RE GONNA SKIP CENTER GLAZER
AND WE'RE GOING TO. WELL
APPARENTLY CENTER GLAZER IS
ISN'T PAYING ATTENTION I
THOUGHT MAYBE I'D GET HIS
ATTENTION BY SAYING THAT SO-
NEXT WE HAVE S. B. SEVEN EIGHT
TWO BY CENTER GLAZER. SEVEN
GLAZER MAY PROCEED THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY I THANK THE CHAIR AND
THE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME
ON THIS BILL IT'S AN EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS MEMBERS I'M SURE
YOU'VE READ THEM. SO I'M GONNA
TRY TO SUMMARIZE SOME OF THE
KEY POINTS HERE THIS BILL BY
THE WAY IS COMPLEMENTARY TO THE
BILL THAT YOU JUST HEARD BY THE
SENATOR FROM STOCKTON S. B.
FIVE OF SEVEN. CAN I APPLY THE
SENATOR FOR HER WONDERFUL WORK
IN THE SPACE OF CHANGE PLEASED
TO BE PARTNERING WITH HER ON.
SB SEVENTY TWO WOULD IMPLEMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR- THAT
CAME OUT JUST THIS PAST SUMMER-
IN A REVIEW OF OUR STATE MENTAL
HEALTH SYSTEM THE AUDITOR FOUND
THAT ONE IN FOUR INDIVIDUALS
WHO EXITED A CONERVATORSHIP.
REPLACED ON A CONSERVATORSHIP
AGAIN DESPITE HAVING BEEN
DEEMED TO HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFULLY. RECOVERED
PREVIOUSLY. THIS IS BECAUSE
THEY FAILED TO GET THE CARE.
THAT WOULD KEEP THEM IN A
STABLE CONDITION THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT THOSE EXISTING
CONSERVATORSHIP SO WHOEVER IS
RECENTLY EXITED THEM WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO BE PLACED INTO AN
INVOLUNTARY ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT IT IF THE COURT FINDS
THAT THE TREATMENT WOULD REDUCE
THE RISK. OF THE PERSON'S
MENTAL HEALTH DETERIORATING
WHILE LIVING INDEPENDENTLY.
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
IS USED BY COUNTIES PROVIDE
CARE IN A SETTING THAT IS LESS
RESTRICTIVE THAN
CONSERVATORSHIP. IT ENSURES
THAT INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE
SERVICES SUCH AS PSYCHIATRIC
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND ASSISTANCE
WITH HOUSING. THE STATE AUDITOR
RECOMMENDED THAT INSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT BE USED
WHEN APPROPRIATE FOR
INDIVIDUALS EXITING
CONSERVATORSHIP. BUT AS THE-
THE AUDITOR NOTED THIS IS NOT
POSSIBLE UNDER CURRENT LAW.
BECAUSE THE CRITERIA FOR
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
SERVICES EXCLUDES THESE
INDIVIDUALS. THE PROBLEM IS
THAT WHEN THEY LEAVE THE
CONSERVATORSHIP THIRTEEN STABLE
EVEN IF THEY ARE AT RISK FOR
DETERIORATING IN THE VERY NEAR
FUTURE. BUT TO BE PUT INTO AN
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT CARE THEY
HAVE TO BE CLASSIFIED AS
SUBSTANTIALLY. ARRAY THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW COUNTIES TO USE
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
AS A STEP DOWN FORM OF CARE. AS
INDIVIDUALS TRANSITION TO
LIVING INDEPENDENTLY WITH ME IS
JULIE SNYDER OF THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. WITH THAT MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR IS MISS SNYDER ONLINE.
I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
THIS IS JULIE SNYDER WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE THE
INSTITUTE IS AN INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE WHOSE FOCUS IS
ADVANCING SOUND PUBLIC POLICY
AND INSPIRING LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUE SURROUNDING BRAIN HEALTH-
AND ON THAT NOTE I WOULD LIKE
TO START BY THINKING THIS
COMMITTEE. AND SENATOR GLAZER-
FOR INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
BATTLE WE SUPPORT SB SEVEN
EIGHTY TO YOU AS OPPOSED TO
SMART AND COMPASSIONATE
INTERVENTION TO BREAK THE
EXPENSIVE TRAUMATIZING
REVOLVING DOOR THAT IS
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCED BY
CALIFORNIANS LIVING WITH A
SEVERE MENTAL ILLNESSES THEY
SHUTTLE BETWEEN JAILS. THE
STREET AN EMERGENCY ROOMS.
INVOLUNTARY HOLDS IN
CONSERVATORSHIP ARE OFTEN
VIEWED AS A WAY TO STABILIZE
INDIVIDUALS AND BREAK THIS
CYCLE HOWEVER AS SENATOR GLAZER
OUTLINED AT THE STATE BUDGET
LAST YEAR HIGHLIGHTED HOW THESE
INTERVENTIONS FAIL OVER TIME
FOR MANY PEOPLE BECAUSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE LEFT WITH OUT
THE SUPPORT THAT WHICH
FACILITATE THEM LIVING
INDEPENDENTLY AND SAFELY IN THE
COMMUNITY. HE LOS ANGELES ALONE
SEVENTY FOUR HUNDRED PEOPLE
EXPERIENCED FIVE OR MORE
INVOLUNTARY HOLDSINTERESTED
TWO YEAR PERIOD SH AND THAT'S
PERHAPS NOT SURPRISING WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THAT THIS CAN'T 90% OF
THEM WERE ENROLLED IN THE MOST
COMPREHENSIVE METHODS FOR
PROVIDING COMMUNITY BASED CARE.
WHICH ARE EITHER FULL SERVICE
PARTNERSHIPS. FOR ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT. IN THE
CURRENT L. GREAT FOR OUT
TREATMENT PREVENTS THOSE WHO
ARE EXTRA CONSERVATORSHIP FROM
ACCESSING IT. BY REMOVING THAT
BARRIER SB SEVEN EIGHTY TWO
TAKES A CRITICAL STEP FORWARD
IN BRIEF BREAKING THE REVOLVING
DOOR CYCLE SH FROM THE
INSTITUTE'S PERSPECTIVE OUR
GOAL SHOULD ALWAYS BE TO
SUPPORT PEOPLE IN ACCESSING THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE TREATMENT
POSSIBLE. HERE T. IS AN
EFFECTIVE COMMUNITY BASED STEP
DOWN APPROACH THAT HELPS
PREVENT FUTURE CONSERVATORSHIP.
FOR THIS REASON THE SAME PER
AGAINST IT YOU CAN SEE THE
OPTICALLY SUPPORT JUST BE SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I BET THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS SNYDER- OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I SEE NO
ONE IN THE GALLERY ROOM ONE
TWELVE THERE'S NO ONE ROOM ONE
TWELVE. OTHER WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE LINE. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
IN WE DO NOT HAVE ANY ONE
QUEUING UP AS OF RIGHT NOW ALL
RIGHT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
WILL PROVIDE THEM TWO MINUTES.
ANY OPPOSITION IT WOULD BE ONE
AND THEN ZERO TO GET INTO THE
QUEUE- SITTING NO OPPOSITION NO
ONE. I'M SORRY GO AHEAD NOT A
MODERATOR. THERE'S NOBODY IN
HERE I APOLOGIZE ALL RIGHT I
SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY
KNOWN- IN ROOM ONE TWELVE-
LET'S BRING IT BACK HERE THE
CHAMBER. I SEE NO MICROPHONES
RAISED. CENTER LAYERED THE
SELLER ON MOVED THE BILL ALERT
MOVES THE BILL- SENATE GLAZER
WOULD LIKE CLOSE. THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE AND TO GET THE
CHAIR AND THE STAFF. I
RECEIVED- ELEVEN OH WONDERFUL
BIPARTISAN VOTED SENATE HEALTH
AND APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY. BASED ON A GLAZER-
MANAGING COUNSEL PEOPLE THE
ROLE THIS IS ASKING SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR GLAZER.
THE MOTION IS BY SENATOR
LAYERED AND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST THE RIVER RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE- BURKE I
BORJAS. ADAM DID. THE REST SO I
CAN. HI WINDS ARE I. JONES
LAYERED HI THERE IT AYE STERN
YOUR NINE STERN I Y. CASKEY BY
WACO SKI I WIENER. WIENER AYE
YOU HAVE SEVEN TWO ZERO SO FAR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
GLAZER. NEXT SENATORS ALSO
BECAUSE YOU MAY PRESENT FROM
EITHER YOUR DESK OR THE PODIUM
WHICHEVER YOU CHOOSE. RIGHT
THANK YOU- WE HAVE. SB SIX OH
SIX HUNDRED AND SALAS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND-
JUDICIARY CHIEF COUNSEL I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SB SIX OH
SIX I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OF THANK YOU AND SB
SIX OH SIX WILL CODIFY PARTS OF
THE FEDERAL OSHA POLICY FOR
AGREE JUST EMPLOYERS GIVING CAL
OSHA THE AUTHORITY TO IMPOSE
ADDITIONAL PENALTIES ON
EMPLOYERS FOR WILLFUL
VIOLATIONS WERE WORKERS HAVE
BEEN KNOWINGLY HARMED BY A
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
AND STATE LAWS. AND SAFETY
LAWS- IT BUILDS OFF THE FEDERAL
OSHA'S CORPORATE WIDE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT BY A
PROVIDING HELLO SHE WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO ISSUE A SUSPENSION
OR TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDER
AT ALL LOCATIONS UNDER COMMON
OWNERSHIP WHEN EMPLOYERS
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
DIRECTLY VIOLATE LABOR AND
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS AS
CHAIR OF THE SENATE SPECIAL
COMMITTEE ON PANDEMIC EMERGENCY
RESPONSE LAST YEAR I DID HELP
HOLD A OVERSIGHT HEARING ON
WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WHERE WE LEARNED THAT
CALLOW SHOULD HAVE BEEN
INUNDATED WITH MORE COMPLAINTS
THAN THEIR INSPECTORS CAN
HANDLE- BUT THEY DIDN'T NEED
THEY NEEDED TO BE MORE FOCUSED
LEADING STAFF TO. INCREASINGLY
RELY ON LETTER ONLY
INVESTIGATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
INSUFFICIENT IN AND EFFECTIVELY
PROTECTING FRONTLINE WORKERS SB
SIX OF SIX PROVIDES HELLO SURE
WITH THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO
MAXIMIZE THE USE OF THEIR
LIMITED RESOURCES THEY'RE
THEY'RE ABLE TO RESPOND MORE
EFFECTIVELY IT ALSO ESTABLISHES
A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION FOR
RETALIATION IT WILL PROTECT
WORKERS TO COME FORWARD WITH
THE POSITIVE COPING NINETEEN
TESTS OR WHO REQUEST FOR- PP
FOR A TEST AND THOSE WERE
REPORT UNSAFE CONDITIONS IF
WORKERS ARE NOT CONFIDENT THEY
WILL BE PROTECTED FROM
RETALIATION THEY WILL BE LESS
LIKELY TO COME FORWARD AND
REPORT. VIOLATIONS TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT TODAY I HAVE JUST A
GREAT WALL LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR U. S. C. W. WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL AS WELL AS MITCH
STRIKER POLICY ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
ON STANDBY STEVEN KNIGHT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
WORKSAFE- FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS BUT I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK HER AYE VOTE ON SB SIX OF
SIX THINKING MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU SENATE GONZALEZ MISS GRAY
WILL ARE YOU ON THE LAW. YES I
AM CAN YOU HEAR ME. I CAN GO
AHEAD. ONE BOB IN THE INVESTOR
CARE NUMBER MY NAME IS DR THE
GRANT WHILE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH W. ACTORS COUNCIL
UPW REPRESENTS OVER A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE FEED
PHARMACEUTICAL AND RETAIL
SECTORS ALL OF YOU HAVE BEEN
THE IN FRONT LINE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS DROPPED AT THE END OF
YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE MEMBERS
RISE TO THE OCCASION AND PUT
THEIR AND THEIR FAMILIES HEALTH
AND SAFETY ON THE LINE.
CALIFORNIANS DROPPED HIM THAT
MAKE OUR MEMBERS HAVE SUFFERED
IMMEASURABLE. LOSSES BECAUSE
THE COMPANY. I WE RECOGNIZE
THAT CALLOUS THE BARELY
UNDERSTOOD AND UNDER RE. THAT
LAST BUT NOT. TO WILL ARGUE
FOR. AND CHAIN OF WHERE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR KEEPING WORKERS
SAFE ON THE JOB. CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT PERMIT HELLO SHOULD TO
LEVY FINES OR OTHER REMEDY THAT
A SUFFICIENT BY THE CONSEQUENT.
TO DETER DEADLY CONDUCT BY
LARGE CORPORATIONS MAKES
IMPORTANT NEEDLESSLY
DUPLICATIVE AN EXPENSE THAT.
AND FELT THAT KNOWLEDGE THE
CRITICAL ROLE WORKER COMPLAINTS
PLAY AND THE EFFORT TO IDENTIFY
AND PRIORITIZE. WORKPLACE
SAFETY VIOLATIONS. THIS IS WHY
WE NEED SB SIX OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR DEVELOPER OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. I THINK IF
THE STATE DOESN'T SIMPLY RACE
COLORS THE PENALTY PROBLEM
PLAYERS. BUT TAKE A TARGETED
APPROACH RAISING PENALTIES FOR
LARGE EMPLOYERS SERVING AS A
REAL INCENTIVE. FOR EMPLOYERS
TO VOLUNTARY COMPLY WITH HEALTH
AND SAFETY STANDARDS.
ADDITIONALLY COLORS IT DOES NOT-
CURRENTLY HOW COOL THAT IT'S
LOCAL DOUBLE CHAIN COMPANIES
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN AN EMPLOYER
THREATENED POLICIES OR
PROCEDURES. ARE IN DIRECT
VIOLATION OF HEALTH AND AFETY
ORDERS. A LARGE CHAIN DRUG
RETAILING PLAYER ISSUED EMPIRE
WRITTEN POLICY THAT STATED.
WORKERS WHO ARE WORKING SIDE BY
SIDE AN INDIVIDUAL WHO TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COCAINE NINETEEN.
CAN CONTINUE WORKING NOT NOT
WHAT THE NINE NINETY FIVE MATH
BUT CROSSED MY- DIRECT
VIOLATION OF QUARANTINING
REQUIREMENTS. THIS POLICY
RESULTED IN WORKERS COMING TO
WORK ALL POSITIVE WITH SEVEN
EIGHTEEN AND INFECTING OTHER
WORKERS. PALESTINIAN TOLD A
COMPANY MIGHT A BASEMENT THIS
IS BEN BADLER POLICIES.
ULTIMATELY SAVING WORKERS AND
THE PUBLIC LIVES. LASTLY
WORKERS BECAUSE YOUR FAITH AND
TRUST IN COMING FORWARD WITH
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES.
RELATED TO COVER NINETEEN ABOUT
RETALIATION. SB SIX THIS
EXCELLENT SURE THAT WORKERS
AREN'T SCARED TO REPORT
POSITIVE KEVIN NINETEEN PASS-
HELPING THANK YOU VIOLATIONS OF
EMPLOYER OUT OF FEAR OF
RETALIATION. RETALIATION FOR
LOW WAGE WORKERS MEANS THAT
PART OF THEIR FAMILY GOING
HUNGRY OR THE FRONT OF THE-
ALTAR BENEFITS ANY PANDEMIC.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
EYEBROW ON. THE FACT THAT THE.
IT'S REALLY COVERED THE MAIN
POINTS BEHIND THIS BILL WE JUST
WANTED TO EMPHASIZE A FEW QUICK
ONES. THE FIRST IS THAT THE
EGREGIOUS VIOLATION SECTION. IS
A SUBSET OF WHAT ARE CALLED
WILLFUL VIOLATIONS AND EITHER
ONE OR THE EMPLOYER. KNOWINGLY
VIOLATED THE LAW OR KNEW THAT
THERE WAS A HAZARD THAT COULD
BE VERY DANGEROUS AND DIDN'T
MAKE ANY REASONABLE EFFORTS TO
MITIGATE THAT. AND THIS IS A
SUBSET OF THOSE LOCAL
VIOLATIONS. OF LOCAL ELECTIONS
ARE ONLY CITED- LAST YEAR I
THINK THERE WERE TWO AND THE-
BEFORE THERE WERE THREE. AND OR
TALKING ABOUT A SUBSET OF THOSE
IN THE EXTREME CASE SOME OF
WHICH WE'VE SEEN DURING.
NINETEEN WHEN AN EMPLOYER IT IS
FAILING TO TAKE ACTION THAT
COULD SAVE LOTS OF WORKERS
LIVES. YEAH THE QUICK POINT WE
WANTED TO REALLY EMPHASIZE
WHAT'S THAT. SECTION OF THE
BILL THAT ALLOWS COALITION TO
FIGHT TO THE LABOR CODE. GIVES
THE LEGISLATURE AUTHORITY TO
WEIGH IN ON WORKER HEALTH AND
SAFETY WHEN NECESSARY JEFF.
CURRENTLY CAL OSHA INSPECTORS
ONLY ENFORCE TITLE IN HEALTH
AND SAFETY REGULATIONS. AND THE
REALLY ISN'T ANYONE THERE TO
ENFORCE THE LAW WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO STEP IN
QUICKLY. TO DEAL WITH WORKER
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES THAT
STILL GIVES THE LEGISLATURE
THAT AUTHORITY WHICH WE THINK
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. AND WE
ARE YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER. ALL RIGHT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUB. I SEE
WE HAVE ONE WITNESS IN THE
GALLERY. I THINK YOU NEED TO
STEP CLOSER MICROPHONE OKAY
DESERVE BETTER. THE OBSERVERS I
MAY HAVE A CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU- THE OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
WINDOWS IN THE ROOM ONE TWELVE.
NO WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE. ALL RIGHT WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE
PLEASE GIVE US JUST YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION. STE
MODERATE IF YOU OPEN A FEW
AREN'T. PART OF SIX OKAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE UP TO FIFTY SEVEN
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU RENEE
BAYARDO AT THE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIANS TRANSPORT. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER THREE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON NOT MUCH GERMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LIVING COSTS
THAT SMART TRANSPORTATION
DIVISION CALIFORNIA STATE LAWS
THAT BARRED STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. PICTURED
HERE IN MEMBERS TAYLOR JACKSON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX ZERO SIX. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER. TWO SIXTY FOUR SIXTY
FOUR. THE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY WE WILL GO TO THE LINE.
ONE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON I DON'T REMEMBER
THE CUSTOMER ON BEHALF OF
RECORDS ADVOCATE TRANSPORT
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER. ONE
EIGHTEEN. YES HI GOOD AFTERNOON
STEVEN KNIGHT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF WORKSAFE PROUD TO
CO SPONSOR SENATOR GONZALEZ IS
SB SIX OF SIX THANK YOU CENTERS
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER. TWO SIXTY
THREE TO FIFTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTOPHE MAIRE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX OF SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND OUR LAST ONE IS
ONE FIFTY NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS MARICA
YOSHIHARU WITH THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR ALL RIGHT
BRING BACK THE CHAMBER I SEE NO
MICROPHONES UP- CIVIC IT'S
ALMOST YOU CAN CLOSE I WANT TO
THANK OUR SPONSORS FOR CALLING
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY
VOTE THANK YOU. THEIR MOTION
MOVED BY SENATOR RUSSELL. BOB
ALL RIGHT BEVIN TO CANCEL IF
YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL YES
THEY WOULD- THIS IS SB SIX OH
SIX BY SENATOR GONZALEZ OF THE
MOTION BY SENATOR DID I SO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND THEN RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS I'M BURKE HI I'M
BURKE AYE BURGESS CARRIERA DID
ASAL. THE REST SO I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. JONES
LAYERED. LAYARD I'D STERN.
STERN HIGHWAY CAL SKI. WHY
CASKEY AYE WIENER WIENER AYE
YOU HAVE SEVEN TWO ZERO ALL
RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL ON
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS HIS BILL
IS NEXT SB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR
WILL GIVE CENTER HERTZBERG JUST
A MOMENT TO APPEAR IN THE
CHAMBER. A PREVIEW OF THINGS TO
COME- AFTER CENTER HERTZBERG
WILL BE S. J. R. NUMBER TWO BY
SENATE HUESO- THE NERVE CENTER
LEYVA S. B. TWO SEVEN EIGHT
THEN SENATOR MAN SB THREE NINE
ONE. LET ME LET FOLKS WHO ARE
WATCHING AND LISTENING KNOW
THAT SB THREE FIFTEEN BY
SENATOR ROTH WHICH IS NUMBER
EIGHTEEN THEN YOU'RE A HIT
PARADE IS NOT GONNA BE HEARD-
AFTER SENATOR MINUTES COULD. BE
HEARD AT THE VERY END OF
TODAY'S AGENDA. ALL RIGHT SO
YOU'RE CONCERNED OR HERTZBERG I
SEE THE DOOR OPENING.
SENATE
HERTZBERG. ONE SEVEN HERTZBERG
SB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR WE'LL GIVE
YOU A CHANCE TO GET SETTLED.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU MUCH.
MEMBERS MISTER CHAIR PAULA
JUDGES AND CLEATS COMMITTEE
IT'S THE CONJUGAL FEW THINGS
I'M SO SORRY SO HERE'S THE THIS
THIS THIS BILL HAS BEEN EITHER
A THE REASON I'VE BEEN REDUCED
IT IS BECAUSE- THE COURT OF
APPEALS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARONIE ASLI DECIDED
THE CASE. ON JANUARY TWENTIETH
THE CASE IS CALLED WOOD VERSUS
SUPERIOR COURT OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY LITERALLY JUST ON
JANUARY TWENTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE FOURTH DISTRICT COURT
OF APPEALS. WHICH HELD A
PUBLISHED DECISION THAT THE-
FOR EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES ACT
ADMINISTERED BY THE- FOR
EMPLOYMENT AND THAT HIGH
HOUSING DEPARTMENT BASICALLY
SAID THAT- A SOMEBODY WHO
SUBJECT TO COMPLAINT- COULDN'T
BE REPRESENTING REP NOT
REPRESENT YOURSELF DIDN'T HAVE
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE. AND
THE REASON HAS WE HAVE UNDER
THE EOC AND OTHER FEDERAL LACKS
IN THE LIKE THIS ATTORNEY
CLIENT PRIVILEGE SHOULD EXIST
BETWEEN THE AGENCY ON THE ONE
HAND AND THE INDIVIDUAL ON THE
OTHER IS BECAUSE YOU NEED THAT
LEVEL OF CONFIDENCE FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE
INVESTIGATORS TO PRESENTING
THEIR CASE. THE PERSON WHO'S
BEEN DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IS
THE REAL PARTY IN INTEREST AND
SO THEY NEED TO BE PROTECTED.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
CLARIFYING LAW HERE AND
BASICALLY CHALLENGING THE COURT
IN THE WORST CASE THAT WAS A
RONI ASTLEY DECIDED TO MAKE IT
CLEAR. THAT IN THESE CASES THAT-
THIS ATTORNEY CLIENT RIVILEGE
PROTECTS THIS PRO BONO UP
PERSON. YOU KNOW THE- THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES ACT WAS
STARTED CREATED NINETEEN FIFTY
NINE- BY BOTH WILLIAM MUMFORD
GUS HAWKINS TWO AFRICAN
AMERICAN MEMBERS OF THIS HOUSE
TO THE OTHER HOUSE OF THIS
LEGISLATURE. ITS PURPOSE WAS TO
PROTECT PEOPLE CIVIL RIGHTS
LIKE THE EOC IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE SINGLE LARGEST
CITY IN THE COUNTRY THE DOES
THAT. AND SO THIS CASE BECOMES
REALLY IMPORTANT THIS LAW
BECOMES REALLY IMPORTANT
CORRECTING THIS RONI IS CASE
BECAUSE YOU NEED WHEN PEOPLE
ARE APPEARING PRO BONO YOU NEED
THEM TO HAVE A COMPLETE COMFORT
LEVEL WITH THE GOVERNMENT THAT
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
PROVIDE IS CONFIDENTIAL IN THE
IT WOULD CASE IT WAS ACTUALLY
AN EMAIL THAT WAS PROVIDED. AND
THE OTHER SIDE WAS TRYING TO
GET DISCOVERY SO THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL THAT
SIMPLIFICATION TO ONE PAGE BILL
BUT OFTEN A WIN THE COURT OF
APPEALS OR WHEN THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
IMPROPERLY INTERPRETS THE LAW
IT'S OUR DECISION OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IN OUR BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT TO CLARIFY THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE I
HAVE ADAM AMERO. WHO IS WITH
THE AGENCY WHO IS HERE AS A
WITNESS TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH YES
YOU'RE RIGHT. THANK YOU SIR.
HERTZBERG MR AMERILA ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. YEAH IT COULD HAPPEN
CHAIR AMBER HONORABLE MEMBERS.
I AM NOT AMERICA. DIRECTOR OF
EXECUTIVE PROGRAMS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ALSO KNOWN AS E. S.
T. H. THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
SPONSORING THIS BILL AND DOES
NOT HAVE A POSITION ON IT BUT
I'M HERE TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THIS BILL CLARIFIED
THAT UNDER EXISTING LAW THE
LAWYER CLIENT PRIVILEGE AND
CATCHES THE CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE FDA
TO LAWYERS AND INDIVIDUAL TO
COME TO OUR DEPARTMENT ALLEGING
THAT THE DOUBLE THAT THEIR
CIVIL RIGHTS HAVE BEEN
VIOLATED. COMMUNICATION SHOULD
BE ABSOLUTELY SHIELDED FROM
DISCOVERY TO PROMOTE FULL AND
OPEN DISCUSSION BETWEEN DLPH
LAWYERS AND VICTIMS OF
DISCRIMINATION. JUST THAT THE
PRIVILEGE PROTECT CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
DEFENDANTS AND OUR CASES AND
THEIR COUNSEL. TECHNICALLY
SPEAKING AND AGREED TO PERSON
WHO COMES TO OUR DEPARTMENT
IT'S NOT OUR CLIENT THE
DEPARTMENT IF THE CLIENT OF OUR
LAWYERS. BUT IF YOU HAVE KIDS I
PICKED THEM UP DISCRIMINATION
AND EXPRESSED ROLE IN A CAGE
FREE BRING ON THEIR BEHALF.
THEY ARE THE REAL PARTY IN IT
IN TRANSIT CENTER HERTZBERG
GETS NOTED AND. INTERVENE IN
OUR CASE. SCHERING PLOUGH. THE
CIVIL RIGHTS CAME HE BEACH
LAWYER NOT COME. BUT THE REAL
PARTY ABOUT CONFIDENTIAL LEGAL.
SICKENING ARE NOW FOR D. F. H.
IMPORT THE STATE PUBLIC POWER.
ARE RADICALLY NEEDING AND
REMEDYING DISCRIMINATION IN OUR
STATE. THE REASON DECISION FROM
THE COURT OF APPEAL IN
WOODBRIDGE TO SUPERIOR COURT
AND CAUSING SUBSTANTIAL
CONFUSION THAT IS DEALING
EXTENDED LITIGATION OVER THE
APPLICATION OF THE LAWYER
CLIENT PRIVILEGE TO OUR
DEPARTMENT'S LAWYERS
COMMUNICATIONS BUT THE REAL
PARTY IN INTEREST. YOUR
UNDERMINING AND RAISING THE
COST OF THE STATE CIVIL RIGHTS
ENFORCEMENT SYSTEM THE BILL
RECALLS BACK CONFUSION. THE
SENATOR HERTZBERG JUST NOTE
THAT BILL ALL ONLINE STATE
FEDERAL LAW FEDERAL COURTS HAVE
LONG RECOGNIZED THAT THE LAWYER
CLIENT PRIVILEGE PROTECTS
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
COMPLAINANTS AND FEDERAL CIVIL
RIGHTS ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
SHOULD BE EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY COMMISSION EVEN
THOUGH THERE IS NOT AN ATTORNEY
CLIENT RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
AGENCY AND THEY'RE COMPLAINING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS MAY
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU
MR ROMERO ON OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN THE
ROOM ONE TWELVE. THIS MONTH-
MADAME MODERATOR IF WE GO THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU COULD STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR FILIATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE RENDON ZERO. WE DO HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
THINK I FEEL REPRESENTING
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. OKAY BE
JUST ONE MOMENT HERE ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT. AND OUR
NEXT LINE IS A ONE OLD FOUR ONE
OH FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE OF
FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. OKAY
THAT MIGHT HAVE DROPPED. ALL
RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
MADAME MODERATOR. NO THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURNED OPPOSITION- IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION I SEE
NO ONE IN THE GALLERY AND NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. ANYONE
ON THE LINE IN OPPOSITION. HERE
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY ONE QUEUING UP
RESEARCHER. ALL RIGHT MADAM
MODERATOR- LET LET'S BRING IT
BACK HERE TO THE CHAMBER
THERE'S NO ONE ON THE LINE I
SEE THAT CENTER BOARD JUST HIS
MICROPHONE RAISED AN INCIDENT
WHAT KELSEY DOES AS WELL SO
WE'LL GO CENTER FOR JUST FOR.
THANK YOU. GERMAN MY KNEE JERK
REACTION- TO EXPANDING THE
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE- IS
ONE OF HESITATION THIS THIS-
COMMITTEE I BELIEVE IT WAS LAST
YEAR MAYBE THE YEAR BEFORE
DEALT WITH A SIMILAR SITUATION
WHERE ATTORNEY CLIENT
PROTECTIONS WERE SOUGHT FOR
MEMBERS OF A- COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING ORGANIZATION- TO
FACILITATE THE- DISCLOSURE OF
INFORMATION BETWEEN- MEMBER
AND- COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
LEADERSHIP. AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE IS A NEED AND IT'S
AN IMPORTANT NEED THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE. WITH FOLKS. IN GET
SOME DEGREE OF INFORMATION.
WHILE MINIMIZING THE RISK OF
SUCH DISCLOSURES IN THAT
PROCESS. MY CONCERN HERE IT
GOES BACK TO WHAT WE
EXPERIENCED- WITH OF WITH AN
EARLIER VERSION OF THIS TYPE OF
BILL IS WHAT ARE THE
IMPLICATIONS OF EXPANDING
ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE. AND
I THINK THE AUTHOR IN A MINUTE
IF I IF I MAY POSE A QUESTION
OR TWO AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
TO THE AUTHOR. IS THAT. THE SAN
DIEGO COURT OF APPEALS
DECISION. I HAD OCCASION TO
READ IT LAST NIGHT- I THINK
IT'S PRETTY IMPORTANT PRETTY
TELLING. THE COURT OF PPEALS
IN THIS SUBJECT MATTER.
IDENTIFIED THAT ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE IS DESIGNED
INHERENTLY TO BE BETWEEN ONE AN
ATTORNEY NUMBER TWO A CLIENT
WITH THE EXPECTATION OF
PROVIDING LEGAL SERVICE THROUGH
THAT RELATIONSHIP. HERE I
BELIEVE THIS BILL IS ASKING FOR
US TO DO AWAY WITH THE
CONDITION PRECEDENT THAT THERE
BE. ONE AN ATTORNEY AND TO A
CLIENT. IN THIS SITUATION THE
DEPARTMENT OF- HOUSING- FOR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. SERVES
THE NEEDS OF THE INDIVIDUALS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS
NOT SERVE AS AN ATTORNEY OR
LEGAL ADVISER TO THE INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS- PRESENTING INFORMATION
PRESENTING POTENTIALLY
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO FORESEEABLE
NEXUS BETWEEN THAT CLIENT IN
THAT DEPARTMENT LEGAL ADVISER
THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR THEM TO
PROVIDE LEGAL SERVICE TO THAT
INDIVIDUAL. SO MY CONCERN IS
THAT IF WE KNOW BASED ON THE
SAME DAY OF COURT OF APPEALS
DECISION. THAT AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO REACHES OUT TO A DEPARTMENT
WHERE THERE WILL NEVER EVER BE
A FIDUCIARY DUTY OR EXPECTATION
OF. PROVIDING LEGAL SERVICE IF
WE EXPANDED TOURNEY CLIENT
PROTECTIONS TO THAT. THEN I
THINK. THAT WOULD BE A KITTEN
TO AN INDIVIDUAL REACHING OUT
TO THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE. ASKING FOR INTERNET
CLIENT. COMMUNICATION WHEN THE
DA'S OFFICE OR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE LOOKS AFTER
THE INTERESTS OF THE WHOLE OF
THE STATE NOT THE INDIVIDUAL.
SO THERE'S A THERE'S A WE USE
AT ALL FOR A SLIPPERY SLOPE I
MEAN THIS IS THIS IS VERY
COMPELLING STATE CONSEQUENCES
THAT WE COULD FORESEE HERE SO I
GUESS MY QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR
IF I MAY THROUGH THE CHAIR. IS
I'D LIKE TO HEAR AN EXPLANATION
AS TO HOW THIS WOULD BE
CONFINED IF THIS BILL WERE TO
MOVE FORWARD THAT WOULDN'T BE
EXPANDED UPON IN THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE IN SUBSEQUENT
LEGISLATIVE CYCLES. WE'RE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE SEEKING
INFORMATION AND THEN WE GIVE
THEM BEING GIVEN ATTORNEY
CLIENT PROTECTIONS WHEN THEY
WILL NEVER EVER BE A CLIENT. IF
I COULD POSE THAT QUESTION TO
THE AUTHOR HERTZBERG WHICH LIKE
THE QUESTION REPEATED NO I GOT
IT I GOT IT ALL RIGHT-
HERTZBERG. YOU CAN RESPOND OR
IN YOUR CLOTHES OUR RESPONSE IN
THIS MAY BE MY CLOTHES HOPE
LIVES NO MORE QUESTIONS. WHAT
IS THE PUBLIC INTEREST. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE WE DECIDED
IN THIS STATE THAT WE ARE GOING
TO PROTECT PEOPLE'S CIVIL
RIGHTS. THAT WE WERE GOING TO
CREATE A STATE AGENCY TO
PROTECT INDIVIDUAL CIVIL RIGHTS
THAT IS THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
QUESTION BECOMES JUST LIKE THE
E. O. C. WHERE I'VE HAD A
RELATIVE WHO USED TO BE THE
CHAIRMAN OF THAT. UNDER BOTH
NIXON AND FORD. THE AMBASSADOR.
THIS SAME MODEL APPLIANCE SO
WHAT WE HAVE IS A PERSON WHO
CIVIL RIGHTS HAS BEEN VIOLATED
THE QUESTION AS A PRACTICAL
MATTER THAT IS INFORMED BY A
LONG HISTORY OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WITHOUT ABUSE SIR A
PROCESS ISSUES OF WHAT. SHOULD
THE ATTORNEY CLIENT PRIVILEGE
MEANS IS THAT WE NEED THIS
CONFIDENTIAL RELATIONSHIP.
BETWEEN OUR AGENCY WHOSE JOB IT
IS TO PROTECT PEOPLE CIVIL
RIGHTS AND THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
WAS ARTICULATED THIS WAS
EXPRESSED OUR WITNESS TO BE THE
REAL PARTY IN INTEREST. THE
REAL PARTY IN INTEREST IN CASES
IS REALLY WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT SO YOU CAN'T PROSECUTE
THESE CASES IT'S LIKE HAVING A
WITNESS PROTECTION PROGRAM OR
VICTIM RIGHTS PROGRAM IN THE
PEOPLE VERSUS AN INDIVIDUAL TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SAFETY IT'S
EXACTLY THE SAME THING. BUT THE
QUESTION BECOMES HOW DO YOU DO
THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE THAT
CONFIDENTIALITY OTHERWISE YOU
COULD NEVER PROSECUTED CASE SO
YOU COULD GET CAUGHT UP IN THE
MEETING AND I DON'T THINK THE
ANSWERS WITH RESPECT TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IT ALL
APPLIES TO THIS DIAGNOSTIC.
BECAUSE THE ONLY WAY THIS WORKS
IS NOT EXPANSION THIS IS A
CLARIFICATION THAT IS WAS
INDICATED BY THEIR TECHNICAL
ADVISER IS NECESSARY BY THE
CONFUSION CREATED BY THE COURT
IN SAN DIEGO. AND IT IS ALSO AS
A FINAL POINT RATE THIS IS NOT
INVENTING SOMETHING NEW THIS IS
NOT A BROAD EXPANSION OF WHAT
WE MEAN BY ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE. THIS IS SIMPLY WHAT
HAS BEEN TRIED IN TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE ONLY
REASON I STAND BEFORE YOU TODAY
IS BECAUSE ONE COURT IN SAN
DIEGO MADE A DECISION TO VERY A
VERY AWAY FROM THAT. AND THAT
THIS. T. THAT CREATED IN. FIFTY
NINE IN CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT
PEOPLE CIVIL RIGHTS COULD
CONTINUE TO DO SO. I THINK THAT
REALLY ADDRESSES IT SHOWS THAT
ITS MAINSTAY THIS IS NOT SOME
ABERRATION BUT ISN'T SOME WILD.
INTERPRETATION OF WHAT WE MEAN
<c.green>Y THIRTY CLIMB PRIVILEGE AND</c>
THAT IN FACT THE REAL
INTERPRETATION IT WAS
PROBLEMATIC WHAT IS IN THE
WORST CASE ON JANUARY TWENTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU.
SURE IF I COULD FOLLOW UP. YES
GO HEAD TO THE BOARD THANK YOU-
AND I AND I BELIEVE THAT THERE
ARE REAL MERITS TO LOOKING
AFTER THE PUBLIC GOOD. BUT
THERE MUST BE MECHANISMS THAT
COULD BE CREATED THAT WOULD
ALLOW FOR CONFIDENTIAL ASK.
PROTECTIONS FOR COMMUNICATIONS
WITHOUT MOVING IN THE DIRECTION
OF. ATTORNEY CLIENT PROTECTIONS
IN PRIVILEGE. WOULD THAT NOT BE
A VIABLE ALTERNATIVE. TO THE
CHAIR MR IS THE QUESTION I
DON'T THINK SO I DON'T SEE WHY.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LONG BODY OF
THE HISTORY OF THE BODY OF LAW
OF WHAT IT MEANS I GET YOUR
POINT WE COULD CREATE SOME
HYBRID. SOME NEW KIND OF MODEL
THAT SAYS WELL THIS ISN'T
TECHNICALLY ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE BUT WE WOULD BE
LITIGATING THIS FROM HERE TO
THE HEAVENS. WE HAVE A
PRINCIPLE IT IT ONLY APPLIES
ONE WAY IT'S ONLY FOR ONE
LIMITED PURPOSE. AND I WOULD
SUGGEST TO YOU THAT IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE SAME PROCESS.
THAT HAS BEEN IN THE LAW ON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR MANY
YEARS WITH THE- THE EEOC THE
COMPLIMENT OPPORTUNITY
COMMISSION. WHICH HAS A SIMILAR
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WE HAVE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT
PEOPLE CIVIL RIGHTS. I WOULD
SAY YOU MIGHT HAVE A POINT. BUT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT IT'S BEEN
IN THE LAW FOR A LONG TIME ONE
COURT CASE CAME DOWN. THROUGH
SOME CONFUSION. OUR JOB IN THIS
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT IS TO
CLARIFY THAT COMPETED TECH
INFUSION AND MAKE SURE. THAT
THE WAY THE LAW SHOULD BE
INTERPRETED AND THAT IS TO
PROTECT THE LITTLE GUY WHO
SCARED TO DEATH WHOSE RIGHTS
HAVE BEEN VIOLATED AND NEEDS
EVERY PROTECTION POSSIBLE. TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE TAKEN
CARE OF AND THAT THERE DOES NO
CHILLING EFFECT ON THEIR
ABILITY TO COME FORTH TO
EXPLAIN. AND STAND UP FOR THEIR
BREACH OF THEIR CIVIL RIGHTS.
INJUSTICE CLARIFICATION AND
JUSTICE CLARIFICATION- IN THE
CIVIL RIGHTS- CONTEXT. THE
HOLDER OF THE PRIVILEGE. IS THE
GOVERNMENT. FOR THE INDIVIDUAL.
THE GUY. OKAY SO THAT'S WHAT
YOU'RE DOING YOU'RE BASICALLY
THE GOVERNMENT'S JOB IS A
PUBLIC POLCY TO THE CHAIR. IS
TO PROTECT. CIVIL RIGHTS THAT'S
EIGHT STATED CRITICAL DEVELOP
PURPOSE OF OUR LAW IN
CALIFORNIA FOR SEVENTY YEARS
SIXTY YEARS. THAT'S THEY HOLD
THAT THAT'S AND THEY NEED TO
HOLD IT TO GIVE THE PERSON
CONFIDENCE SO IN THIS
PARTICULAR CONTEXT THE HOLDER
OF THE PRIVILEGE WOULD BE THE-
DIVISION OF THE STATE AND NOT
THE INDIVIDUAL- YEAH. SO IN A
TREE CLIENT PRIVILEGE. THE
CLIENT HOLDS THE PRIVILEGE. SO
THIS IS NOT ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE BY VIRTUE OF THE FACT
THAT THE HOLDER OF THE
PRIVILEGE IS NOT THE PRINCIPLE
AND WHAT THE INSTRUMENT MEANING
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OR THE EOC OR THE- ANY
VARIATION OF THE DIVISION OF
THE STATE. HOW DOES HOW DO YOU
RECONCILE US GENERAL DURING THE
PRIVILEGES NOT MATTER THAT'S
THAT'S A DISTINCTION WITHOUT A
DIFFERENCE SENATOR THAT'S A
DISTINCTION WITHOUT A
DIFFERENCE IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
IS THAT GOVERNMENT CAN SERVE
ITS PURPOSE THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
WHO'S GETTING HURT CAN BE COULD
HAVE COMFORT. THAT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO BE UP THEIR
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMATION WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO PREPARE THEIR
CASE IS GOING TO BE ADVERSELY
USED AGAINST THEM AND THE
GOVERNMENT'S PURPOSE IS GOING
TO BE SERVED AND SO IT'S AN
ARGUMENT WHERE THEORETICALLY
YOU CAN SAY WELL AS I GUESS THE
MOST AND THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING IS THAT. THE DEFINITION
OF CONFIDENTIALITY IS STEEPED
IN THE LAW SO THAT THERE'S NO
RISK TO THE INDIVIDUAL THAT YOU
INVENTED SOME NEW THEORY BUT
THAT THEY KNOW THAT THIS
DEFINITION IS GOIG TO PROTECT
THEM ALL RIGHT AND I NINE ONCE
AGAIN I ABSOLUTELY RESPECT MY
COLLEAGUE- BOARD MELANIE
QUESTIONS. IN ALL FINISHED
RIGHT HERE CHAIR THANK YOU IS
THAT I BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE ARE WHEN
IT COMES TO ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE THE HOLDER OF THE
PRIVILEGE. IS DETERMINATIVE.
AND IF THIS A HEALTH AND SAY
MATTER FOR EXAMPLE SOMEONE
COMES FORWARD WITH THE HEALTH
VIOLATION ALLEGATION AGAINST A
RESTAURANT YOU KNOW YOU CAN SEE
HOW THIS TYPE OF ATTORNEY
CLIENT ASK PROTECTION WE'LL
BELIEVE NOT MAYBE THIS
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE BUT IT WILL
MOVE FORWARD- IN THE FUTURE AND
I THINK IT WOULD DILUTE THE
ESSENCE OF AN ATTORNEY AND A
CLIENT RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
EXPECTATION OF LEGAL SERVICE-
SO. I WOULD I'M GONNA
RESPECTFULLY- NOT BE SUPPORTIVE
BUT I DO AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR
OF THIS THAT THERE SHOULD BE
SOME TYPE OF PROTECTION I
BELIEVE IT SHOULD BE MORE IN
THE FORM OF CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATION PROTECTIONS FOR
EVIDENTIARY PROTECTIONS NOT
ATTORNEY CLIENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER GORGEOUS OTHER
QUESTIONS. HELLO CAL SKI. SEVEN
SO MY CUSTOMERS THE BILL THANK
ON BIG BEFORE WE MOVE TO CENTER
HERTZBERG IS CLOSE I WOULD ASK
THAT ON ALL THE MEMBERS REMAIN
FOR JUST A MOMENT WE'RE WE HAVE
AN ISSUE WITH SB SIX OH SIX A
PREVIOUS BILL SO IF YOU JUST
REMAIN IN PLACE FOR GOING TO
TAKE A SHORT BREAK AFTER THIS
BILL- AND THEN RESUME BY SHORT
I MEAN TWO MINUTES. ALL RIGHT-
SO HERTZBERG D. CHEMICALS YEAH
BRIEFLY I THINK I MADE ON MY
POINTS I DON'T WANT TO DO IS
JUST I DO YOU DON'T APPRECIATE
THE A QUESTIONING THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THIS LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT AND IF I
CAN'T DEFEND THIS BILL THAT YOU
GO DOWN. BUT I THINK I HAVE
DEFENDED IT IN THE ONLY POINT I
WANT TO MAKE. IS THAT. WE DON'T
MAKE LAWS AND HYPOTHETICALS. IF
TOMORROW SOMEBODY COMES UP WITH
ANOTHER BILL UNDER DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAN THEY COME
WITH DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES
EACH MEASURE WILL BE MERIT WILL
BE JUDGED ON ITS OWN MERITS
THIS IS SOLID THINKING IT'S
BASED UPON A LONG STORY
DECISIS- TRADITION IS RESULT OF
THE EEOC AND WE'RE CORRECTING A
BAD COURT DECISION AND JUST
EDGED IT IT'S NECESSARY FOR
ENFORCEMENT OF LAW TO PROTECT
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE SEEKING
PROTECTION. OF THE VIOLATION OF
THEIR CIVIL RIGHTS AS FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK SENATE
HERTZBERG MANAGE ACCOUNTS OF
YOUR CALL THE ROLL. YES THE
MOTION IS BY SORRY. THE MISSION
LAWCENTER WILL LIKE HEALTHCARE
CENTER I CASKET EMISSIONS BY
CENTER WHITE HOUSE SKI AND-
DISS SB SEVEN SEVEN FOUR BY
CENTERS HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS
D. PASSED TO THE SENATE FLOOR
UMBERG BY AMBER GUY BURGESS.
BUDGET PORTIS NO COPY ADAM. I
DID ALSO HI THE REST SO I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JONES. LAYERED BY
LAYERED AYE STERN. STERN AYE A
WEIGHT CAL SKI WORKOUTS SKI I
WINNER WINNER I WANT TO. SIX
SEVENTY NINE THAT'S NINE TWO
ONE AND YOU'RE MISSING A MEMBER
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL WE'RE GOING TO RECESS BUT
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU STAY IN
THE CHAMBER WE'RE GOING TO
RECESS FOR LESS THAN FOR TWO
MINUTES OR SO. SO WE'LL BE IN
RECESS FOR. TWO MINUTES.
WE'RE
GOING TO WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO SB SIX OH SIX BY CENTER
GONZALEZ- AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
THE ROLE ON SB SIX OH SIX THE
SENATE WHERE CENTER GONZALEZ.
ALL OKAY PUBLISHES OKAY GONNA
GO BACK TO SB SIX OH SIX ALL
RIGHT BENSHI COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD OPEN THE ROLE ON SB SIX
OH SIX. FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ARE UP
FORTUS CABALLERO. HERTZBERG
JONES YEAH THAT'S IT AND SO YOU
HAVE ONE TWO THREE FOUR FIVE
SIX YOU HAVE SEVEN TWO ZERO
FIVE THE MOTION PASSES ON
SUNDAY GONZALEZ YES MISTER
TRADE LIKE THE- A CALL MOTION
TO RECONSIDER AND REQUEST THAT
THE OPPOSITION SPEAK AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO RECONSIDERATION OF SB
SIX OF SIX THAT MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED- SO
NOW WE'RE GOING TO RETURN TO SB
SIX SO SIX- I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION ON SB SIX OH SIX. SO
THE BASICALLY THE RECORD HAS
BEEN VACATED THE VOTE HAS BEEN
VACATED LET'S GO BACK TO SB SIX
OH SIX I UNDERSTAND THAT MR
MOULTRIE IS ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION SB SIX OH SIX WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MR MOULTRIE ARE
GOING TO GO THE GALLERY WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
AND NEVER GOING TO GO THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX OH SIX SO MADAM
MODERATOR IF MR M<c.cyan> IS</c>
AVAILABLE- WOULD LIKE TO HEAR
FROM HIM. I'M HERE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MISTER MOULTRIE
LIMIT AND LET ME APOLOGIZE. FOR
WHATEVER GLITCH WHATEVER ERROR
MAY HAVE BEEN COMMITTED SO
MISTER M<c.cyan> GO AHEAD. NOT A</c>
WORRY MISTER KERRY I QUITE
UNDERSTAND THAT NONE OF IT WAS
INTENTIONAL AND YOU ALL ARE
VERY GOOD SO THANK YOU- THE-
CIRCLING BACK- AGAIN THIS IS
ROBERT MUTRIE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AT.
SIX THIRTY SIX I'D LIKE NOTED
WAS DOWNGRADED FROM A JOCULAR
DUE TO THE MARCH TWENTY FIFTH
AMENDMENTS CLARIFIED SOME OF
THE INITIAL EATING- VERY OVER
BROAD LANGUAGE THAT WE STILL
HAVE CONCERNS. INTO MOVED IN
QUICKLY IN THAT UNIT TIMELINE
FEEL. FREE AND FOR ME ONE TIME
IN THE LAST- PRESENT FOR. SB
SIX BIG THREE CYGNET NEW. I
FROM. AVERAGE TO REBUILD BUT
NINE. AS WELL AS NEW. ARE
PRECARIOUS AND- WITH THE-
NECESSARY GIVEN CURRENT LAW- IN
ADDITION IT'S CHANGES IN
HORSEMEN AND UNDERCUT THE
EXISTING REGULATORY PROCESS-
I'D LIKE TO CLARIFY A FEW
POINTS THAT WERE RAISED. BY
THE- SUPPORTERS. AT THE COUCHES
STAFFING ISSUES YOU AGREE THAT
THAT ISSUE FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
SOME TIME. HOWEVER THE BILL
DOES NOT ADDRESS STAFFING- THAT
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PRESENTLY BEING ADDRESSED IN
THIS BILL IS HIGHLY SEPARATE
FROM THAT POINT. NATALIE BUT
NOTABLY I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THIS BILL IS NOT
LIMITED TO COPE IN NINETEEN AND
IT CHANGES THE CALLOUS AND
THESE ARE LONG TERM STRUCTURAL
CHANGES- WHICH WE- SHOULD
RECOGNIZE FOR THEIR SCOPE AND
NOT JUST THAT SHORT TERM COVER
NINETEEN THAT. MEASURES IF THEY
WERE LIMITED TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN EMERGENCY REGULATION
DURATION OR THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY. THAT WOULD BE
DIFFERENT- WITHOUT. THE LIKE Q-
NO THAT DESPITE SOME MENTION OF
THIS NONE OF SB SIX THEY COULD.
ARE LIMITED TO LARGE AND- OR
LIMITED BY THE FACT EMPLOYER IN
ANYWAY. I'M TRYING TO SPECIFIC-
THE PRESUMPTIONS. HERE FIRST
REPEATED- UNNECESSARY GIVEN THE
PROTECTIONS HE CRAP ALLY IN THE
LABOR CODE. BUT NOTABLY WE
WOULD ASK THAT GOING FORWARD IT
THE ISSUE HERE IS CALLED THE
NINETEEN THAT THEY SHOULD BE
TIED TO THE DURATION OF THE
CALL THE NINETEEN EMERGENCY-
OTHERWISE WE APPEAR TO BE
CREATING. DISEASE SPECIFIC
PRESUMPTION THE RETALIATION
THAT WILL LAST IN PERPETUITY
AND WE DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
A GOOD PRACTICE GOING FORWARD-
TURNING BRIEFLY TO THE ISSUE OF
ENTERPRISE WIDE THANK HAITIANS
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I'LL
JUST TOUCH ON. KIND OF ONE
ISSUE HERE. THE ENTERPRISE WIDE
STAYCATION AS PRESENTLY DRAFTED
THIS BILL- ALLOW. FOR A- AS
DIFFERENT APPEALS PROCESS THAT
IN FACT- REQUIRED IN. TO START
KICKING BEFORE THE APPEAL
VACATION ESSENTIALLY BEFORE THE
COURT CONFIRMED IN FACT GET
ANYTHING WRONG- WE DISAGREE
WITH THAT AT THE POLICY BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY. THAT PACIFIC
PROCESS LAID OUT IN THE BILL.
IS NOT CLEAR AS TO WHEN AN
EMPLOYER HAS TO BEGIN TAKING
ACTION. ON THAT DIFFERENT
PROBLEMS SO THAT IF AN
EMPLOYER. OR PEOPLE. ALL THANK
YOU- WELL WITHOUT THEIR THANK
YOU FOR THE AUTHORS TO US ON
THAT YOU LOOK FOR TO CAN TO
SPEAK IN THEIR RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB SIX OF SIX THANK YOU
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR CIRCLING
BACK THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
MUTRIE WE'LL GET APOLOGIZE SO
ANYONE ELSE THAT IS KNOWN IN
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION IS NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE IN
OPPOSITION SO LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES IF THERE'S ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION
SB SIX OF SIX- PLEASE ANNOUNCE
YOURSELF MR OR MADAM MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD. OPEN THE LINES-
AN OPPOSITION OF THE- THERE ARE
SIX OH SIX. WE HAVE MY NUMBER.
TWO SEVENTY TWO. THESE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE DIAGRAM IF
YOU W. THERE'S AT THE BORDERS
YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO SPEAK IF I
CAN I'M OUT THERE THAT TO THE
RECORD. I'M HAPPY TO GIVE AT
THE END OF THAT MORE HELPFUL.
BUT BUT I'M SORRY DID. THEY
DIDN'T QUITE UNDERSTAND THAT
DOES. MISCARRY WALL IF THERE'S
OTHERS IN SUPPORT I BELIEVE
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT- WE'RE NOW
IN OPPOSITION OF COURSE YOU
WERE FREE TO AUGMENT THE RECORD
WITH ANY WRITING YOU WISH-
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS PATHOLOGY DOT COM
BEHALF OF PUBLIC RISK
INNOVATION SOLUTIONS AND
MANAGEMENT OF PRISON ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH A COMPANY CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE LINE NUMBER. TWO
EIGHTY ONE. MY NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HEY WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER.
TWO EIGHTY THREE. HE WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA GROCERS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION SEPTEMBER. THANK
YOU. AND THEN WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER TWO FIFTY ONE. KEVIN
ANDERSON N BEHALF OF FAMILY
WINEMAKER OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE WESTERN CAR WASH
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE A
LINE NUMBER. ONE FIFTY SEVEN.
MY NUMBER ONE FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. VERY WE WILL MOVE
TO LINE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF HIS
BRADBURY WITH UNITED
CONTRACTORS IN OPPOSITION SB
SIX OH SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CAN YOU MAIL WE WILL GO BACK TO
LINE NUMBER TWO EIGHTY ONE. YOU
MIGHT HAVE YOURSELF ON MUTE AT
THE OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME. I
CAN HEAR YOU NOW. GREAT
ADVOCATING HAMPTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION ARE OPPOSED. THANK
YOU. AND OUR LAST ONE COMES ON
THE LINE UP TO EIGHTY SEVEN. HI
THIS IS JAMIE CONN ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS WHO WERE OPPOSED TO
SB. SIX AT SIX. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND WE DO HAVE ONE MORE
CUTE AT THE ONE FIFTY SEVEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS BRIAN
LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY MORE IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ARE NOT A MODERATOR-
CENTER GONZALEZ- WE HAVE TO GO
BACK TO THE BEGINNING TO SOME
DEGREE DO YOU ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AS PROPOSED. YES
MISTER CHARITY ART THANK YOU
SENATE GONZALEZ ALL RIGHT- IS
THERE MOTION. SENATOR ALSO
MOVES THE BILL- THE SENATE
DROPPED THE SENDER GONZALEZ G.
CARE CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL RESEARCHER THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. ON THIS BEEN IN MOTION
BY SENATOR RUSSELL OF BENCI
COUNSEL IF YOU WOULD CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS SB SIX ZERO SIX BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR THE MOTION
BY SENATOR DID ALSO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND THEN RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE HI. I'M BY BOARD YES.
PORGES ESPYS. OH SIX. REPELS
FERRIERO HI CABALLERO I DID AYE
SO. DID I SO I GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE JONES JONES NO LAYERED.
LAYERED HI STERN STERN AYE
STERN AYE A WHITE CAL SKI HIGH
WEIGHT CAL SKI I WIENER. WIENER
BY- ONE ONE SECOND THE BOARD
JUST DID YOU WANT TO VOTE. YOU
WANT TO GO BACK FOR I GUESS
IT'S CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS
OKAY- BARGES NO BORJAS NO SAID
THAT VOTE HAS. TO THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT NINE TWO
TWO ALL RIGHT THAT'S THE POOL
COMMITTEE SO THAT THE BILL IS
OUT. ALL RIGHT THE ICC HUESO
SERVICE THANK YOU FOR BEING SO
PATIENT. AT THE CENTER HUESO SK
R. NUMBER TWO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THIS PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- IT'S MY-
PLEASURE TO PRESENT AS J. R.
TWO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A
RESOLUTION THAT WOULD CALL. ON
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENACT
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM I'VE BEEN PART OF THIS
LEGISLATURE FOR OVER TEN YEARS
NOW AND IN THOSE TEN YEARS. WE
HAVE WORKED TO SEND A MESSAGE
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
DIFFERENT SUBJECTS RELATED TO
IMMIGRATION BUT THIS ISN'T THE
ISN'T THE FIRST TIME WITH US
FOR COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM. GOING BACK TO TWENTY
TWELVE TWENTY FOURTEEN WE EVEN
HAD A REPAIR REPUBLICAN LED
EFFORT BY CENTER FIGHT ACT ON
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM. THIS BILL. MORE WORK
ALONG SAME AREAS ASKING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO ENACT A
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM THE TIMES NOW WHICH IS
VERY IMPORTANT THAT OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA- REALLY THAT OUR
ENTIRE COUNTRY MOVE FORWARD ON
SOMETHING THAT IS IN OUR BEST
INTERESTS. CURRENTLY THERE ARE
AN ESTIMATED ELEVEN MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS IN THE
UNITED STATES TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION CALL CALIFORNIA HOME.
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
CONTRIBUTE TO. OUR ECONOMY TO
OUR SOCIETY WE HAVE BEEN- THE%
TAXPAYERS HAVE BEEN PAYING TO
EDUCATE A LOT OF THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE- ACTUALLY A LOT OF THESE
DOCTORS STUDENTS MANY OF THEM
WITH COLLEGE DEGREES. THAT ARE
WELL DESERVING OF A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP. AS OF THE MOST
RICH. STATE IMMIGRANT RICH
STATE IN THE NATION ONE IN TEN
CALIFORNIA WORKERS ARE
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS ARE
UNDOCUMENTED. THE LOGICAL AND
STREAMLINED PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP WOULD STIMULATE OUR
NATION'S ECONOMY IT WOULD HELP
OF UNITE FAMILIES WHO WOULD DO
SO MANY THINGS THAT ARE. IN IN
IN THE VEIN OF WHAT IS GOOD FOR
OUR COMMUNITY HELLO I'M CALLING
ON ALL OF US TO UNITE. BOTH
BOTH PARTIES SMALL ALL SEGMENTS
OF OUR COMMUNITY TO GET BEHIND
A MESSAGE TO WASHINGTON THAT IS
TIME. THEY START WORKING ON
THIS IT'S BEEN OVER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS SAID ANY MEANINGFUL WORK.
ON ON ON IMMIGRATION REFORM HAS
BEEN DONE IN WASHINGTON. YET WE
HAVE SOME CHILDREN THAT WERE.
RAISED HERE FROM A VERY YOUNG
AGE ONE TO THREE YEARS OLD THE
WORK EDUCATED IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ARE CURRENTLY WORKING-
FOR A BUSINESS OURSELVES. AREA
OF OUR ECONOMY CONTRIBUTING YET
THEY ARE STILL LIVING IN THE
SHADOWS. AND WITHOUT. THE
PROPER PROPER. VISIT US
CITIZENSHIP MANY OF THEM WISH
TO APPLY BUT REALLY FRANKLY
THERE REALLY IS NO REAL PATHWAY
TO CITIZENSHIP. MY FATHER CAME
TO AMERICA NAY CHIU FORTY NINE
THE CROSS THE BORDER LEGALLY IT
THAT PERMIT IS ACTUALLY ON FILE
ON THE INTERNET YOU CAN FIND
IT. THAT THE PERMIT HE GOT HE
WAS A NE DAY BERMAN HE WALKED
INTO AN OFFICE. GOT A PERMIT TO
COME INTO THE COUNTRY TO ENTER
LEGALLY HE WORK LEGALLY. BY
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO IT WAS A US
CITIZEN HIPLIFE IN NINETEEN
FIFTY TWO TO BE A US CITIZEN
TODAY IF YOU APPLY TO BECOME A
US CITIZEN. THEY COULD TAKE YOU
TEN FIFTEEN EVEN TWENTY YEARS.
THAT REALLY IS NO VIABLE OF
PROCESS TO ENTER THE COUNTRY
LEGALLY SO MANY PEOPLE THE WHAT
IS LEGALLY OUT OF DESPERATION.
AND IT IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT WE
FIND A WAY TO DO THIS IN A WAY
THAT MAKES SENSE FOR MODERN
TIMES FOR THE OF THIS MODERN
ECONOMY FOR OUR SOCIETY. THAT
IF WE DID ANYTHING AT ALL TO
ALLOW THESE YOUNG DR- THAT KIDS
TO BE ADMITTED I MEAN THEY WERE
BORN THEY WERE PRACTICALLY. A
FULLY RAISED IN THIS COUNTRY
THEY SHOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BECOME CITIZENS FIRST AT THE
VERY LEAST. BUT IN THIS-
DOCUMENT- IT A STATES GOLDBERG.
I HOPE- YOU CAN. THIS IS NEEDED
OVERDUE. AND I WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE YOUR SUPPORT. ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT WOULD
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATE HUESO I
UNDERSTAND THAT MR JORGE SILVA
ASSEMBLY PRESIDENT VALLEY
COLLEGE IS ON THE LINE. THAT
CORRECT MATAMATA RAIDER. IN AND
MR SILVA ONLINE IF YOU LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES.
OKAY AWESOME- WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN TOM BURKE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF G. R. TIL CALLING
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
BACK AND IMPLEMENT
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM. OKAY SILVA ON THE
TWENTY FIRST ASSEMBLY PRECEDENT
ARAMBULA COLLEGE I WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN CALIFORNIA AND HAVE
LIVED IN CALIFORNIA FOR FIVE
YEARS. KAMALA RATS AND I'M
CURRENTLY ON THE PATH TO
BECOMING A UNITED STATES
CITIZEN I UNDERSTAND THE
PRIVILEGE I HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE ALL MY GOALS AND
BECAUSE OF THAT I FEEL
OBLIGATED TO SPEAK FOR ALL MY
STUDENT PEERS CONSTANTLY LIVE
IN FEAR CONFERENCE FUTURE. MY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
APPELLATION OVER 90% BUT IMPACT
BECAUSE. OF ITS CLOSE PROXIMITY
TO THE BORDER. FORTUNATELY
BASED IN F. OF THE MEMBERS AND
THALIDOMIDE. AND FAMILIES IN.
IN OUR SCHOOL AND OUR- I'M HERE
TO SPEAK ON MY OWN MY BE HAPPY
IN THE SMALL AMOUNT OF THAT I
HAVE SPENT IN NEARLY. ROLE I
HAVE HEARD SO MANY. AND TRIED
STORY ABOUT COMMITTED TO ORDER
TO WHICH THEIR IN. ADORATION I
DON'T HAVE TO TELL ME ARE NOT
ABLE TO IT I DO A I THINK HELP
THEM. BECAUSE THEY COMPLICATED.
STATUS I HAVE HEARD FROM.
FIGURE BILL DID. CHILDREN
EFFORT TO CLASS BECAUSE THEY
FEEL THEY CAN MAKE IT YOU
STARTED MAKE THEM BOTH LED BY
LEGAL. AND HAVE HER FRIENDS FOR
ME THAT OUT OF. THE PROJECT. OF
THEM AND FAMILIES THEY WHICH
SCARED TO BE REGISTER OR APPLY.
SO MANY OF MY SOME OF THEM BY
TO RESTRICT TAX. THEIR AND WE-
TO CONTINUE TO CALIFORNIA
PURSUING AN EDUCATION AND BY
WORKING HARD TO UPLIFT THEIR
FAMILIES IN THE COMMUNITY M.
FOR ABOUT A WEEK. YES THEY ARE
NOT ABLE TO FULLY PARTICIPATE
IN OUR ECONOMY OUR SOCIETY IN
OUR COMMUNITY THINK ABOUT ALL
THE LEGAL. THAT MAKE THEM FEEL
ON A WANTED AND LET OUT. HOW
THE ABILITY TO REMIND YOU ALL
OF THE RESPONSIBILITY WE HAVE A
LEADERS TO ADVOCATE FOR AND
EMPOWER THOSE WHO NEED. IT THE
MOST. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER- OTHERS THAT ARE
TESTIFYING AND I SEE ONE IN THE
I SEE NO ONE IN REAL ONE TO.
AND MATAMATA WRITER IF YOU
WOULD UP THE ON THE PHONE LINE
SUPPORT. OF THE MEDIA REMIND
THEM THAT THAT THEY SHALL GIVE
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR POSITION. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE S. J. R. Q.
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO THE LINE UP
TO EIGHTY EIGHT. OKAY THAT LINE
HAS DROPPED AND THERE ARE NO
OTHERS CUTE. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR NOW LET'S TURN THE
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE LINE A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION I'VE NOT IDENTIFIED.
META MODERATORS ANYONE
IDENTIFIED HIMSELF OR HERSELF
IS IN OPPOSITION PRIMARY
OPPOSITION. OPPOSITION THE
FIRST ONE AND THEN ZERO. THEN I
DO NOT SEE ANYBODY QUEUING UP
FOR OPPOSITION THANK YOU I SEE
NO ONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- LET'S
BRING IT BACK HERE TO THE FLOOR
CENTER THE RUSSELLS MICROPHONE
IS UPS. CENTER THE ROSSELL.
THANK YOU I'M PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR. OF THIS AND I THANK- A
SENATOR OF FOR BRINGING THIS
ISSUE UP. WE TAKE IT FOR
GRANTED I BEEN INVOLVED AT THE-
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION- ISSUES. A
SINCE PRESIDENT REAGAN SIGNED.
AMNESTY BILL IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX WE HAVEN'T HAD ANYTHING
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX TO
THE BENEFIT OF THOSE IMMIGRANTS.
THERE IS A ENTIRE INDUSTRIES
AND THAT KIND OF CALIFORNIA.%
THAT ARE ENTIRELY DEPENDENT ON
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS OR
SIGNIFICANTLY DEPENDENT SO
THERE SHOULDN'T BE A SINGLE
PART OF THE STATE WHERE PEOPLE
AREN'T. SHOWING APPRECIATION
FROM LANDSCAPING AGRICULTURE TO
GARMENT TO RESTAURANTS
HOSPITALS CONSTRUCTION YOU NAME
IT SO- AGAIN I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF BECAUSE THEY ARE PART AND
PARCEL OF OUR COMMUNITY 75% ARE
OF MIXED STATUS FAMILIES. THE
AVERAGE LENGTH IS TEN YEARS OF
LIVING IN THIS COUNTRY AND
CONTRIBUTING OUR RIGHTS TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THE
USER THAT ALSO CENTER WHAT
CASCADE YOUR MICROPHONE UP. YES
HI THE SECURE HI I'M ALSO WILL
BE SUPPORTING THE SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION I KNOW THAT MOST OF
THE ATTENTION WILL GO TOWARDS.
THE REFORMS ON IMMIGRATION
STATUS AND DACA AND THOSE
THINGS BUT I'M PARTICULARLY-
IT'S PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT YOU KNOW OUR
WORDS MATTER AND THE CODES
MATTER AND STRIKING. THE WORD
ALIEN FROM ALL THE FEDERAL CODE
TO SOMETHING THAT IS LONG
OVERDUE. DO YOU SEE THE USE OF
WORDS CAN BE VERY HURTFUL AND
HATEFUL QUITE FRANKLY WITH THAT
AND ALSO I THINK THE RESOLUTION
THAT. IT ENDS WITH OF HOLDING
DUE PROCESS WHICH AGAIN
SOMETIMES WE TAKE FOR GRANTED
BUT IN. IN A SYSTEM WITH THAT
THAT WE HAVE WITH IMMIGRATION-
WE ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE JUDGES
WE HAVE EMPLOYEES WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BUT
THAT'S NOT. BEFORE US TODAY
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THAT THAT
THOSE ELEMENTS ARE EMPHASIZED
AGAINST WILL BE SUPPORTING IT.
THANK YOU SIR WHITE HOUSE
CONCERN HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN KNOW I DON'T
NORMALLY SEE AND RISEN- I HOPE
I SIGN AND BILLS. BUT I SIGNED
ON THIS RESOLUTION BECAUSE- THE
TIME IS NOW WE HAVE HAD THIS
DISCUSSION I THINK SINCE.
EIGHTY SIX. THESE ARE
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES AND-
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE A STATEMENT
WE'VE GOTTA PUT THAT REALLY PUT
SOME ELBOW GREASE INTO THIS AND
IT WHAT DOES IT SAY WHAT IS
RESOLUTION SAME SIMPLE TERMS
FIVE POINTS AND I WILL RAISE
THEM. FOR THE RECORD. ONE
MAINTAINING FAMILY STRUCTURES.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE CARE
ABOUT A LOT IN THIS LEGISLATURE
CARRY ALL SORTS OF LEGISLATION
THAT DEALS WITH IT. TOO
CREATING A PATHWAY FOR
CITIZENSHIP FOR DACA RECIPIENTS
AGAIN ISSUES THAT WE HAVE DEALT
WITH TIME AND TIME AGAIN IN
THIS HOUSE IN THIS LEGISLATURE
IN THIS GOVERNMENT THREE.
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY FOR
ASYLUM SEEKERS HUGELY IMPORTANT
FOR UPGRADING THE CURRENT VISA
PROGRAMS IN ORDER TO HAVE LEGAL
WORK FORCE IN THE SYSTEM THAT
BETTERED FORCS LABOR
PROTECTION. THAT'S NOT VERY
RADICAL AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S FUNDAMENTALLY NECESSARY
AND SOMETHING WE TALK ABOUT AND
IT'S AN ACCOUNTS HE SAID. A
LIMITING THE TERM ALIEN AND UP
HOLDING DUE PROCESS THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL AND SACRED RIGHTS
THAT ALL OF US HAVE. IN WHAT
THIS CONSTITUTION THIS
COUNTRY'S ABOUT. IT IS TIME.
SIGNED ON THIS IS IMPORTANT
STRONGLY SUPPORTED. I THINK ALL
OF US G. TO WORK HARD BUT WE
HAVE A WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY
NOW. TO GET THIS DONE AS FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU SIR
HERTZBERG ANYONE ELSE CARE TO
SPEAK SAYING NO OTHER
MICROPHONES REYES- SERVICE.
OCCUR CLOSER MOTION. SIMILAR
MOVE- SIR SO YOU CLOTHES. I
THANK THE GOOD CENTERS THEIR-
VERY SUPPORTIVE COMMENTS AND
JUST SIMPLY ASK FOR. I LOVED US
FOR EVERYONE SUPPORT NICE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE AND THIS.
EXTENDS UP TO ALL PARTS OF OUR
STATE. AT ALL LEVELS SO WOULD
BE NICE TO HAVE- A UNITED VOICE
BEHIND- THIS MESSAGE TO
WASHINGTON. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SEVEN HUESO A MENTION CAL
SIMPLY CALL THE ROLL THIS IS S.
J. R. TWO BY SENATOR WAS SO. UP
WITH THE MOTION BY SENATOR
LAYERED. THE MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED ORDERED TO THIRD
READING- BURKE HI I'M BURKE AYE
PORGES. CABALLERO CAPITAL I DID
ALSO DID I SO I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
AYE JONES. JONES NOT VOTING
LAYERED HI LAYERED I STERN
STERN AYE STERN HIGHWAY CAL SKI
ARE LIKE CASKEY AYE WIENER. HEY
WE HAVE ONE IN. YEP EIGHT ZERO
SO FAR ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL THANK YOU SIR HUESO
CENTER LEYVA. CENTER LEYVA.
THANK YOU ALSO FOR YOUR
PATIENCE NEXT BILL IS ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN S. SEVEN EIGHT
BY CENTER LEVEL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS YOU SEEM
LIKE YOU HAVE A SPICY LITTLE A-
HEARING SO FAR. S. B. TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT IS A
REINTRODUCTION OF SB TWO SIXTY
SIX WHICH WAS PASSED BY THIS
HOUSE IN THE ASSEMBLY WAS
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
HOWEVER WAS PULLED BACK FROM
ENGROSSING AND ENROLLING IN THE
HOPES OF NEGOTIATING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION UNFORTUNATELY
DUE TO COVERT NINETEEN OF THE
NEGOTIATIONS WERE NOT ABLE TO
HAPPEN THEREFORE WE RE
INTRODUCED AND HAVE TO SEVENTY
EIGHT THIS IS BONE THIS IS
PROTECTS PROMISED AND PAID FOR
RETIREMENT BENEFITS OF CALPERS
MEMBERS BY MAKING SURE NO HARM
COMES TO A RETIREE. FOR ANY
COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED PENSION
COMPENSATION THAT WAS REPORTED
TO THE SYSTEM THIS MAJOR
RESPONSE TO CASES IN WHICH
PENSIONABLE COMPENSATION OF
RETIRED EMPLOYEES AS RECTOR
RETROACTIVELY DEEMED DISALLOWED
BY CALPERS IN THESE INSTANCES
THE RETIRED EMPLOYEES ARE
FORCED TO PAY BACK THE TOTAL
OVERPAID AMOUNT AS WELL SUFFER
PERMANENT REDUCTIONS IN THEIRPENSION. MOST RETIREES LIVE ON
A FIXED INCOME AND SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO EXPERIENCE UNEXPECTED
CUTS TO THEIR BENEFITS
CERTAINLY AT NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN LONG AFTER THEY HAVE
RETIRED SB TWO SEVENTY EIGHTS
GIVES RETIREES IMPORTANT PEACE
OF MIND THAT THE RETIREMENT
THAT THEY EARNED AND PAID FOR
OVER A LIFE OF PUBLIC SERVICE
WILL CONSISTENTLY BE. THERE
THROUGHOUT THE RETIREMENT YEARS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS IS A PROCESS
FOR CALPERS AND EMPLOYERS TO
WORK TOGETHER TO PROTECT
RETIREE BENEFITS AND PREVENT
THESE INSTANCES FROM EVER
HAPPENING IN THE FIRST PLACE.
SB TWO SEVENTY EIGHT ALSO
COMPELS EMPLOYERS TO KEEP THEIR
PROMISE TO RETIREES AND HOLD
THEM HARMLESS FROM ANY
REDUCTIONS TO THE RETIREMENT AS
A RESULT OF DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION. SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IS DOUG SUPERS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND WHEN APPROPRIATE
MEMBERS AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THEY SAY LEYVA THE STEAMERS.
THANK YOU MISTER JUSTIN WAS IN
THE GALLERY THANK YOU GO AHEAD
SIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS- DOUG SERVERS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS. WE
ARE PLEASED TO SPONOR SB TWO
SEVEN NAME LIKE TO THANK CENTER
LEYVA FOR HER ONGOING WORK ON
THIS ISSUE AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE- DETAILED
ANALYSIS. THIS ISSUE FIRST CAME
TO THE C. P. F. ONE A
FIREFIGHTER EMPLOYED BY THE
CITY OF DAVIS- RETIRED AFTER
SERVING NEARLY THIRTY THIRTY
YEARS- SERVING THE PUBLIC FOR
THIRTY YEARS- AFTER FIVE YEARS
OF RETIREMENT CALPERS NOTIFIED
THE- RETIRED FIREFIGHTER. THAT
OKAY ITEM THAT WAS SUBMITTED BY
THE CITY OF DAVIS WAS
DETERMINED TO BE DISALLOWED
CONSEQUENTLY CALPERS- SOUGHT
TO. SEEK REIMBURSEMENTFOR THE
OVERPAYMENT NOT FROM THE CITY
OF DAVIS WHO HAD BARGAINED THE
SPECIAL COMPENSATION ITEM BUT
FROM THE RETIRED FIREFIGHTER-
THE REIMBURSEMENTS OFF I
CALPERS INCLUDED A LUMP SUM OF
FORTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
A SUBSTANTIAL REDUCTION IN THE-
FIREFIGHTERS PAY GOING FORWARD.
GOING FORWARD LIKE MANY
RETIREES ON A FIREFIGHTER A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER OR OR
SCHOOL EMPLOYEE RETIRE THEY
RELY ON THEIR- PENSION FOR
THEIR DAY TO DAY- INCOME NEEDS.
UNLIKE MANY PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYEES FIREFIGHTERS AND
OTHERS OFTENTIMES DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO SECURE SOCIAL
SECURITY BENEFITS MAKING THIS-
THEIR PENSION THEIR ONLY SOURCE
OF INCOME IN RETIREMENT. THIS
BILLS EXPERT TO PROTECT THE
RETIREE BY ENSURING THAT A
BENEFIT THAT WAS BARGAINED FOR
IS MAINTAINED AND THE SITUATION
THAT HAPPENED TO THE DAVIS
FIREFIGHTER DOESN'T HAPPEN TO
FUTURE RETIREES. EXISTING LAW
AND CALPERS REGULATION HAS
ESTABLISHED RULES AROUND THESE
CATEGORIES OF COMPENSATION
EXAMPLES OF THE COMPENSATION
OUR LONGEVITY PAY HAZARD PAY
EDUCATIONAL INCENTIVE PAY AND
EXAMPLES OF THE RULES OR-
THINGS LIKE THAT TYPE OF THAT
SPECIFIC COMPENSATION ITEM
NEEDS TO BE OFFERED TO THE
ENTIRE RIVER CLASS. IF THESE
COMPENSATION ITEMS ARE NOT
IMPLEMENTED A REPORTED
CORRECTLY WE COULD FIND A
SITUATION WHERE PAY ITEM IS
DISALLOWED BY THE SYSTEM AND
THE RETIREE NEEDS TO- BEAR THE
BURDEN OF THAT OVERPAYMENT OR
FUTURE REDUCTION. GENERATIONS
OF HARD WORKING MEMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA'S MIDDLE CLASS OF
DEDICATED THEIR CAREERS THIS
PUBLIC SERVICE OFTEN ARE
EARNING LESS OVER THE COURSE OF
THEIR CAREERS- THEN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR- COUNTERPARTS- TO EARN
AND PAY FOR THE PROMISE OF A
SECURE RETIREMENT. WE BELIEVE
SB TWO SEVEN EIGHT IS IMPORTANT
MEASURE TO PROTECT THE PROMISE
OF THAT SECURE RETIREMENT AND
FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE ARRIVAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU THE SEWERS AS ARE
ONLY IN PERSON WITNESS HERE
TODAY WE APPRECIATE YOU
CHANGING. IT UP FOR US. ALL
RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT-
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THERE BEING NONE- NO THE
WINDOWS IN THE GALLERY NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES TO TAKE THOSE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF F. B. TWO
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
IF SENDS EURO. AND WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE UP TO NINETY FOUR.
TWO NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THEY WILL MOVE ON TO THE
LINE NUMBER TO NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IMAGE
FACTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IMPORT.
SAME STEIGER. THAT IS MY NUMBER
K TWENTY FIVE. MEMBERS
PARTNERING WITH THEIR READING
OF SUBSTANCE REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS. COURT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYMORE IN SUPPORT ON
THE LINE ALL RIGHT LET'S NOT
TURN THE OPPOSITION I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE- DYLAN
GIVENS AS WELL AS BE JOHN MAY
YOUR MAY ARE OF LET'S START
WITH MR DYLAN GIVENS. MISTER
GIVENS IS ON. THERE WE GO YEAH
HERE'S THIS RICHARD MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE- KILLING GIVENS
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TWO SEVEN.
ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIFTY. BUT I COULD
YOU. FOR THE MOMENT THE BILL
OUR- WE REMAIN OPPOSED BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING TOWARDS A
RESOLUTION MARKETS. IS TRULY
UNFORTUNATE RETIREES HAVE THE
PENSIONS CUT OFF THEIR OWN WE
SHOULD WORK TOGETHER TO FIGHT
READY THIS WELL THAT THE FACT
THAT TAKEN TO PREVENT IT FROM
EVER HAPPENING. IN THE FIRST
PLACE. I IF YOU CHOOSE YOU BOB
YOU RECORD IT REMEDY AT THIS.
FOR MAKING RETIREES PENSIONS
ARE ALL. ONE CAL SIX STEPS TO
DISALLOW. BENEFITS BECAUSE THE
BENEFITS BY LATE LAW HOW ARE TO
PAY TO VIOLATE THE LAW THANK A
FEW. SHE BE UNABLE TO PAY FOR A
PENSION BENEFITS PROBABLY THE
LAW. FIRING THESE HEY I'M
PENSIONS AND BY THAT SHOULD.
CERTAIN THAT THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES PENSION REFORM ACT
BETTER KNOWN AFTER. BY
GOVERNMENT FEET A SIMILAR BILL
INTRODUCED. EACH SEMESTER. OF
DEATH WILL IN PART- THIS BILL
WILL ESTABLISH FROM THE SHE- IN
THANK YOU. CALCULATED PENSION
BENEFITS IN CASES WHERE SOLD.
AND RETIRED HIGHER THAT YOU GET
THAT STUFF OUT LAW THIS YEAR
THE OPTIONS EXTENSION MUST BE
CALCULATED TO THE LAW ON THE
FIRST. THAT EVER. NEVER FIND.
ON THE PROGRAM. EVERY YOU
CORRECTED SHE SHE- I'M THAT
THIS BILLS TO BE COULD EASILY
USE TO SEARCH THE AGENTS OR.
THE GOVERNMENT AND ULTIMATELY
TAXPAYERS WITHIN. THAT
PROVISION DOESN'T GO FAR ENOUGH
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT REQUIRE
CALPERS IS CERTIFIED BY THE
THEY REFUSE LANGUAGE THAT
AFFECTED YOUR- THANK YOU MISTER
GIVEN ITSELF BY. THANK YOU SIR-
NEXT WE'LL MOVE TO MISTER BIJAN
MAY ARE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
DETER ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- WE REGRETFULLY
HAVE TO CONTINUE OPPOSING THIS
MEASURE TODAY AS MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER GIVENS NOTED WE HAVE
DEEP CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS MEASURE
WOULD MEAN. FOR US AND FOR THE
STABILITY OF THE RETIREMENT
SYSTEM. THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
MEASURE WOULD EFFECTIVELY ALLOW
AN END RUN AROUND. IN CREATE A
MORAL HAZARD TO PUBLIC AGENCIES
BECAUSE THEY COULD PUT WHATEVER
THEY WANT IN THE DEMO YOU
KNOWING THAT IT COULD BE
CIRCUMVENT THAT AT ANY POINT
NAY TO CONTINUE MAKING. THOSE
PAYMENTS BEYOND THAT WE ALSO
FEEL INCREDIBLY STRONGLY THAT
MORE RESOURCES ARE NEEDED FROM
CALPERS IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR MO USE ARE CERTIFIED
RYAN WITH THE PEARL AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE MISTAKES DON'T
HAPPEN. WE SHARE THE AUTHOR'S
INTEREST IN MAKING SURE THAT
RETIREES ARE PROTECTED HOWEVER
PLATING THE FISCAL LIABILITY ON
PUBLIC AGENCIES FOR BENEFITS
THAT THEY NEGOTIATED IN GOOD
FAITH BECAUSE DETERMINATION BUT
ARE MADE BY CALPERS. IT WILL
CREATE SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS IN
OUR ADMINISTRATION AND IN OUR
FISCAL CONDITION GIVEN WHERE WE
ARE BECAUSE OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND ENDEMIC
INDUCED RECESSION. WE SIMPLY
REQUEST MORE TIME TO WORK
THROUGH THESE ISSUES AND MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THE RESOURCES WE
NEED. ADDITIONALLY WE DO FEEL
STRONGLY THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
LEGAL QUESTION THAT CAN BE
RAISED. BECAUSE OF THE PAYMENT
AND WHETHER OR NOT HELP- THE
DETERMINING OF THE DISALLOWED
COMPENSATION MAKE THEM ILLEGAL
AND WHETHER WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE MAKING THOSE PAYMENTS
WE KNOW THAT IT'S AN ISSUE. OF
LEGAL DISAGREEMENT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO MORE CONVERSATION
BUT AGAIN WE DO THINK MORE
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE MISTAKES ARE
MADE IN THE FUTURE AND PUBLIC
AGENCIES AREN'T BUT HOLDING THE
BAG FOR MISTAKES THAT CALPERS
MAKE. AND THEN CORRECT ON THEIR
OWN. DOWN THE LINE. THANK YOU
MR CARE. THANK YOU SIR. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS WHO WERE IN
OPPOSITION- THERE ARE NO OTHERS
IN THE GALLERY NO OTHERS IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE SO IF WE TURN
TO THE PHONE LINE. IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO SEVENTY
ZERO. THEN WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE UP TO NINETY NINE. I GET
AFTERNOON ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU. IN THE NEXT LINE IS. TO
EIGHTY NINE. MY NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IT WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT LINE
OF ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAMELA KIDS
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THEN MY NUMBER Q. NINETY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
THIS IS DIRECTLY ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION. APPLE
COMPETITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT NUMBER. TWO SEVENTY SIX.
AN AMATEUR MEMBERS CARE AWESOME
BEHALF OF THE TOWN OF TRUCKEE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER. THREE
HUNDRED THREE ZERO ZERO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. THEN THE LAST ONE WE
HAVE IN QUEUE HERE TO NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JEFF
AKA REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE AND THERE ARE NO
MORE MORTGAGE YOU. THERE IS NO
ONE IN CURING THEM THANK YOU
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
CHAMBER I SEE NO MICROPHONES
REYES- IS THERE A MOTION.
GIPSON JONES I'M SORRY DID YOU
HEAR MY PHONE UP I DID NOT
MISTER CHAIR BUT YOU MOVED
FASTER THAN I WAS ABLE TO
RESPOND TO SIR THANK YOU FOR
CALLING ME APPRECIATE IT- I
REMEMBER THIS. BILL FROM LAST
YEAR AND I AND I VOTED AGAINST
IT AND- AND I WAS TRYING TO
REMEMBER WHY ME- BECAUSE THE-
THE WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT HAVE
A REALLY COMPELLING. STORY AND-
YOU KNOW I CERTAINLY WOULD ONE
FIND MYSELF IN THAT POSITION SO
I HAVE YOU KNOW ONE IN
RECOLLECT RECALLING FROM LAST
YEAR THE CONCERN WAS A GIFT OF
PUBLIC FUNDS YOU KNOW WHETHER
CALPERS KEEPS PAYING YOU KNOW I
THINK THAT'S ONE ARGUMENT THAT
THEY'RE MAKING IS IT'S A IT'S A
GIFT OF PUBLIC FUNDS OR NOW IF
THE CITY IS REQUIRED TO PAY IT-
IT STILL WOULD BE A GIFT OF
PUBLIC FUNDS HAVE YOU
CONTEMPLATED THAT.
INSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGE. PHONON
THERE WE GO YES WE HAVE IT THE
SHORT ANSWER IS IT IS NOT A
GIFT OF PUBLIC FUNDS AND IT IS
NOT UNCONSTITUTIONAL I THINK
THERE'S SOME CONFUSION THERE
OKAY I'M GONNA SUPPORT TODAY
MISTER SCHECK THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU MISTER JONES ALL
RIGHT. SENATE JONES OTHER- C.
KNOW THE MICROPHONES THERE
MOTION. CENTER LAYERED. MOVES
THE BILL- SENATE LEVEL WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST WANNA BE REALLY
CLEAR THAT THESE ARE NOT
MISTAKES THAT CALPERS HAS MADE
THE EMPLOYERS NEGOTIATED AND-
USE AND CBA'S THAT MAY HAVE
BEEN OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH
CALPERS OUR HOPE IS THAT WITH
THIS BILL IF IT GETS SIGNED
INTO LAW. THAT THE EMPLOYERS
AND CALPERS WILL WORK TOGETHER
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS NEVER
HAPPENS AGAIN WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIMILARLY THE
MINUTE SHE COUNTS OF YOU CALL
THE ROLL SKEPSIS SPT SEVENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR LEYVA AND THE
MOTION IS BY SENATOR LAYERED TO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE HI.
AMBERG BY PORGES- CARRIE IT
OVER. DID I SO DID I SO I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE JONES JONES I
LAYERED LAYERED I STERN GEN
NINE STERN I WAKE HOUSEKI. WHAT
KASKY FIVE WIENER THAT'S THE
THING THAT'S EIGHT ZERO SO FAR
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT ON
CALL THANK YOU SIR LEYVA NEXT
WE HAVE THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
IRVINE WITH S. B. THREE NINE
ONE. SINNER MAN SOON THE FLOOR
WILL BE YOURS. THANK YOU CARE
ARMOR AGAIN THANK YOU THE
COMMITTEE STAFF OF AND WORKING
WITH OUR OFF MY STAFF ON THIS
BILL. I SPECIFICALLY I WANT TO
THANK TIM GRIFFIN'S PRETEND
GRIFFIS I'M SORRY WAS HELPLESS
CRAP NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL
AND AS I'LL DISCUSS I'M HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSING ANALYSIS THANK YOU
SENATOR- SB THREE NINETY ONE
AUTHORIZES COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT. BOARDS TO SAFELY
MEET VIA TELECONFERENCE OR
VIDEOCONFERENCE DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS ANISH
INSURERS THAT FAIR
PARTICIPATION IN THESE MEETINGS
IS ACCESSIBLE TO MEMBERS. AS
YOU ALL PROBABLY KNOW THE DAVIS
STERLING COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT ACT REQUIRES THE
ID'S TO PROVIDE A PHYSICAL
MEETING LOCATION FOR ALL
MEETINGS- WHICH AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE CAN POSE SIGNIFICANT
RISKS DURING EMERGENCIES I LIKE
THE KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC OR.
ANY NUMBER THE WILDFIRES WE
FACE RECENTLY. LAST YEAR IN
RESPONSE THE COMPANY PANDEMIC
THE GOVERNOR ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND STATE AGENCIES.
TO MEET AND VOTE REMOTELY GET
AND SO FAR NO SIMILAR ACTION
HAS BEEN TAKEN FOR HOAS.
CONSEQUENTLY HOAS HAVE FACED
IMMENSE DIFFICULTIES IN
ORGANIZING LAWFUL MEETINGS IN
THE MIDST OF THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. FROM LAST YEAR A TWO
WAYS OF FOUND THE ORGANIZING IN
PERSON MEETINGS CURRENTLY
REQUIRED UNDER EXISTING LAWS.
HAS OFTEN BEEN IMPRACTICABLE
SANSEI FOR EVEN ILLEGAL. IN
RESPONSE TO THIS THE CALIFORNIA
LAW REVISION COMMISSION WORK
LAST FALL TO CRAFT A NARAL
POLICY RECOMMENDATION. THAT
SIMPLY WAIVE THE REQUIREMENT TO
PROVIDE AN IN PERSON MEETING
LOCATION FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF
MEETINGS- DURING A DECLARED
EMERGENCY OR DISASTER AND I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE GOAL OF
THIS BILL IS TO PROVIDE A
NARROW EXCEPTION. TO ENSURE
PARTICIPATION IS ACCESSIBLE
MEMBER THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
ID'S TO FULFILL THE FOLLOWING
REQUIREMENTS. THEY MUST PROVIDE
CLEAR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
PARTICIPATE. THE MEETING NOTICE
MUST INCLUDE THE TELEPHONE
NUMBER AND EMAIL OF A PERSON
WHO CAN PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WITH THE
TELECONFERENCE PROCESS. BOTH
BEFORE AND DURING THE MEETING.
THEY MUST ENSURE THAT EVERY
DIRECTOR AND MEMBER HAS THE
SAME ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE MEETING. THAT WOULD EXIST
IF THE MEETING ARE HELD IN
PERSON. ANY VOTER THE DIRECTOR
SHALL BE CONDUCTED BY ROLL
CALL. AND LASTLY PARTISAN IT
SHALL BE GIVEN THE OPTION OF
PARTICIPATING BY TELEPHONE. NOW
DURING THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING THIS BILL A NUMBER
OF CONCERNS WERE RAISED ABOUT
THE INTEGRITY OF ELECTIONS. ARE
ELECTIONS- FOR H. AWAY BOARDS
FOR EXAMPLE. TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS WE ARE ACCEPTING A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS- THE STATE
THAT SPECIFICALLY HOAS MUST
GENERALLY PROVIDE PHYSICAL
LOCATIONS FOR MEMBERS OBSERVE.
AND INSPECT THE ACCOUNT
ELECTION BALLOTS EVEN DURING A
DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY OR
DISASTER UNLESS. THE THERE IS-
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU AND
SITUATION WHERE- PHYSICAL HUMAN
PROXIMITY IS DANGEROUS OR
IMPRACTICAL. AND SO THE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IS THAT THE
DECLARED OR PROCLAIM DISASTER
EMERGENCY MAKES IT UNSAFE OR
IMPOSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE TO GATHER
IN PERSON IN ORDER TO COUNT AND
TABULATE BALLOTS UNDER THOSE
NARROW CIRCUMSTANCES- IN PERSON
COUNTING AND OBSERVATION MAY BE
WAIVED BUT WE ARE STILL
REQUIRING THAT VIDEO
OBSERVATION IS REQUIRED. WE'RE
ALSO ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY THAT ANY VIOLATIONS OF
THIS BILL SHALL BE SUBJECT TO
THE SAME VIOLATION. ENFORCEMENT
COMMON INTERESTS AND BUILD AN
OPEN MEETINGS ACT. AND THE
PRIOR TO NATURE WAYS FIRST
VIRTUAL MEETING THEY MUST SEND
AN EMAIL NOTIFICATION OF
MEMBERS WHEN MAIL SERVICE WILL
NOT ACHIEVE ACTUAL NOTICE.
PLEASE ALL FURTHER CLARIFY THE
CENTRAL ISSUE THIS BILL SEEKING
TO ADDRESS THAT UR CURRENT LAW
DOES NOT ANTICIPATE OR PROVIDE.
CONTINGENCIES FOR FAIR AND SAFE
PARTICIPATION H. O. IN MEETINGS
DURING EMERGENCIES OF THE KIND
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF IN THE LAST
YEAR. MODIFIERS THE GLOBAL
CAN'T ANNEX RECENT EMERGENCIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT IN CALIFORNIA
IS NOT ALWAYS POSSIBLE OR SAFE.
FOR SENSATIONS TO PROVIDE IN
PERSON MEETING LOCATIONS AND
THAT IS WHY SB THREE NINETY ONE
A PERMISSIVE BILL THAT SIMPLY
GIVES YOU IDEAS ANOTHER OPTION
FOR MEETING. AGAIN DURING THEIR
OWN CIRCUMSTANCES OFFICIALLY
DECLARE EMERGENCIES AND
DISASTERS IS SO URGENTLY
NEEDED. TODAY I HAVE WITH ME TO
TESTIFIED BRIAN HAGER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVIEW
COMMISSION AND- HATCHELL A.
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION ATTORNEYS
MARC COUNTY. THANK YOU SIR MAY
IS A EBERLE THE PHONE. YES CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS QUIEN BRAIN HUBERT I'M
THE DIRECTOR LAW REVISION
COMMISSION- I'M HERE TODAY JUST
TO HELP EXPLAIN THE
COMMISSION'S RECOMMENDATION
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OF MEMBERS
HAVE ABOUT IT- THE ONLY POINT I
WOULD ADD TO- SENATOR MEN'S
EXPLANATION. IS THAT THE
COMMISSION INCLUDED IN ITS
RECOMMENDATION THAT THIS BE
INTRODUCED AS AN URGENCY BILL
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE WE HEARD- RELIABLE
ANECDOTAL ACCOUNTS BUT A LOT OF
THE ID'S DURING THE PANDEMIC
WE'RE GOING AHEAD AND HOLDING
TELECONFERENCE MEETINGS WITHOUT
A PHYSICAL LOCATION. REALLY
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T SEE ANY
ALTERNATIVE THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE
DURING THE EMERGENCY. AND SO
THEY HAVE SORT OF EXPOSE
THEMSELVES TO POTENTIAL
LITIGATION CHALLENGING THE
VALIDITY OF THEIR ACTIONS AT
THOSE MEETINGS THAT WERE
TECHNICALLY OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH THE ACT AND SO WE WANTED
TO PROPOSE A CHANGE. THAT COULD
HOPEFULLY BE- INTRODUCED AND
ENACTED IN TAKE THE MEDIA FACT-
SO THAT WOULD BE VERY
BENEFICIAL CHANGES COULD GO
INTO EFFECT RIGHT AWAY AND LET
US SEE IDEAS GET ONTO A
LEGITIMATE. FLOODING FOR THEIR
MEETINGS GOING FORWARD. I HAVE
ANY OTHER TO A- THANK YOU
MISTER- ALSO MISTER DIRK- CHILL.
YES. I'M BURGEONING HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I'M I'M A
CALIFORNIA TURNING INTO MY FIRM
WE REPRESENT MANY HUNDREDS OF
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS
ARE C. ID RANGING IN SIZE FROM
JUST UNDER THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO SIX STATE HOME- JUST
ABOUT A YEAR AGO AND WITH THE
CLICK ON TO THE COBIT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE SAW MANY C. ID
STATES WITH REALLY SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES. HAS ALREADY
REFERENCE THE OPEN MEETING ACT
EXPRESSLY REQUIRES THAT THE
BOARD- PROVIDE A PHYSICAL
LOCATION FOR BOARD MEETINGS
HOWEVER AS WE ALL KNOW VERY
STATE AND LOCAL LAWS TO MANDATE
PROHIBIT GATHERING THAT THAT
PHYSICAL LOCATION AND EVEN IF
THEY WEREN'T TECHNICALLY
PROHIBITED VOLUNTEER BOARD
MEMBERS RESIDENT PROFESSIONAL
MANAGEMENT ALL THAT SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT HOLDING PHYSICAL
LOCATIONS OPEN FOR MEETING SO
AT A VERY CRITICAL TIME ADDED A
VERY BUSY TIME IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR OUR VOLUNTEER
BOARD MEMBERS TO DO THEIR JOB.
SO AT THAT TIME BY NECESSITY TO
BROWN ACT OTHER LAWS FAIRLY
QUICKLY MOVED IN ASSISTED IN
AND THE CONTINUATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HOWEVER WITH RESPECT TO SEE
AIDID'S WE SAW NO SUCH RELIEF
FOR THEIR VOLUNTEER LEADERS AND
MEMBERS SO THAT SAID. AS WAS
JUST MENTIONED EVEN WITHOUT THE
CHANGE TO THE LOCKER SAID THESE
MANY COMMUNITIES DRIVEN BY THAT
SAYING THAT THAT'S THE BEGAN
CONDUCTING OPEN MEETINGS
WITHOUT PHYSICAL LOCATIONS AND
IT QUICKLY. THE TREND CONTINUED
ACROSS THE STATE. THIS ENABLED.
ATTENDANCE FOR HOME PHONE OR-
THE NEW THE RESIDENTS ARE
BOARDING NEEDED LEAVE THEIR
REPAIR SUPPORT. IT PROTECTED
THE- IN THE COMMUNITY
VOLUNTEERS FROM EXPOSURE TO
COLD AT NINETEEN WHICH IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT THAT ARE
AGE RESTRICTED COMMUNITY HAD
ENABLED COMMUNITIES TO CONTINUE
TO FUNCTION AT THE CRITICAL
TIME WHEN THE FAMILIES WERE
STICKING CLOSE TO HOME. MORE
THAN EVER BEFORE. IN THE END IT
WAS OBSERVED BY EVERYBODY IN
OUR INDUSTRY THAT THIS
TRANSITION DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE COMMUNITY MEMBER
INVOLVEMENT AND COMMUNICATION
THE LEVELS OF THE NEVER EVEN
BEEN SEEN BEFORE- BUT- THIS
MORNING I SPOKE TO THE-
COMMITTEE LEADERS INTO VERY
LARGE AGE RESTRICTED
COMMUNITIES HERE INORANGE
COUNTY. ONE THAT JUST ABOUT A
THOUSAND OR THE OTHER IT IS
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOORS
ONE OF THEM REPORTED THAT THEY
HAVE. ACTUALLY CALCULATED THAT
THEY HAD MORE THAN A 50%
GREATER PARTICIPATION THEIR
MEETINGS AND THEY DID CREE COVE
IT. THE OTHER WITH TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED ON SAID THEIR
ATTENDANCE HAS MORE THAN
TRIPLED EDUCATING. THEMSELVES
OVER THESE REASONS THAT
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE PASSAGE
OF THREE NINETY ONE ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SIR- OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT THERE ARE NONE ARE
WE- ACTUALLY. DO HAVE WITNESSES
SUPPORT HERE IN THE GALLERY. WE
MISTER CHAIRMAN BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE IS CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE ACTION COMMITTEE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU MISTER
BROWN I SEE YOU'VE BEEN VERY
PATIENT AS WELL- ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING NONE LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES. YOU ARE DOES
MARTIN AT THE THREE NINETY ONE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND
WE WILL GO TO THE LINE OF ONE
THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
HEARING MEMBERS OF THE MATTER
NOT. LOOKING VERY CALLING ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA BUT I THINK THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF FOR WORKING TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AND I
THINK IT COMMITTEE FOR THE MOST
RECENT AMENDMENT- WOULD THE
MANAGER CREATURE MEMBER
OPPOSITION YOU GET. PRECLUSION
OBERNOLTE WHERE'S THE ****
DURING PROBABLY. AROUND OR OF
EIGHTY WE NEEDING MANAGER ARE
ABLE TO ACT YOUR YOUR NAME AND
YOUR PHILLY. AND YOUR äITION
SO LET'S LET'S TURN TO THE NEXT
CALLER. THAT IS LINE THREE OH
THREE. YEAH THIS IS TONY SOLD
BERMAN ORANGE COUNTY- BUT
AGAINST OPPOSED TO THE- I'M A
RESIDENT AND A FORMER EACH
ELECT BOARD MEMBERS. THANK YOU
WE'RE GET WE'RE GOING TO. GET
TO OPPOSITION AND JUST THE
SECOND RIGHT NOW WE'RE TAKING
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINES
NAME. YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION IN A MOMENT WE'RE
GOING TO TURN TO OPPOSITION-
AND- WE'RE GONNA LIVE IT
SUPPORT AS WELL AS OPPOSITION
TO NO MORE THAN FIFTEEN
MINUTES. ALL RIGHT. CONTINUOUS
SUPPORT MY NUMBER. TWO SIXTY.
MY NAME IS JACKIE KESSLER. I'M
A RESIDENT INSIDE CITY SHADOW
HILLS AND A FORMER DIRECTOR OF
THE THIRTY FIVE FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY EIGHT CHOI
ASSOCIATION ELECTION AND VOTER
RIGHTS ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO
ALL VERY MUCH THREE NINETY ONE
LET'S TURN TO THE NEXT. WITNESS
IN SUPPORT. IN THE NEXT LINE IS
TWO NINETY THREE. MISTER KAREN
MEMBERS JENNIFER WATER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY
MANAGER IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER TWO FORTY THREE.
MY NAME IS FRED BIRDS ON THE
BOARD PRESIDENT FOR THE MORGAN
HILL HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION-
TEMECULA WE URGE PASSAGE OF
THIS BILL AND WERE SHOULDN'T
GIVE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE
MORE WITH THE LINE OF ONE
FOURTEEN. ACTUALLY I'M IN
OPPOSITION SO ALL PUNCH OUT
PUSH BACK IN WHAT IT'S CALLED
ALL RIGHT. ANYONE ELSE.
MATAMATA RAIDER IN NOT HAVE. NO
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYMORE WHAT WAS
THE ONE FOURTEEN ARE YOU IN
SUPPORT. NO NO I'M IN A IN I'M
IN OPPOSITION. NOT HAVE ANY
MORE IN SUPPORT ON THE LINE ALL
RIGHT LISTED OPPOSITION
UNDERSTAND THEIR TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES MISTER DOUGLAS W.
ALEXANDER- ACTUALLY TEN COLONEL
DOUGLAS W. ALEXANDER AND- HENNY
KELLY WE'LL START WITH COLONEL
ALEXANDER. ARE YOU ON THE LINE
SIR ARE YOU THERE. HELLO ARE
YOU THERE YES CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN. THANK YOU MR MY
NAME IS DOUG ALEXANDER- RETIRED
LIEUTENANT COLONEL UNITED
STATES AIR FORCE AND SPEAKING
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE. FOR CALIFORNIA
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION LAW. IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. A
RETIRED JOURNALIST IS A FORCE
OF THE TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF
ACTIVE SERVICE TWENTY YEARS OF
WHICH I WAS A SPECIAL AGENT IN
THE AIRFORCE ALSO SPECIAL
MASTICATION SERVING IN THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE OFFICER.
FOLLOWING MY CAREER IN THE
MILITARY I GRADUATION UNIVERSAL
COMMON LAW SCHOOL. TRIED TO
SLOW IN SOUTHEAST GEORGIA FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS. MY WIFE AND
I OWN A CONDO IN PARTICULAR
COUNTY. WE SPLIT OUR TIME
BETWEEN CALIFORNIA AND GEORGIA
WE HAVE TWO SONS LIVING IN THE
LOS ANGELES AREA. I WAS
RECENTLY ELECTED IN THE- IT WAS
RECENTLY TO THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. FORGOTTEN OR
SOCIALIZATION CANNOT PERSONALLY
GOING THROUGH AND WITNESSED
ELECTION BY VIDEO CONFERENCING.
CONTRARY TO CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW THE ANNUAL MEETING WAS HELD
ON MARCH TWENTIETH THIS YEAR
BUT AS SOON ONLY. AN ELECTION
WAS HAILED BY MAIL IN BALLOTS
ONLY USING IT TO THE ENVELOPE
SYSTEM. AFTER THE ANNUAL
MEETING WAS CALLED TO ORDER THE
INSPECTOR OF ELECTIONS IT WAS
DOWN IN ORANGE COUNTY BEGIN
COUNTING THE BALLOTS. AND THERE
ARE VIDEO WHEN DARK. THE
MEETING CONTINUED AND OTHER
BUSINESS WAS CONDUCTED. AFTER
ALL THE OTHER BUSINESS WE
CONDUCTED INSPECTOR CAME BACK
ONLINE AND TO PRODUCE A
SPREADSHEET BOASTING THE BOATS
AND NOW SEEING THE RESULTS.
THERE WAS NO RECORDED VIDEO
AND- NO ONE WAS ABLE TO WITNESS
THE COUNTING OF THE VOTES.
NOBODY COULD PERSONALLY SEE
WHAT SHE WAS DOING WAS A TOTAL
LACK OF TRANSPARENCY IN THE
SELECTION. A SIMILAR WE WERE
ABLE TO KEEP THE POLLS OPEN FOR
THE TWENTY NINETEEN NATIONAL
ELECTION AND WE CLEARLY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO HOPEFULLY HOLD.
H. O. A BOARD ORIGINAL ACTION
AND WE ORIGINAL VOTE ON THE
TRINITY ONE BILL. THANK YOU
COLONEL ALEXANDER NEXT A PENNY
KELLY. LET ME- USED. WE CAN
HEAR YOU. HELLO THERE YOU HEAR
ME YEAH YES PLEASE PROCEED. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE PROCEED
IS CALLING. OKAY I AM THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE TIRE
AMERICANS AND I'M SPEAKING FOR
THE ESTIMATED ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION THREE YEARS LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION YOU KNOW SENIOR
VOTE LEAVE OUT ON A LOT OF
THINGS I'M SITTING HERE IN
GEORGIA MORE PEOPLE ARE HAVING
TO VOTE TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM
AND THIS MAKES. IT A LITTLE
MORE IMPORTANT TO ME I THINK.
YEAH BELIEVE THE BILL LOADING
RIGHT TO ENSURE FUNKY LUNCHEON
ARE. ONLY FAIR THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER WENT OVER THE- WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE YOU'VE
MADE A LOT OF CHANGES TO THIS
LAW BUT YOU HAVEN'T GONE FAR
ENOUGH BY DELETING THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THERE BE A
PHYSICAL LOCATION FOR A
MEETING. SB THREE NINETY ONE TO
LEAVE THE RIDE A SENIOR TO WIN
THE COUNTING OF THEIR BALLOTS.
NOW IT'S UP TO. CAMERA IS
HARDLY A SOLUTION ESPECIALLY
FOR SENIORS WHO HAVE NO
INTERNET. WHO HAVE NO TROUBLE
TRANSPARENCY IN ELECTIONS WITH
THE HUGE ISSUE IN THE NOVEMBER
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION. IT WAS
LONG ISSUE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP WON IN THE COURT THAT WAS
THE CAMPAIGN THE RIGHT OF HIS
CAMPAIGN STAFF TO BE ABLE TO
WITNESS AND MONITOR. HANDLEY'S
COUNTY BALLOT WE AFTER THAT
ALSO TRANSPARENCY IS A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT IN
ASSOCIATION ELECTION SB. THREE
NINETY ONE TAKE AWAY THAT RIGHT.
THE ISSUES NOT CLUB. ANOTHER OF
GOVERNMENT I THANK THE DAY
LIVES OF SENIOR LEADERSHIP
NOBLE. ON SB THREE NINETY ONE
THANKYOU THANK YOU MISS KELLY
OF ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I SEE NINE HERE IN
THE GALLERY I SEE NONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE. NO I'M NOT I'M NOT
A WRITER NEEDED- GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES
OPPOSITION TO SIMPLY GIVE US
THEIR NAME THEIR AFFILIATION
AND THEIR POSITION. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE TO DO AT THIS TIME.
WE GO TO LINE THREE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK. YEAH BUT
YOU HAVE TO DO. NINE THREE OH
THREE OR LINES OKAY. YES SIR
TERRY'S TALENTS AND AGAINST THE
OPPOSING IT- A MEMBER OF H.
AWAY AND THAT FORMER BOARD
MEMBER. THANK. ZERO TWO ONE
THREE OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANTHONY HER
ARM FROM SPECTRUM SACRAMENTO
COUNTY I'M A WHOLE NEW
HOMEOWNER AND I'M GRADUATING
LAW STUDENTS I WANT TO MENTION
AND- SECTION. THEN I YOU READY
TO GIVE US OUR NAME. YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION-
STRONG OPPOSITION I THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. THE TO LINE ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS LINDA BROWN I'M A REP
IN A SIXTY UNIT H. AWAY AND A
FORMER BOARD MEMBER AYE OPPOSED
THREE NINETY ONE AS WRITTEN
THANK YOU. AT THE TWO NINE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS EDWARD
CHESHIRE I'M FROM SAN DIEGO A
HOMEOWNER IN A C. I. D. AND
ALSO A FORMER BOARD MEMBER AND
I OPPOSE THREE NINETY ONE BOTH
AS WRITTEN AND AS AMENDED IT
DID REDUCE UNNECESSARY THANK
YOU. THE NEXT CALL. YOU TO GO
TO LINE TWO TWENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TWENTY TWENTY SIX
JULY AND OPEN. EIGHT MILLION
TWO NINE TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE CLASS. I AM BACKING
BOARD I'M A HOMEOWNER AND A
BOARD MEMBER AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU. LIKE
TO GO TO NINE EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
KELLY SELES I AM A HOMEOWNER
FROM ORANGE COUNTY I'M STRONGLY
OPPOSED IN URGING A NO VOTE ON
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
TWO NINE TWO OH EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TWO A LINE IS OPEN.
SORRY MY NAME IS TINA
MONTELONGO- MY CREATION
RENOWNED LAW FIRM ARNOLD PALMER
BOARD MEMBER BOARD MEMBERS IN
MY POSITION IS NO NO. THANK YOU
I'M AGAINST IT ARE YOU THANK
YOU NEXT. THANKS TO THE TWO ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS MARY BETH LEWIS
I AM A HOMEOWNER IN AN AGE OF
AGENTS IN THE CITY OF MORGAN
HILL THAT CONSULTANTS CAN OCCUR
COUNTY AND I AM OPPOSED TO BILL
SB THREE NINE ONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MISTER MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD GIVE US AN ESTIMATE
HOW MANY OTHERS ARE ON THE
PHONE. WE HAD THREE MORE BY
THANK YOU. I'D LIKE TO GO TO
LINE ONE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES MY NAME IS GUS
PETRA BORG PLASTER COUNTY H.
AWAY HOMEOWNER. FORMER H. AWAY
BOARD DIRECTORS ALSO-
CALIFORNIA SENIOR CITIZEN THIS
BILL LAX ENFORCEMENT. SEWER
PROTECTION ON SENATORS FROM
EAST REGION IS VERY NATIONAL
PLEASE. OPPOSE THANK YOU. LIKE
TO GO TO LINE OF PLEASE AHEAD.
HI MAGGIE KESSLER PRESIDENT AND-
SHADOW HILL FORMER DIRECTOR I
ASK YOU TO PLEASE NOT MAKE
THESE CHANGES WE NEED MORE.
PRIORITY IN VOTING AND VIDEO
GRADING IS NOT A GOOD AND WHEN
YOU GO TO THE NEXT CALLER YES.
THANK DON'T KNOW. MEXICO LINE
THREE OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE THREE OR FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SH NO THERE'S NO NOTHING
Q. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR DOES
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. WE'RE GOING
TO BRING IT BACK HERE THE
CHAMBER I SEE MISTER
HERTZBERG'S MICROPHONE OFFICE
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU. WHICH WAS
LAST FRIDAY CHAIRMAN- MY STAFF
SAID TO ME A EMAIL. FROM A VERY
SATISFIED CONSTITUENT- THANK IN
OUR OFFICE FOR WORKING HARD TO
HELP THEM GET A FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR GRANT UNDER THE PROGRAM
WE RECENTLY PASSED. SO I CALLED
UP THAT PERSON. TO THANK THEM
FOR SENDING A NOTE. SO OFTEN
THIS WE IN PUBLIC SERVICE WE
ONLY GET FOLKS ARE ANGRY AND I
WANTED TO JUST THANK. THIS
PERSON FOR HER GRACIOUSNESS. IN
THE CONVERSATION SHE TOLD ME
THAT SHE'S HAVING A BIG PROBLEM.
THAT SHE LIVES IN A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION WITH ABOUT EIGHTY-
FOLKS IN THE COMMUNITY AND THAT
THE BOARD ASSESSED HER TOO MUCH
MONEY AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY. AND I STARTED SKING HER
ABOUT IT AND WHAT HAPPENED AND
HOW TO THE CURRENT SHE AID.
WELL BUT YOU KNOW THEY HAD A
VIDEO MEETING ASSUME MEETING OR
WHATEVER. THIS IS FORTY PEOPLE
OF OUR HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION
DON'T HAVE EMAILS THEY DON'T
HAVE ZOOM IN OR ZOOM SCISSORS
SENIORS. AND I SAID TO THEN GET
NOTICE AND SO THAT THE
ASSESSMENT THAT POSE SUCH A
BURDEN ON HER AND HER HUSBAND-
WAS EXTRAORDINARY. AND SO I
LOOK AT THE AMENDMENTS TO THIS
COMMITTEE PUT TOGETHER AND I'M
ASSUMING THAT THE AUTHORS
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS. NUMBER
VOTE FOR THIS TODAY IS AN
ACCOMMODATION IN THE HOUSE OF
ORIGIN TO MOVE ALONG. WITHOUT A
COMMITMENT TO VOTE FOR ON THE
FLOOR. AND I KNOW SOME OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE HAD SOME ISSUES
WITH IT. BUT I GUESS IT'S JUST
WHAT I WANTED TO SAY ON THE
RECORD IS. YOU KNOW I'VE
ENJOYED IN THIS ENOUGH AND I'VE
LISTENED TO SOME OF THE
TESTIMONY AND I. SHARED WITH-
MISTER MAN STAFF THAT YOU KNOW
IT'S GONNA RAISE THIS ISSUE-
BUT I JUST THINK THAT WHEN YOU
READ THIS STUFF. THAT THESE ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT DECISIONS IT
WAS MENTIONED. ED YOU'VE GOT IF
YOU GOT SENIORS AND THEY DON'T
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY. AND I GET
WE'RE TRYING TO DO ZOOMS IN THE
IN THIS AND THE AND THE-
ASSESSMENT WAS AN EMERGENCY
ASSESSMENT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC EXACTLY THE
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE TALKING
ABOUT. AND SHALL PUT TOGETHER A
PETITION BECAUSE THERE WAS NO
DUE PROCESS AND HALF THE PEOPLE
OF THE ASSOCIATION NEVER EVEN
KNEW DECISION WAS BEING MADE.
SO I JUST THINK THAT AS WE
ENGAGE IN THIS DISCUSSION. YES
TO SOME MODERNIZATION IS NEEDED
ON THE ONE HAND. BUT ON THE
OTHER HAND IT HAS TO BE A DEEP
SYMPATHY SENSITIVITY IF YOU
WILL. TO THE FOLKS THAT ARE UP
TO SPEED WITH ALL THIS
TECHNOLOGY. AND MAKE SURE THESE
DECISIONS INCLUDE THEIR VOICE
THAT'S ALL SO I WILL BE VOTING
FOR TODAY I WANTED TO MAKE THAT
STATEMENT BECAUSE IT WAS JUST.
ABSOLUTELY BY HAPPENSTANCE.
THAT THIS HAPPENED AND I WANTED
TO SHARE THOSE OBSERVATIONS AND
SENSITIVITIES AND I. THANK THE
AUTHOR AND I. WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS AND CHAIRMAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MAJORITY- I SEE
MISS WHITE HE SAID WHITE HOUSE.
MR OF THE STATURE I HAVE A-
QUESTION I APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY THE
COMMITTEE THAT IT'S BEEN
ACCEPTED BY THE AUTHOR- WHAT
I'M NOT CLEAR ON IS THE
NOTIFICATION. BY EMAIL. I
UNDERSTAND. MANY PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE EMAIL BUT SOMETIMES THESE.
BOARDS HAVE THE EMAIL BUT THE
PEOPLE SAY I WANT TO GET THE-
PAPER COPY BECAUSE I'M- A
RETIREE OR THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
THE MAIL. WINDIES EMERGENCIES
ARE COMING IN. I DON'T THINK
THE AMENDMENTS. REQUIRE THE-
THE BOARD TO SEND OUT EMAILS TO
EVERYBODY THAT THEY HAVE ME
MAIL ON WHETHER THEY WANT THE
NOTICE OR NOT. I WOULD ASK THE
AUTHOR THAT. IF THAT IF MY.
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT CORRECT
OR NOT CORRECT. THE COMMISSION
ANSWER THAT- SENTIMENT I THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION CENTER- SO
MY UNDERSTANDING BILL I WILL
REFER TO IT DEREK- ONE OF MY
WITNESSES BUT- IS THAT WHAT
WE'RE DOING IS MODELED OFF OF
EXISTING STATUTORY LANGUAGE
UNDER THE CIVIL CODE SECTION
FORTY FORTY- WHICH ALLOWS FOR
EMAIL AS AN ALTERNATIVE IF
THEY'VE OPTED IN AND SO THE
PREFERRED METHOD IS MALE. IF
THAT IS NOT POSSIBLE THEN THEY
WILL BE SENT BY EMAIL OR IF THE
PERSON IS OPERATING THE EMAIL
THEN THEY WILL SEND EMAIL- IF
MAIL IS NOT POSSIBLE. FOR
WHATEVER REASON THEN THEY WILL
SEND EMAILS TO EVERYBODY THEY
HAVE EMAILS ON FILE FOR- AND
THAT'S JUST CONSISTENT WITH
CURRENT PRACTICES WITH THE CODE
BUT I'LL LET BURKE ANSWER THAT
AS WELL. IT THIRTY THREE THE
ACCOUNT DID YOU WANT TO HAVE
THE- THE SPECTRAL RESPONSE YES
PLEASE REFER. MISTER CASUALTY
ARE ABLE TO RESPOND. THE
MEASURE SHARED THAT THAT ISSUE
WAS ADDRESSED AND- SUBSECTION
C. OF THE PROPOSED FIFTY FOUR
FIFTY AND IT DOES IT IS MODELED
AFTER THE INDIVIDUAL NOTICE
THAT IT SET OUT IN CIVIL CODE
SECTION FORTY FORTY- BUT WHAT
DID PROVIDED THAT WE ARE GOING
TO ADD KNOW AS A LEAD YOU KNOW
FURTHER UP IN THE STATUTE-
PROPOSED. IT DOES SAY WE'RE
GONNA GET INDIVIDUAL NOTICE AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE EMERGENCY-
UNDER WHICH WE ARE GOING GOING
TO BE USING THESE TYPES OF
MEETINGS. AND IT GOES ON TO SAY
IN SUBSECTION C. THAT IF AS A
RESULT OF THE DISASTER
EMERGENCY MAIL DELIVERY OR
RETRIEVAL IS NOT POSSIBLE FROM
THE GIVEN ADDRESS WITHIN AN
ASSOCIATION THAT WE WILL
PROVIDE THAT ALSO WE WILL
PROVIDE THAT NOTICE BY EMAIL TO
AN EMAIL ADDRESS THAT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED BY THAT OWNER TO THE
ASSOCIATION. WITH ALREADY BUILT
INTO THE DAVID STERLING COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT ACT IT IS
A PROCESS BY WHICH PEOPLE
PROVIDE THEIR CONTACT
INFORMATION INDICATE WHETHER
THEY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THEIR
MATERIAL DELIVERED TO A
DIFFERENT ADDRESS IS BY MAIL
AND ALSO ALLOWS THEM TO OPT IN
BY EMAIL ALL OF THOSE THINGS
WILL BE. GREEN IT WILL BE IN
THE- EVERY ORDER WILL BE RE MY
OF THAT IN THE PROCESS. EVERY
OWNER WILL BE HAVE BEEN. IN
THIS PROCESS AND IN THE CASE
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE A DELUDE
AN ADDRESS WITHIN THE
ASSOCIATION SUCH AS WITH A FIRE
THAT CANNOT BE DELIVERED TO OUR
RETREAT FROM. IT WILL
AUTOMATICALLY BE SENT AN EMAIL
THEY HAVE ON FILE- AND- AGAIN
THROUGH THIS PROCESS OF
HOMEOWNERS ARE REMINDED OF THAT
AS WELL AS IN OUR ANNUAL
DISCLOSURES THERE THE
SOLICITATION FOR ANY IMITATE.
ANY INFORMATION ABOUT
ADDITIONAL ADDRESSES THEIR
EMAIL THEY WISH YOU FOR FUTURE
USE. THANK YOU SIR SENATE WHITE
HOUSE KEEP UP OKAY. MISTER
CHAIR I UNDERSTAND I THINK AND
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY FOR SOME
DISTRUST FROM SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION SO. I WOULD FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE IF RATHER THAN
HAVING THE DECISION MADE OF
WHETHER IT WAS POSSIBLE OR NOT
FOR THE PHYSICAL LOCATION
BECAUSE- WE'VE HAD. THIS
PANDEMIC IS GONE UP DOWN UP AND
WE AT DIFFERENT TIMES IT
CHANGES IF IT WERE JUST A
REQUIREMENT THAT IF YOU HAVE
THE EMAIL. THEY WOULD GET THAT.
THEY WOULD GET NOTICE ON THAT
AND THAT WOULD. HOPEFULLY HAVE
SOME ASSURANCE THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAVE AND I'LL MAKE
IT SHORT IS JUST ON THE
RECORDING OF THE- OF THE-
MEETINGS RIGHT NOW WITH THE
AMENDMENTS IS NOT. REQUIRED I
MEAN EVEN I CAN FIGURE OUT HOW
THE RECORD DISEASE MEETING AND
I WAS ONE OF THE AUTHOR COULD
COMMENT ON WHY. IF IT'S ONLY AN
EMERGENCY WHY THAT WOULDN'T BE
AN ADDED PROTECTION. FOR PEOPLE
FEEL MORE AT EASE WHAT WAS
GOING ON. BASED ON WHAT KIND OF
CONSIDER ME COULD RESPOND SO
AGAIN I WILL REFER TO MR PENCIL
OF MY QUICK RESPONSE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT CURRENT
LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE A TWO IS
TO RECORD. MEETINGS AT ALL SO
THIS WOULD BE. PUSHING WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO CHANGE THE
OVERALL LAW AROUND H. AWAYS AND
MEETINGS. AND SO WE ARE TRYING
TO AS I SAID EARLIER CRAP A
NARROW. SET OF PROCEDURES FOR
WHEN THEY ARE EMERGENCIES THAT
PREVENT PHYSICAL IN PERSON
MEETINGS- SO WE WANTED TO JUST
KIND OF KEEP THAT THE SCOPE OF
THIS BILL NARROW. AND WE DIDN'T
WANT TO. MAKE OVER ARCHING
CHANGES TO THE LAW THAT FALL
OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL-
BUT OUR FOR MR PENCIL AGAIN.
THE SCHEDULE. MISTER CHAIR AND-
SENATORS- THAT SB THREE NINETY
ONE DOES NOT CHANGE A LONG
STANDING CORPORATE RECORD
KEEPING REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION BOARD
MEETING VIDEO AND AUDIO
RECORDINGS HAVE NEVER BEFORE
BEEN REQUIRED A COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION OR ANY OTHER
CALIFORNIA CORPORATION THAT I
KNOW OF I DO THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT POLICY SHIFTS THE
LAB AND I BELIEVE PERSONALLY
IT'LL HAVE SIGNIFICANT POSSIBLY
VERY NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION. IN PARTICULAR
THOSE WITH LOWER LEVEL AND ON
THE ECONOMIC STRATA SO AS SUCH
I BELIEVE THAT IF WE ARE GOING
TO EVEN ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION. BE DROPPED
SEPARATELY FROM THE BILL. THANK
YOU SIR SAN JUAN CASKEY. I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS THIS IS ONLY
TO APPLY WHEN THERE'S AN
OFFICIALLY DECLARED EMERGENCY
OR DISASTER SO I UNDERSTAND IT
IT'S- EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES. I THINK THERE'S
BEEN QUITE A BIT FIGHT OF
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALEXION'S IN THESE MEETINGS ARE
OPEN AND- A FULL TIME. I'M
PREPARED TO SUPPORT THE BILL
RIGHT NOW MISTER CHAIR BUT
THAT'S ALL MY QUESTIONS TODAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO I CAN
SKI I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
MICROPHONES UP. ON DECEMBER
MANY CHEMICALS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO THE COLLEAGUES AND TO
ALL THE WITNESSES FOR
TESTIFYING TODAY. I TRY TO MAKE
A FEW POINTS IN CLOSING FIRST-
THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL IS MEANT
TO BE NARROW IT APPLIES ONLY
OFFICIALLY DECLARED STATE
EMERGENCIES- AND- WITH RESPECT
THE ELECTIONS CONCERNS WHICH WE
HEARD ABOUT FROM A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FOLKS- I SHARE THOSE
CONCERNS THE LAST THING WE WANT
TO DO IS CREATE UNFAIR.
ELECTIONS THAT ARE BUT WE HAVE
THE POTENTIAL FOR ANY KIND OF.
MISCONDUCT OR OR LESS THAN
PERFECT INTEGRITY- AND AGAIN I
WOULD EMPHASIZE THAT WHAT WE'VE
PROPOSED HERE. IS AN EXEMPTION
THERE WILL ONLY BE ALLOWED TO
BE CARRIED OUT- WHEN THERE IS
WHEN IT IS UNSAFE OR IMPOSSIBLE
TOGETHER IN PERSON. AS I
UNDERSTAND IT IN THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES THERE'S NO
ALTERNATIVE OTHER THAN TO
CANCEL THE ELECTION- WHICH IS
SOMETHING I THINK IS NOT A
GREAT ALTERNATIVE WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS. CREATE
PROCEDURES TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF THESE TYPES OF
ELECTIONS THAT MAY HAPPEN ONLY
IN VERY VERY NARROW
CIRCUMSTANCES- AND SO WE DO
HAVE PROCEDURAL PROTECTIONS I
WOULD JUST POINT OUT THAT THE-
CIRCUMSTANCES CRIED BY ONE OF
THE WITNESSES WHERE THE CAMERA
TURNED OFF IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
VOTING. WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED
EXPRESSING NOT BE ALLOWED IN
THE LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL. SO
WE ARE PRETTY CREATING
PROCEDURES THAT ARE NOT BEING
CARRIED OUT RIGHT NOW UNDER
WHAT'S- AFFECTED REALLY THE
WILD WEST OF THE PANDEMIC.
WHERE PEOPLE HOAS ARE CARRYING
OUT MEETINGS REMOTELY ARE
CARRYING OUT ELECTIONS REMOTELY
BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
ALTERNATIVES. WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS PROVIDE A COMMON SENSE
SOLUTION THAT I HOPE WE CAN ALL
AGREE. THAT LEAVES THE GENERAL
POLICY OF IT THAT WE NEED TO
CRAFT SOME KIND OF RELIEF. FOR
SITUATIONS WHERE YOU CAN'T MEET
IN PERSON BUT THAT THE LAW
REQUIRES YOU TO MEET IN PERSON
RIGHT NOW. FINALLY I WANT TO
JUST ADDRESS- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES IS CONCERNED
BECAUSE I SHARE THOSE IS A AND
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS- AND
I THINK NOTICE IS ABSOLUTELY
IMPORTANT. AND AGAIN I'LL
EMPHASIZE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO HERE IS CREATE PROCEDURES
AND MORE OPEN AMENDMENTS TO
FURTHER MAKE THOSE PROCEDURES
MORE ROBUST. OF A RIGHT NOW.
SENIORS CAN PARTICIPATE BY
TELEPHONE. ALREADY- A
CONFERENCE. AND THEY WOULD- BUT
AS AS I NOTED. THEY WERE HAVE
TO THE BILL REQUIRE THAT YOU
HAVE SOMEBODY WHO PROVIDES
CLEAR TECHNICALS INSPECTS
SISTANCE INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
PARTICIPATE- MEETING NOTICE
MUST INCLUDE ALL THE FOLLOWING
TELEPHONE NUMBER EMAIL THE
PERSON WHO CAN PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WITH THE
TELECONFERENCE PROCESS BOTH
BEFORE AND DURING MEETINGS SO
TRYING TO CREATE SOME
PROTECTIONS THAT DON'T EXIST
RIGHT NOW. WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WHAT WE CAN AGAIN AND THIS IS
IN THAT NARROW CIRCUMSTANCE WE
CAN'T HAVE PHYSICAL MEETINGS IN
PERSON- AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS TRYING TO ADDRESS BUT
WITH ALL THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU CINNAMON. MOTION TO I SEE
MOTION. SIR LAYERED MOVES. ON
THE BILL. MAN TWO COUNTS OF YOU
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS SP THREE
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR MEN-
MOTION BY SENATOR LAYERED
SOLUTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED-
BURKE. NUMBER AYE BURGESS. HAVE
A ADAM I HAVE YOU KNOW I DID
ALSO GET US THE I. GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT.
HERTZBERG HI JONES HI JONES I
LAYERED. LAYERED ICE STERN.
STERN I WAKE HOUSEKI NO.
WIECKOWSKI NO WIENER HI WIENER
I THAT. THAT'S NINETY ONE WITH
ONE PERSON MISSING ALL RIGHT
WE'LL PUT ON CALL- I KNOW I'VE
MADE THIS ANNOUNCEMENT BEFORE
BUT FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
WATCHING LISTENING SB THREE
FIFTEEN BY CENTER ROTH IS GOING
TO BE HEARD AT THE END OF THE
HEARING AS OPPOSED TO NOW- WE
NEXT TURNED TO S. B. THREE
EXCUSE ME SB FIVE THREE EIGHT
BY CENTER RUBIO. SO RUBIO I SEE
CENTER RUBIO IS PRESENT.
WAITING FOR THE PODIUM TO BE
CLEANED. SENATE RUBIO WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. TURN MEMBERS TODAY I AM
PRESENTING SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
A CRITICAL MEASURE FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS SEEKING
PROTECTION FROM THEIR ABUSERS
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
WILL ALLOW VICTIMS TO FILE
ELECTRONICALLY DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS AS
HE TRIED TO LEAVE DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS. I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN HAS COMMITTEE STAFF
ARE BILL SPONSOR THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO AS WELL AS OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS FOR WORKING ON
THIS BILL WITH ME. WE DO PLAN
TO TAKE AMENDMENTS ARE TO
REMOVE THE FEE FOR THAT AGAIN
SEEKING PROTECTIONS AS WELL AS
CLARIFIED THAT E. FILING COVERS
ALL DOCUMENTS IN THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER
PETITIONS. AS WAS RECOMMENDED.
MEMBERS I MET THISPANDEMIC WE
HAVE SEEN SURVIVORS BE PUT IN
AN EVEN MORE DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS. THAT THERE WERE IN.
BY THE SHELTER IN PLACE ORDERS
ACROSS THE WORLD C. FOR AT HOME
FOR VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS IN THE CASE. NOW
WHEN THERE'S VIOLENCE IN THE
HOME SOME STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
DOUBLE DIGIT INCREASES IN THE
VOLUME OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASES IN THE U. S. WHICH HAS
BEEN REFERRED TO AS A PANDEMIC
WITHIN A PANDEMIC. ACCORDING TO
JUST ONE CITY IN MY DISTRICT
THE EXPERIENCE A 2100% INCREASE
IN CASE WORK RELATED TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES LAST
YEAR. UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO FACE SYSTEMATIC
BARRIERS PREVENTING SURVIVORS
OF ABUSE FROM SEEKING
PROTECTIVE ORDERS IN A SAFE
MANNER. IT IS CRITICAL TO ALLOW
FOR REMOTE TESTIMONY BECAUSE
THE VICTIM IS ALREADY DEALING
WITH THE TRAUMA ASSOCIATED WITH
SEEING THEIR PERPETRATORS AND
PERSON OR DEALING WITH COURSE
OF CONTROL WHICH CAUSES
PARALYZING FEAR. THESE ARE
VICTIMS WHO ALREADY HAVE TO
MUSTER THE COURAGE TO LEAVE A
DANGEROUS SITUATION. THE LEAST
WE CAN DO IS REMOVE THE
UNNECESSARY BARRIER TO KEEP
THEM PROTECTED. IF I MAY I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
FIRST WITNESS MARC ELIOT FROM
SAN DIEGO A SAN DIEGO CITY
ATTORNEY. UP MY SECOND WITNESS
IS LAINE WHITE FEATHER AND
ADVOCATE FOR SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND A
SURVIVOR HERSELF AND FINALLY I
HAVE ON THE PHONE TODAY AND
DOROTHY SAN DIEGO SUPERVISING
DEPUTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY CITY
ATTORNEY EXCUSE ME. WHO WILL BE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THANK YOU MEDICARE
SET ASIDE REVIEW JUST TO
CLARIFY YOU DID ACCEPT THE
MOMENTS IS A RIGHT. YES I DID
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISS
ELLIOTT IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE ON
THE PHONE YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M NOT
WORKING AT THE COMPANY
CONFIRMED YOU CAN HEAR ME YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. WONDERFUL
THANK YOU WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
SENATOR RUBIO'S LEADERSHIP ON
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ISSUES. I'M
MARA ELLIOTT THE CITY ATTORNEY
OF SAN DIEGO MY OFFICE FRIENDS
AND FAMILY JUSTICE CENTER TO
HELP VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND SEX TRAFFICKING.
WE ALSO HAVE A GUN VIOLENCE
RESPONSE UNIT THAT HAS
INTERVENED IN MORE THAN FIVE
HUNDRED INSTANCES WHEN GRANDMA
CAN VIOLENCE WAS THREATENED.
AND ONE THIRD OF THOSE CASES
THE INTENDED VICTIM WITH A
SPOUSE PARTNER OR EX PARTNER.
ANYONE WHO WORKS WITH SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE KNOWS HOW
MUCH THEY FEAR BEING RE
VICTIMIZED BY THEIR ABUSERS.
WHEN THEY VISIT A COURTHOUSE
EVEN IF IT'S JUST TO SEEK
PROTECTION FOR THEMSELVES AND
THEIR CHILDREN. FEAR OF
HARASSMENT AND VIOLENCE
INTENSIFIED. AND FOR GOOD
REASON STUDY SHOWED THE MOST
DANGEROUS TIME FOR VICTIMS
DURING SEPARATION AND WHEN
SEEKING A RESTRAINING ORDER. BY
GIVING THEM AN OPTION TO
TESTIFY REMOTELY AT A HEARING
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER. SB
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT REMOVES THAT
BARRIER AND LET'S JUST TO
FOLLOW ITS COURSE. OUR SYSTEM
HAS NEEDED TO EVOLVE TO MEET
THE CHALLENGE OF A PANDEMIC.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE NOW KNOW
THAT REMOTE TESTIMONY IS BOTHPRACTICAL AND EFFICIENT. IN SAN
DIEGO AND AROUND CALIFORNIA
IT'S BEEN USED FOR BOTH TYPES
OF RESTRAINING ORDERS COVERED
BY SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT WITHOUT
COMPLICATIONS OR CONCERNS. WITH
MOST SERVICES MAKE THE PROCESS
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND LESS
INTIMIDATING. IN AMONG THE
PEOPLE WHO MOST DESERVE THE
HIGH NEED ACCESS AND PROTECTION
OF BROMO HEARING ARE THOSE WHO
THINK RESTRAINING ORDERS. FROM
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS OFTEN
MOVE OUT OF STATE TO ESCAPE AN
ABUSER LOSE ACCESS TO A CAR
WHEN THEY'RE SEPARATED FROM
THEIR ABUSER. BECOME SINGLE
HEADS OF HOUSEHOLDS WHO CANNOT
AFFORD TO TAKE A DAY OFF WORK
OR PAY FOR CHILD CARE. BILL
WHEN THEY'RE OUT IN PUBLIC AND
COULD BE STOCKS BY THEIR
ABUSER. STUDIES ALSO SHOW A
STRONG AND ALARMING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS ELLIOTT UP NEXT
MISS WHITE FEATHER. YEAH THIS
WHITE FEATHER YOU MADE ANY YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS ELAINE WHITE FEATHER
I AM A SURVIVOR AND ADVOCATE
AND ACTIVIST AND A VETERAN
WORKING AND GENDER BASED
VIOLENCE OR FORTY YEARS ON THE
FRONT LINE. IT IS AND ALWAYS
HAS BEEN VERY DIFFICULT FOR ANY
SURVIVOR OF THE CRIME OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE INTIMATE
PARTNER VIOLENCE TO DEAL WITH
OBTAINING BRINGING ORDERS HIS
THE TENUOUS PROCESS THAT IS
BOTH OVERWHELMING AND
INTIMIDATING. TRIGGERING EVERY
SURVIVOR GOING THROUGH THE
COURT PROCESS. FOR THE VAST
MAJORITY OF SURVIVORS VICTIMS
MARKET LIKE THE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. AND AGAIN THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM IS OFTEN 90% OF BECAUSE
OF THIS. BUT NO CURRENT OPTION
EFILE FOR DVR OF THE IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC I'VE FOUGHT THE
VERY DEEPLY. I'M ALSO INCREASE
REQUEST FOR SAFETY AND SERVICES
THAT HELP THE BRAIN ARE LIFTED.
BUT THOSE WHO DO HAVE INTERNET
AND COMPUTER ACCESS E. FILING
ALLOWED SURVIVORS TO KNOW THEY
HAVE A PHYSICAL DISTANCE. FROM
THE ABUSER AND THAT THE- YOU'VE
BEEN UNAWARE OF THE PHYSICAL
LOCATION. FOR THOSE WHO COULD
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO INTERNET OR
COMPUTERS HE FINALLY FROM A
SAFE AND SECURE SPACE LIKE. A
LOCAL TVORGANIZATION GOOD
SERVICE ONE OF THE MOST
EFFICIENT AND LESS THREATENING.
WAYS YOU GO THROUGH THE COURT
PROCESS. AND THERE'S LIKE A
PAYMENT WHAT I'M INFORMED THE
PATIENT. IN ARE. LGBT I THINK
OF CAR AND E. FILING COULD
INCUR FULL TO TELLING AND PARTS.
BEGINNING ON. THEY CAN PASSAGE
ALMOND FOR LEGISLATION IN THE
FORM OF SOCIAL JUSTICE BECAUSE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS NOT ONLY A
CLIENT IT IS A SOCIAL JUSTICE
ISSUE. THANK YOU MISS WHITE
FEATHER. ALL RIGHT LET'S TURN
NOW TO SUPPORT WINDOWS IN THE
GALLERY SEEING NONE SAYING NOT
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE WILL NOT
TURN TO THE PHONE. ON THE PHONE
IF YOU WOULD PROVIDE YOUR NAME
YOUR FILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. NOT A MODERATOR IF
YOU'D OPEN THE PHONE LINES. IF
YOU ARE IN FOR F. B. AT FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AND WE WILL LOOK AT A LINE
OF THREE TWELVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER KAREN MEMBERS OF THE
SOVIET POLICE SHOT ON BEHALF OF
THE OFFICE OF LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY MIKE YOUR IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU TO SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE. THREE
FIFTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE
MINOR BEHALF THE GIFFORDS LAW
CENTER IN SUPPORT THANKS SO
MUCH THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
THREE OH SIX. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MORE ATOP
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO'S MAYOR TODD GLORIA AND
THE CITY COUNCIL OR PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THE MEASURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU. CAN WE GO TO
THE LINE OF THREE SIXTEEN.
THANK YOU ARE CHRISTINE
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP KINDA
MUSTY FILING IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
MORE IN Q. MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU LET'S TURNED OPPOSITION I
SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE
NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- IS
THERE A WITNESS. ON THE PHONE
LINE IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FIVE THREE EIGHT. SO MADAM
MODERATOR IT ARE THERE ANY.
CALLERS IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE THREE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AT FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND
WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q.
PROPOSITION ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- NOW TURNING TO THE
CHAMBER I SEE CENTER BOARD IS
MICROPHONES UP CENTER BOARD
JUST. THANK YOU MR. I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE. THE AUTHOR- THE
SENATOR FROM BALDWIN PARK ON
THIS. ON THE ON THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION- NORMALLY I WOULD
FIERCELY PROTECT THE ABILITY.
THAT IS ENSHRINED IN OUR IN OUR
LEGAL SYSTEM FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
TO CONFRONT THEIR ACCUSER.
UNDER CERTAIN LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT CAN BE
TERRIBLY COUNTERPRODUCTIVE AND
DANGEROUS AND SO- I'M
DEFINITELY GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY AND
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. IN A PERFECT WORLD YOU
DON'T HAVE TO RESPOND RIGHT NOW
IN A PERFECT WORLD THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD HAVE. SOME
ADDITIONAL PROVISO THAT WOODS
THAT WOULD INDICATE THAT UPON A
FINDING OF NECESSITY- THAT-
THESE PROTECTIONS BE PUT INTO
PLACE TO THE INDIVIDUAL- WOULD
NOT HAVE TO CONFRONT THE
INDIVIDUAL I THINK THAT WOULD
MAKE IT EVEN TIGHTER BUT I'M
PROUD TO SUPPORT IT TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER BOARD IS.
OTHERS I SEE NO OTHER
MICROPHONES. ALL RIGHT- IS
THERE A MOTION SIR THEY'RE ALSO
MOVES- ED. ANY ANY OTHER
CONVERSATION OR THE
CONVERSATION OVER COMMENTS.
SENATOR RUBIO DO CARE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR YES
MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE JUST WANTED TO SHARE
THAT TRIGGERS FOR AN ABUSER ARE
UNPREDICTABLE. AND SPORE A
VICTIM EVERY SINGLE DAY IN
FRONT OF THEIR ABUSER MAY BE
THEIR LAST SEOUL THANK YOU
BECAUSE WE NEED TO NOT PUT
VICTIMS IN HARM'S WAY AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BENCI
COUNCIL RECALL THE ROLE THIS IS
THE SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR RUBIO. THAT MOTION BY
SENATOR GRASSO AND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND THEN RE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON RULES AND
BURKE. AMBERG FIVE LARGEST
BOARD JUST I CARRY IT ON. I DID
ALSO HI SO I GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
BY. HERTZBERG JONES THANK JONES
I LAYERED. STERN. STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI AYE AYE CASKEY AYE
WIENER WIENER I. THE LITTLE
THAT'S NINE TWO ZERO SORRY ARE
PUT THE BILL ON CALLED NEXT WE
HAVE SB SEVEN FOUR SIX BY
SENATOR SKINNER- SENATORS
SKINNER- I'M SURE WILL BE
ARRIVING MOMENTARILY.
CAN YOU
THERE WE GO. I AM TEMPORARILY-
FILLING IN FOR OUR FEARLESS
LEADER- CENTER SKINNER WOULD
YOU PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS. CAN I GIVE YOU SOME
BACKGROUND. SO HISTORICALLY THE
ONLY WAY A BUSINESS CAN LEGALLY
INFLUENCE AN ELECTION IS
THROUGH CASH OR AN IN KIND
CONTRIBUTION OR BY MAKING
INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURES ALL OF
WHICH ARE COVERED BY F. PPC
RULES AND ARE REPORTABLE.
HOWEVER RECENT ADVANCES IN
VARIOUS OF OUR INTERNET
TECHNOLOGIES. MADE IT POSSIBLE
FOR COMPANIES TO INDIVIDUALLY
INFLUENCE VOTER BEHAVIOR BY
CURATING THE ONLINE CONTENT WE
SEE. AND SKEWING IT TOWARD A
PARTICULAR POLITICAL STANCE.
OUR ELECTION LAWS HAVE NOT
CAUGHT UP WITH THE ADVANCEMENT
OF THE INTERNET. SO THAT ONLINE
BUSINESSES THAT USE OUR INFO.
SO IT'S NORMAL THAT THEY WOULD
USE OUR INFO FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU
BUY POLITICAL AD YOU'RE
TARGETING THEIR POLITICAL AD
TOWARDS CERTAIN PEOPLE THAT'S
WITH THAT SO YOU KNOW WHERE
EVEN A- A PRODUCT DAD. AND THE
INTERNET SITES HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO DO THAT. HOWEVER
THEIR ONLINE BUSINESSES THAT
USE THAT SAME TARGETED INFO TO
STEER INFORMATION THAT IS NOT A
PAID POLITICAL AD. THAT THEN
SUPPORTS OR OPPOSES A CANDIDATE
OR A MEASURE. AND WHEN THEY DO
THAT IT IS NOT CURRENTLY
REPORTABLE. SO WHAT SB SEVEN
FOUR SIX DOES. IS PROVIDES A
REALITY CHECK FOR WE CONSUMERS
AND RESTORES PUBLIC TRUST IN
ONLINE CONTENT BY ALLOWING US
TO KNOW IF WE'RE BEING
POLITICALLY TARGETED IT ALLOWS
THE CONSUMERS PERSONAL
INFORMATION HAS BEEN USED FOR A
POLITICAL PURPOSE REQUEST
REPORT FROM THAT BUSINESS AS TO
HOW THAT INFO WAS USED REQUIRES
A BUSINESS TO DISCLOSE TO THE
CALIFORNIA PRIVACY PROTECTION
AGENCY THE NAMES O CANDIDATES
COMMITTEES OR BALLOT MEASURES
WHICH THEY'VE USED PERFORMED
PERSONAL INFO FOR AND WHAT THE
PURPOSE WAS. AND REQUIRES THE
CEO OF SUCH BUSINESSES TO
CERTIFY UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY THAT THE BUSINESS HAS
TRUTHFULLY DISCLOSED ALL
POLITICAL ACTIVITY. NOW I WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE MY WITNESSES WHO
ARE SKINNER OF SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT ALASTAIR MACTAGGART
FROM CALIFORNIANS FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY AND ARIEL FOX FROM
COMMON SENSE MEDIA. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER OF MR MCTAGGART
ARE YOU WITH US. YES SIR CAN
YOU HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU GO
AHEAD. GREAT THANK YOU- BODY
BELT RETIRED I'M CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE
TODAY. I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
SKINNER FOR WHO. LEADERSHIP
HERE ON THIS REALLY IMPORTANT.
ISSUE WHICH I CONSIDER NOTHING
LESS THAN A REAL THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY. BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT THESE THESE TIGHT
BUT THIS IS A BRAND NEW
INTEREST IN IN IN OUR IN OUR
DEMOCRACY THE SOCIAL MEDIA AND
SEARCH COMPANIES. AND THEIR
ABILITY TO INFLUENCE. IS ALSO
NEW AND YOU KNOW WE ALL
REMEMBER- MR ZUCKERBERG SAYING
THAT WOULD BE AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO FACEBOOK IT'S A
LIQUID FORM. WERE COLLECTED.
WELL HOW DO WE KNOW HOW WOULD
WE EVER KNOW IF FOR EXAMPLE-
THAT. THEIR BUSINESS IT'S TRY
TO GET THE LAW THE CARD THAT WE
TAKE A AS AS- SAID. THERE'S
THIS CURRENT LOOPHOLE AROUND
THE BUSINESSES TO THAT FOR THE-
WERE NOT TALKING TO THIRD PART
AT TRUMP FOR JOE BY PUTTING.
BUT THAT IS WHAT THE LAW ABOUT.
BUT THIS OTHER PIECE THIS WU.
AND IT AND IT NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
BECAUSE AT SOME POINT DON'T FIX
SUMMER'S GONNA THAT BECAUSE
IT'S JUST TOO CHOOSE YOU KNOW.
TO YOU- ANY OF THAT BUT THE
LAST DAY JUSTIN CALL IS YOU
KNOW THERE'S THIS. A PART OF
BILL REQUIRES YOU SEE TWO. THAT
THEIR- IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
LAW. AND ALL IT TO THEIR OUT
THE FOR. IN MY OTHER LIFE YOU
EVERY TIME GET A LOAN FROM A
LETTER YOU YOU HAVE TO CERTIFY
AND- THAT THE BONUS AND YOU
KNOW IT DIDN'T. WITH THE
COMPANY AND ALL THAT
CERTIFICATES IS DONE- UNDER
PENALTY FOR SO YOU KNOW I THINK
THIS IS A PLAIN- BUT
ALTERNATIVE PERSPECTIVE
REQUIREMENTS AND I REALLY I
WANT TO THANK CENTER FOR
LEADERSHIP HERE. AND I THOUGHT
ON. BILL. THANK YOU MR MATTEO.
OF MISS ARIAL FOX. ARE YOU
AVAILABLE. MODERATORS A PARTIAL
FOX ONLINE. I DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT PERSON ON THE LINE AND
I'LL NO ALL RIGHT- WELL LET'S
LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NONE- WITNESSES
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NONE.
LET'S TURN TO THE PHONE LINES
IN. BETTER MODERATOR. FOR MARKS.
OKAY IF YOU'RE IN OF AND AT
EACH OTHER FORTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND WE WILL
GO TO THE LINE OF. ONE FIFTY
THREE. ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS TRUE OF
MUHAMMAD HELD CHAMBER- YOU KNOW
IT TURNS OUT WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
REGISTER IN OPPOSITION WITNESS
IN TIME WITH THE COMMITTEE THE
ONE YEAR OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
COMING. BUT WE WILL TURNED
OPPOSITION AMONG. THANKS. THEN
THE NEXT AVAILABLE TO LINE
NUMBER THREE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GERMAN NUMBERS IN
SENATORS THIS IS MIKE MADDOCK
ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER WATCHDOG
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE. THANK YOU. AND WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q. ALREADY
NOW LET'S TURN TO OPPOSITION- I
DO NOT HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES LISTED IN OPPOSITION
IF THERE. ARE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AS A PRIMARY WITNESS
THEY MAY HAVE TWO MINUTES.
MADAME MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS AT R.
ONE ZERO MY FOLKS AND WE HAVE
MY NUMBER ONE FIFTY THREE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU RESPECTED YOUR
MEMBERS MONEY TO SHORE UP
MOHAMMED THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND NOW WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AS DRAFTED. SB SEVEN FOUR SIX
HAS DROPPED IT OVER BROAD IN
ITS DEFINITION THEN
FABRICATIONS REQUIRES
BUSINESSES TO DISCLOSE WHETHER
INFORMATION IS USED FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES BUT THE
DEFINITION OF POLITICAL
PURPOSES MODERN UP TO INCLUDE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE NON
PARTISAN BUT INDIRECTLY RELATED
TO SPECIFIC CANDIDATES OR
BALLOT MEASURES SUCH AS-
SERVING UP INFORMATION OF
INTEREST TO USERS ARE.
DISPLAYING CONTENT OF INTEREST
USERS ADDITIONALLY AS RAPID
THERE IS DIVISION IN THE BEAUTY
IN THE LANGUAGE OF THIS BILL TO
DISCOURAGE BUSINESSES FROM
ENGAGING IN NON PARTISAN
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT INDIVIDUALS
RIGHT TO VOTE FOR EXAMPLE
SHARING VOTER INFORMATION
DISPLAYING VOTER MAPS OR REALLY
POLITICAL INFORMATION OF ANY
SORT OF POTENTIALLY ALLOWING AN
INDIVIDUAL TO SHARE THAT THEY
HAVE VOTED- COULD BE FRUSTRATED
BY THE OVERBROAD. LANGUAGE IN
IN THIS BILL AN ADDITIONAL SB
SEVEN FOUR SIX EXPOSES IO'S ARE
EQUIVALENT PERSONS TO PERSONAL
CRIMINAL EXPOSURE BY COMPELLING
THEM TO SIGN STATEMENT UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY REGARDING
THE BUSINESSES POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES WHICH THEY MAY OR
MAY NOT BE THE PERSON MOST
KNOWLEDGEABLE TO SPEAK ABOUT.
AND NOT ONLY DOES THIS
REQUIREMENT FORCE A PERSON TO
ATTACHED INFORMATION THAT SHE
OR HE MAY NOT HAVE ACTUAL
KNOWLEDGE OF YOU KNOW EVEN A
GOOD FAITH DISCLOSURE OF ALL
INFORMATION ON THE BILL COULD
LEAD TO A CEO PERJURING HERSELF
AS A RESULT OF SIMPLY
MISUNDERSTANDING THE SCOPE OF
POLITICAL ACTIVITY INTENDED BUT
BUILT. ON THAT OF COURSE
EFFECTIVELY ASK ACTED THE
DETERRENT FOR PARTICIPATING THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS FOR THESE
REASONS WE DO RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE SB SEVEN FOUR SIX
IMMIGRATION. ACT THANK YOU. AND
THAT IS IN LINE IS PRETTY. NOT
OPPOSITION OF MIND BIRTH FORTY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW ON THE OF
INTERNET ACCESS AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. MY NUMBER SEVEN
ONE. SHARE MEMBER CAME TO ME
TREE A MAP ATTACKED WE LIKE
THAT I GOT A CALL CAL AND SO
WITH INTERNET ACCESS AND
RESPECT OPPOSE SB FORTY. THANK
YOU OTHERS OPPOSITION. THERE
ARE NO WHAT OTHER ATHLETES
ANYTHING YOU. ALL RIGHT BRING
BACK TO CHECK I SEE BOARD IS
MICHAEL UP CENTER BOARD IS.
THANK YOU IF I MAY PUT A TO THE
TO THE OFFICE YOU SURE THERE'S
A- DISAPPOINTED CLARIFICATION-
I KNOW LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE WE
DON'T LIKE BEING TARGETED BASED
ON OUR METRICS ARE INFORMATION
IN OUR HISTORY AND PROFILE- IT
IS KIND OF A NEW REALITY THAT
WE'RE HAVING TO CONFRONT. AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER HOW IT IS PRE
AGGREGATED INFORMATION PLEA IN
THIS SCENARIO WITH THIS
REQUIRED THE DISAGGREGATION OF
ALREADY ACCUMULATED INFORMATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION THIS
DOES NOT PREVENT THE TARGETING
I THINK THAT WE CERTAINLY- WELL
SOME OF US MAY OBJECT TO THE
THAT TARGETING THAT IS THE CORE
OF MANY OF THESE ONLINE
ENTERPRISES BUSINESS. SO DOES
NOT PREVENT THAT WHATSOEVER
WHAT IT DOES IS AND IN FACT
MANY OF US WHO RUN FOR OFFICE
BY WEB ADS FOR EXAMPLE AND WE
DO SO. UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY
WILL BE TARGETED AND WE EVEN
DIRECT THE PARAMETERS- WHAT
THIS IS TRYING TO PREVENT IS
THAT TARGETING THAT THE COMPANY
ITSELF CHOOSES TO DO. THAT IS
NOT A POLITICAL AD. AND THUS IS
NOT REPORTABLE SO THAT IF THEY
DO THAT THEN IT IT MUST BE
REPORTABLE SO IF THEY DO
TARGETING ON BEHALF OF. A
CERTAIN BALLOT MEASURE
CANDIDATE OR OTHER VERY
EXPLICIT ELECTORAL POLITICAL
PURPOSE WHICH WOULD OTHERWISE
BE COVERED UNDER OUR REPORTING
LAWS. THEY WOULD HAVE TO REPORT
THAT. IS IT JUST A
CLARIFICATION SO IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS THERE'S BEEN AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF DATA
COLLECTED IN IT IT EXISTS
EITHER PHYSICALLY ON. IN
SOFTWARE OR IN THE CLOUD. WHAT
WOULD HAPPEN TO ALREADY
EXISTING PACKAGES OF
INFORMATION ABOUT PROFILED
INDIVIDUALS COULD THAT
INFORMATION STILL BE USE RIGHT
NOW OR WOULD HAVE TO BE
DISAGGREGATED- I DON'T BELIEVE
IT WOULD BE REQUIRED TO BE
DISAGREED I THINK IT'S WHAT
WHAT AND FOR EXAMPLE. MANY OF
US IN OUR LET'S JUST USE
FACEBOOK IN THE CHATS PART OF
FACEBOOK WE ARE WE OFTEN SAY-
I'M YOU KNOW I SUPPORT X. RICE
SUPPORT WHY. AND OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S GOING TO GET STEERED
TOWARDS- YOU KNOW LET'S SAY IF
IT'S A BUNCH OF DEMOCRATIC
CLUBS THAT ARE SEEING-
EVERYBODY SHOULD VOTE FOR X. OR
Y. AND IT'S BEEN CLEAR IN MY
PROFILE I AM A DEMOCRAT ALSO
FOR EXAMPLE AND I MAY BE MEMBER
OF VARIOUS DEMOCRATIC CLUB
SPEND NOT STUFF MIGHT POP UP.
ON MY FEET RIGHT THERE'S
NOTHING IN THIS BILL THAT WOULD
PREVENT THAT IT'S IF THE
COMPANY ITSELF CREATES CONTENT.
OR STEERS CONTENT. OF THEIR OWN
SO. THAT EXAMPLE A GREAT
EXAMPLE WOULD BE. IF YOU HAD
GOOGLE THE- VARIOUS OF THE
BALLOT MEASURES THAT WERE ON
THE CALIFORNIA BALLOT STATEWIDE
BALLOT MEASURES AND YOU GOOGLE
TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE- A.
B. ANALYSIS OF THEM OR
WHATEVER. THE ONLY ONE WHERE
THE FIRST THING THAT POPPED UP.
WAS THE OPPOSITION ARGUMENT ON
THAT PROPOSITION WAS THE
PROPOSITION THAT AFFECTED.
THOSE INTERNET COMPANIES FOR
EVERY OTHER PROPOSITION IF YOU
GOOGLE THAT. WHAT CAME UP WAS
AND IF YOU GO ON THE SECRETARY
STATE WEBSITE IT IS THE- IN
FAVOR ARGUMENT THAT SHOWS UP
FIRST AND THEN THE OPPOSITION
ARGUMENT. SO THAT'S WHAT WOULD
POP UP WHEN YOU GOOGLE IT
HOWEVER ON THE ONE INITIATIVE
IT POPPED UP INSTEAD THE
OPPOSITION. IT WAS PROBABLY NOT
AN ACCIDENT. OKAY WELCOME IT
WOULD BE- I UNDERSTAND THE
PURPOSE AND I THINK THERE ARE
SOME THERE'S A LOT OF MERIT TO
WANTING TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT IF
WE ARE TARGETED THAT THAT WE
ARE AWARE THAT WERE BEING
TARGETED UP FOR PARTICULAR
VERSUS PURPOSE AND THERE'S A
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS TO GO
ALONG WITH THAT- WOOD I DON'T
KNOW IF AMENDMENTS HAD EVER
BEEN PROPOSED. ON THIS NIGHT DO
THIS IN A RESPECTFUL FRIENDLY
MANNER- THE CEO- COMPONENT OF
IT- I THINK MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE AGGRESSIVE BUT I KNOW
THAT IT'S PROBABLY YOUR INTENT
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD
CONSIDER- REVISING INTO THE
CHIEF INFORMATION OFFICER IN IT
BEING AN ATTESTATION NOT UNDER
PERJURY FOR EXAMPLE IT'LL LEAVE
THAT FOR YOU TO CONSIDER THANK
YOU. PRITCHETT THANK YOU- I
UNDERSTAND THAT ARIAL FOXES ON
THE PHONE WE CALLED UPON HER
EARLIER BUT- BECAUSE OF. SOME
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY WORK ABLE
TO ACCESS HER- SO IT MISS FOX
IS AVAILABLE- GO AHEAD AND
TESTIFY. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES. WONDERFUL THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING KAREN MEMBERS I'M ARIAL
SOCKS JOHNSON WITH COMMON SENSE
MEDIA. COMMONSENSE BECAUSE A
COW CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT WHICH
GIVES IMPORTANT PRIVACY RATE TO
ADULT TEENS AND KIDS AND WE
WERE PLEASED TO SUPPORT LAST
YEAR'S PROPOSITION TWENTY FOUR.
IN ORDER FOR CONSUMERS TO BE
ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY EXERCISE
THEIR GTK RIGHT LIKE HEALTH
COMPANIES TO STOP SELLING OR
USING CERTAIN DATA FOR TO
DELETE IT. CONSUMERS MUST
CLEARLY UNDERSTAND WHAT
BUSINESSES ARE DOING WITH THEIR
DATA IN THE FIRST PLACE. THAT'S
THE CCPA ALSO REQUIRES
TRANSPARENCY AND THAT BUSINESS
IS EXPLAINED THE BUSINESS OR
COMMERCIAL PURPOSES OF THEIR
DATA PROCESSING WHICH AS WE
HAVE ALL SEEN BUSINESSES CAN
USE INDIVIDUALS PERSONAL
INFORMATION FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES AS WELL. AND CONSUMERS
OFTEN HAVE NO IDEA THAT THIS IS
THE CASE COMPANIES HAVE
DETAILED DOSSIERS ON
INDIVIDUALS AND CAN USE THAT
INFORMATION TO ATTEMPT TO
INFLUENCE THE ACTIONS OF A
VOTER. SUCH AS BY PREVENTING
ONE KIND OF AN ISSUE IN
RESPONSE TO A SEARCH QUERY OR
DETERMINING WHAT ORDER CONTENT
WILL SHOW UP FIRST IN THE FEET.
SUCH ACCENT SUCH ACTIONS ARE
CURRENTLY NOT DISCLOSEABLE
UNDER CAMPAIGN. FINANCE RULES.
UNDER SKINNER WOULD STRENGTHEN
THE CT. TO ENSURE THAT. CAN NO
COME ARE USING THEIR PERSONAL
AND FROM TO AND THEIR- IT WOULD
HELP RESTORE TRUST INTO COMPANY
AND THEIR ROLE IN THE
FUNCTIONING TO. TRUST TECH
RIGHT NOW IS AT AN ALL TIME LOW.
ORDINANCE AT A MENTAL LAST WEEK
INTERESTED SO MEDIA. AS LESS
THAN FOR ALL OTHER TYPES OF
THIS. ANOTHER PULLED DECLINING
TRUST AND THAT A MAJORITY
CONSUMERS RIGHT NOW WOULD
RATHER KEEP THEIR INFORMATION
PRIVATE AND SETTLE FOR GENERIC
PRODUCTS RATHER THAN SHARE IT
FOR PERSONALIZATION. CONSUMER
TRUST IS CRITICAL TO BUSINESSES
AND DEMOCRACY THRIVING AND IT'S
A MISINFORMATION AND
MANIPULATION GROW WE SHOULD DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE
CONSUMERS CAN TRUST UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT'S WHAT THEY SEE
ONLINE. THE COMPANY USES AN
INDIVIDUAL INFORMATION TO
ENCOUNTER VOTE YOU SHOULD AT
THE VERY LEAST BE MADE AWARE OF
IT WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
I. THE SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL
ALL RIGHT BRING IT ONCE AGAIN
BACK TO THE CHAMBER I SEE NO
OTHER MICROPHONES THAT ARE
RAISED- IS THERE A MOTION.
SENATOR US MOST. ALL RIGHT
CENTER SKINNER DOT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
OR THANK YOU BENCI COUNSEL TO
CALL THE ROLL THIS IS S. B. C.
FORTY SIX THE MOTION BY SEN DID
I SELL. THE IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS I'M
BURKE. AMBERG I. WE'RE JUST NOT
VOTING IT'LL ZERO AYE INDEED
AYE SO DID I SO I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG DEFINITION
JONES RIGHT BUT JONES NO
LAYERED. LAYERED BY STERN THE
DIVISIONS ARE TOO BROAD AND IT
IS CAPTURES. IT'S QUITE CAL SKI.
CASKEY WE YEAH WIENER I'D
THAT'S NINETEEN. THAT TWO ONE A
COUPLE NOT WILL IN PLACE AT ON
CALL THANK YOU GET I'VE TURNED
THE GAVEL OVER THIS BORE JUST-
IN ORDER. OUR BOARD TO SHARE I
PRESUME THE BILLS. ALL RIGHTS
AMERICA THANK YOU AND IF YOU
PLEASE PRESENT YOUR BILL SB
SIX. THANK MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE PRESENT SB THREE
SIX ONE IT'S VERY BILL SIMPLY
MEANS THAT A CONTRA. ENTERED
INTO A- FOR PURPOSES OF BUYING
OR PURCHASING- BUYING
PURCHASING LEASING A CAR IS
BINDING- VIRTUALLY EVERY OTHER
ELECTRONIC CONTRACT IS BINDING
YOU COULD MORTGAGE YOUR HOME
YOU COULD BUY A HOME
ELECTRONICALLY AND THAT WOULD
BE BINDING. WELL THE CHALLENGES
WITH RESPECT TO ELECTRONIC
CONTRACTS AND I UNDERSTAND SOME
FOLKS ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
OVERREACHING AND OVERBEARING SO%
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU DECIDE TO GO
INTO A DEALERSHIP AND
ELECTRONIC CONTRACT- ON A
TABLET THAT. PERHAPS ON THE
CONCERN IS THAT A SALES PERSON
MAY BE LEANING OVER ONE
SHOULDER AND RIFLING THROUGH
THE CONTRACT WITHOUT ADEQUATE
OPPORTUNITY TO VIEW AND AGREE
TO THE VARIOUS PROVISIONS- THIS
BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT YOU FROM
ENGAGING IN A HARD COPY.
CONTRACTUAL PROCESS WITH A WITH
A CAR DEALER- IT SIMPLY SAYS
THAT YOU CAN BE BOUND AND YOU
COULD. ENTER INTO A CONTRACT
ELECTRONICALLY. SINCE THE CALL
THE- THAT UPON US WELL WE'VE
ALWAYS. MUCH MORE COMMERCE
BEING CONDUCTED ELECTRONICALLY
AND MUCH MORE COMMERCE BEING
CONDUCTED FROM ONE'S HOME. WELL
IN FACT I THINK THAT THAT.
REALLY REDUCES THE CHANCE OF A
SALES PERSON OVERBEARING ON A
CONSUMER WHEN YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VIEW THE
TRANSACTION AT HOME AT YOUR
LEISURE AT WHATEVER TIME OF DAY
OR NIGHT YOU CHOOSE TO DO SO-
IS A SAID IT IT'S A SIMPLE
BILL. I WOULD ASK THAT YOU VOTE
HI I HAVE TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT MR ANTHONY SAMPSON
MANAGING PRINCIPAL SAMSON
ADVISORS AS WELL AS MR IN NYC
LAPUS. I'M HOPING THEY'RE BUILT
ON THE PHONE YEAH. ALL RIGHT
YES I'M HERE. GET AFTER I
DAMPEN ON THE OF THE NEW CARD
ASSOCIATION I FIRST WANT I
THANK THE CHAIR FOR OFFERING
BILL JUST BECAUSE THEY THE VIA
PRODUCT PURCHASE AT LEAST
PROCESS SIMPLER FASTER AND
CONVENIENT BY TAKING ADVANTAGE.
OF THE EFFICIENCIES OF THE
DIGITAL PROPERTIES THAT ARE
USED IN MANY OTHER CONTACT.
TODAY THE SENATE ADVANCE. AND I
KNOW WE'RE GETTING TO THE END
OF THE HEARING THE CHAIRS
ALREADY PROVIDE A GREAT SUMMER
THE BILL SO I JUST WANT TO ADD
A FEW. FIRST CONSUMER SURVEYS
SHOW THAT CUSTOMERS
OVERWHELMINGLY PREFER TO
COMPLETE THE CAR BUYING AND
LEASING PROCESS FROM THE
COMFORT OF THEIR OWN HOME.
RATHER THAN AT THE DEALERSHIP
AND THIS PROPOSAL. ALLOWED THEM
TO DO JUST THAT. BACK IN THE
RETURN TALK AUTOMOTIVE SURVEY.
SEVEN OUT OF TEN CONSUMERS ARE
MORE LIKELY TO BUY A CAR FROM A
DEALERSHIP IF THEY CAN START
THE PROCESS ONLINE FROM HOME.
WE'RE VERY MINDFUL THE
PURCHASING OR LEASING A VEHICLE
COULD BE A LONG PROCESS AND IT
FINDS AN INTIMIDATING ONE. BUT
FROM HOME CONSUMERS FEEL LESS
PRESSURE IN CAN REVIEW THE
TERMS OF THE CONTRACT AND MORE
FAMILIAR AND COMFORTABLE
ENVIRONMENT. RATHER THAN IN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE VEHICLE SALE
P. MANY DEALERSHIPS. TO
CONSUMER INSTEAD ELECT TO GO TO
THE DEALERSHIP. FOR THEIR
PURCHASE OR LEASE TRANSACTION
FINING THE CONTRACT ON AN
ELECTRONIC DEVICES ACROSS THIS
WHICH WHICH MOST IF NOT ALL
CONSUMERS ARE VERY MUCH EXCEPT
THEM. AS IT IS CURRENTLY
PERMITTED IN A VARIETY OF OTHER
CONTACTS. SECOND THIS PROPOSAL
AT THIS BILL PROPOSES TO DO ONE
THING NAMELY THAT IS AUTHORIZED
THE VEHICLE SALE LEASE
TRANSACTIONS TO BE SIGNED
ELECTRONICALLY. CALIFORNIANS
FEDERAL LAW IMPOSED MANY
REQUIREMENTS ON DEALERS RELATED
TO THE SALE OF A MOTOR VEHICLE
AND THESE REQUIREMENTS WILL
CONTINUE TO APPLY REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER VEHICLE CONTRACT IS
EXECUTED ELECTRONICALLY. BY WAY
OF ONE EXAMPLE THE FEDERAL
TRUTH IN LENDING ACT
REGULATIONS THE WHICH STATE
THAT THE CUSTOMER MUST BE FREE
TO TAKE POSSESSION OF. AND
REVIEW THE CONTRACT IN ITS
ENTIRETY FRONT AND BACK. BEFORE
SIGNING THE FINAL CONTRACT
REMAINS IN FULL FORCE AND
EFFECT. FURTHER LAWS PROTECTING
CONSUMERS AGAINST FRAUDULENT
ACTS SUCH AS UNILATERALLY
MODIFYING THE TERMS OF THE
FULLY EXECUTED CONTRACT WITHOUT
THE CONSUMER'S CONSENT OR
KNOWLEDGE. REMAIN IN FULL FORCE
AND EFFECT. AND FINALLY THE CAN
NOW FOR A- THE SIMPSONS TERM
FOR BY THE GENERAL'S OFFICE
INCLUDE THAT THAT BILL WOULD
ALLOW DEALERS TO TAP ON. ON ONE
QUOTE AT ON THE COUNTRY. SUCH
AS WARM THEN IT. FEES WITH THE
CAN NOW WORK. OR CONSENT. BUT
DO WE SO IS ALL FOR. ON CURRENT.
SPECIFIC THE ARE. SALES AND-
ACT WORKS. THE DEALER PROVIDE
SIMPSON NUMBER WITH THE. THREE
ONE YES IF YOU WRAP IT UP REAL
QUICK I I'M THAT. ABSOLUTELY
THAT PRECOGS FOR FORM NEEDS TO
BE PROVIDED PRIOR TO THE EXIT
OF THE- AGAIN THAT DOESN'T SEEK
TO ELIMINATE OTHERWISE MODIFY
THAT COULD FOR. REQUIREMENTS
AGAIN WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR BRING THE FORWARD IN
A PRE IF YOU CONCERT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU N. NEXT UP MODERN CAN
YOU CONFIRM- NICHOLAS- WITH CAL.
AGAIN WASTE ON THE LINE. IN OF
SO- I AM COMPLETE YOUR BECOME
TO TWO MINUTES AND. GOOD
AFTERNOON NICHOLAS OF. AGAINST
WAY- GIVEN THE LATENESS OF AN
OKAY MY COMMON WERE VERY SHORT.
WE THROW AWAY A HUNDRED FIFTH
THOUSAND. OF OFFICE PAPER EVERY
YEAR. AND IT IS REALLY ONE OF
THE MORE STAGGERING STATISTICS
BECAUSE SO MUCH OF THAT IS
UNNECESSARY AND TAKE THEM THAT
WE CAN TRANSITION TO- TO
ELECTRONIC SIGNATURES. ACROSS
THE ECONOMY IT WILL BE ABLE TO
GET RID OF ONE OF THE- LOW
HANGING FRUIT FOR- WASTE
REDUCTION. FOR THOSE REASONS WE
SUPPORT ARE YOU SURE I THOUGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU LET'S BEGIN
WITH ANY SUPPORT WITNESSES HERE
IN THE SENATE GALLERY. SEEING
NONE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM. ONE
TWELVE. I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE
A VIDEO FEED ON ONE TWELVE.
NONE THERE WE GO WE GOT IT NOW-
NO ONE IS IN ROOM ONE TWELVE-
WILL MOVE ON TO THE SUPPORT
WITNESSES WE'VE TESTIFIED VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATE
IF YOU COULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIX ONE.
AND ALSO TELL ME HOW MANY ARE
THERE IN THE QUEUE UP. OKAY WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW HAVE FIVE IN THE
QUEUE AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SUPPORT THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO.
IMMUTABLE THE LINE UP. TO
SEVENTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS ANOTHER LUCK
WITH THE WIDENING GROUP ON
BEHALF OF EACH YEAR AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NINE NUMBER. THREE
TWENTY EIGHT. HEY THAT LINE HAS
DROPPED OUT AND WE HAVE MY
NUMBER. THREE THIRTY ONE. IN IN
CHERRY MEMBERS NAMELY TO WE
KEEP YAKKING ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE AND SUPPORT. IN
THEIR LAST SUPPORT IS. THREE
TWENTY FOUR. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER OF THE
AND UNITING HERE ON BEHALF OF
**** AUTOMOTIVE IN SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHT MARIA CAN YOU CONFIRM
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE- WAITING IN
THE QUEUE TO OFFER SUPPORT.
THERE ARE NO OTHER. CALLERS IN
THE QUEUE THANK YOU HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW FALL THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. EARLY THERE WAS A-
NO OPPOSITION. IN THE PERSON
ANYONE IN THE SENATE GALLERY.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN ONE
TWELVE. STE SEEING NONE- LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES-
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR ANY INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS TO BE THEIR
OPPORTUNITY RECERTIFIED THE
NUMBER THANK. SURE WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER THREE TWENTY SEVEN.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
ROSE MERRY SHAKE HIM PRESIDENT
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
AND SAFETY AND- I APPRECIATE
THE THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS OF THE
LEGISLATION AND THE AUTHOR'S
INTENT- HOWEVER WE SHARE THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE EXPRESSED BY
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
AND BY THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF CONSUMER ADVOCATES THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
WE REGRET THAT WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL
UNLESS IT'S AMENDED TO INCLUDE
JUST SOME BASIC SAFEGUARDS. ARE
NECESSARY- AND- WE HEAR FROM
CONSIDER WHO HAVE BEEN SOME TO
YOU CONTRACTING. CURRENTLY AND-
WHEN IT GOES WELL CAN GO VERY
WELL AND WHEN THEY HAVE
POSSESSION OF THE DOCUMENTS AND
CAN REVIEW THEM AT THEIR
LEISURE- THERE REALLY BANDAGES
FOR CONSUMERS UNDER THAT
SCENARIO. BUT UNFORTUNATELY
SOMETIMES WHEN CONSUMERS ARE AT
THE DEALERSHIP THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO. ACCESS THE DOCUMENT
DIRECTLY AND SOMETIMES THEY
DON'T SEE THE TERMS AT ALL THEY
JUST SEE THE BACK OF THE
COMPUTER MONITOR AND SO THERE'S
BEEN A NUMBER OF ABUSES AND WE
WOULD URGE THAT THE BILL BE
AMENDED TO ENSURE THAT UNDER
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW. SAID
CONSUMERS ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
THE DIP THE INFORMATION ON
THEIR OWN DEVICE. AND IN THE
LANGUAGE IN WHICH THE DEAL WAS
NEGOTIATED AND THAT IF THERE'S
A DISCREPANCY BETWEEN THE
VERSION THAT'S- IN THE
POSSESSION OF THE DEALER AND
WHAT THE CONSUMER HAVE ON THEIR
DEVICES IT'S PRESUMED. THAT THE
CONSUMERS VERSION IS A VALID
ONE AND ALSO THAT WHEN THERE
ARE VIOLATIONS OF THE FEDERAL
LAW THAT THEY WOULD BE
ENFORCEABLE UNDER CALIFORNIA
STATE CONSUMER PROTECTION.
STATUTES SO THAT FOR INSTANCE
THE TRUTH IN LENDING PROVISIONS
THAT- THOSE SUPPORTERS
MENTIONED CAN BE ENFORCED UNDER
OUR STATE LAW THANK YOU MA'AM
CAN YOU ARE THANK YOU YOUR
NAME- I'M NOT CERTAIN I CAUGHT
THAT WHEN YOU FIRST BEGAN. TO
OVER FIFTY ROAD MERRY SHEA HAND
AND I'M PRESIDENT CONSUMERS FOR
AUTO RELIABILITY AND SAFETY
THANK YOU. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. IF NOT WE'LL
MOVE ON TO INDIVIDUAL. OF FOLKS
WISHING DO NOT. AND THAT WAS A
NO. YEAH WE DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY
LIKE YOU THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT-
THANK YOU TO ALL THE FOLKS WHO
OFFERED SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WHEN I BRING THIS DISCUSSION
BACK TO- SENATOR WHAT KASKY.
THANK YOU MR ARCHER I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WERE RAISED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND ART WHAT
I'M WORRIED ABOUT IS IT SEEMS.
A POSITIVE THING THAT PEOPLE
COULD READ THE CONTRACT AT HOME
THEY COULD LOOK AT LOOK AT IT
ON THEIR TABLETS AND IN THE
LAND AND- AVOID THAT PRESSURE.
I'M WONDERING. IF DO YOU
ANTICIPATED TO THE DEALERS
WOULD SEND THE CONTRACTS TO THE
PEOPLE ON THEIR TABLET WHEN
THEY'RE AT THE WHEN I LOOK AT
THE CAR AND THEY SAID MAKE
CONTRACT AND THEN I GO HOME AND
I. I LOOK AT IT OR AND WHY
WOULD THEY NOT BE DOING THAT
RIGHT NOW IF THEY- IF IT WERE
POT IF IT WERE A FILLED CAR
RIDE ISSUE WHEN PEOPLE SIGN.
I'M SURE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU SIR WIECKOWSKI.
BOB THIS IS HAPPENED OVER THE
COURSE LAST VIEWS BUT MORE
PARTICULARLY IN THE LAST TWELVE
MONTHS PEOPLE DON'T GO INTO A
DEALERSHIP. PEOPLE PURCHASE A
CAR ONLINE. THEY LOOK AT THE
CAR. THEY EXAMINE THE
ATTRIBUTES OF THE CAR THEY
PURCHASED THE CAR ONLINE IS
DELIVERED TO THEIR HOME.
WITHOUT EVER VISITING A
DEALERSHIP. BOB IF A PERSON
DOESN'T DEALERSHIP AND I
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS AND WE
WILL WORK CONTINUE TO WORK TO
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS. I THINK
THE PRIMARY CONCERNS ARE WHEN
YOU GO TO A DEALERSHIP. AND YOU
HAVE A TABLET AS WAS TESTIFIED
BY ONE OF THE WITNESSES AND YOU
CAN'T EVEN SEE THE TABLET
SOMEHOW THE- SALES PERSON IS
RIFLING THROUGH IT. AND JUST
GETTING YOUR ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF
CERTAIN PROVISIONS THAT YOU
SEEING IT. THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE AND WILL HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THAT SO IF YOU'RE IN
THE DEALERSHIP YOU GET A
CONTRACT TO GET. PRESS YOU GET
IT HARD COPY- BUT- AGAIN I HAVE
PURCHASE THINGS ONLINE. FOR THE
LUXURY MY OWN HOME SOMETIMES
AND WANTED BUT NEVER PRESSURED
TO DO SO- VERSUS HISTORICALLY
GOING TO YOU KNOW BUY USED CAR.
AND IT'S A DIFFERENT EXPERIENCE
IT'S THE IT IS A LOT EASIER AND
A LOT LESS. PRESSURE FILLED TO
DO SO AT HOME. I KNOW MISTER
CHAIR FOR A SECOND. THERE ARE A
LOT OF ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
PROHIBITED BY LAW AND SOME
HEALTH FRAUDULENT CAN
FRAUDULENT REPRESENTATIONS AND
WE HOPE THAT THE LAW. PUNISHES
THOSE PEOPLE ARE COLLECTS ON
THE AG'S OFFICE YOU KNOW WHAT I
THINK I HEARD THE WITNESS
SAYING WELL WE NOW THAT THOSE
ARE THOSE ACTIVITIES ARE
ALREADY PROHIBITED BY LAW BUT
THE AG'S OPPOSITION TO THIS IS
THAT THIS. ELECTRONIC MEDIUM IS
CORRECT THE REASON IT WASN'T
INCLUDED IN. THE ORIGINAL- THE-
EDTA WAS BECAUSE OF. ON TO
SAY THIS GRACEFULLY THIS THIS
THIS PRESSURE THE PEOPLE FEEL
WHEN THEY GO IN AND THEY PAYING
PURCHASE PURCHASE A CAR- HOW DO
YOU RESPOND TO THOSE THINGS
THAT THE POTENTIAL HAS NOT
CHANGED AS FAR AS THE AG'S
OFFICE AND THEY'RE STILL
PROSECUTING THESE THINGS ARE
STILL THIS BAD ACTIVITY GOING
ON AND THEY FEEL THAT THE
ELECTRONIC. TRANSACTION IS
GOING TO OPEN UP THOSE.
POSSIBILITIES SO I
FUNDAMENTALLY DISAGREE I
FUNDAMENTALLY DISAGREE WITH THE
PROPOSITION THAT. BUYING A CAR
IS SO UNIQUE. THAT YOU CAN'T DO
IT FROM YOUR HOME- SO FOR
EXAMPLE YOU IS I SAID EARLIER
YOU CAN MORTGAGE YOUR HOUSE.
FROM YOUR HOME- I THINK THAT. I
THINK TIMES HAVE CHANGED NUMBER
ONE AND I THINK THAT IN ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE IN ANY
TRANSACTION.WHERE THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT- THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT FOR EXAMPLE
TO THE SALES PERSON YOU MAY
ENCOUNTER SOME SORT OF
OVERBEARING SALES PEOPLE
OVERBEARING SALES PEOPLE WHO
MAY. PRESSURE YOU INTO BUYING
THINGS THAT YOU DON'T WANT. AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU BUY
THINGS YOU DON'T KNOW THAT'S
FRAUD. AND YOU CAN'T BE HELD TO
THAT IF YOU ENTER INTO A
CONTRACT BASED ON FRAUDULENT
REPRESENTATIONS AS IS AS WE
KNOW THAT IS THE VOID OR
VOIDABLE. SO I DON'T I DON'T
SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS SIMPLY.
OKAY THAT'S MY QUESTIONS OR ANY
OTHER MEMBER WISHING TO- PUT
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NONE- CENTER OMER WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE. URGENT IDLE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION ON
SB THREE SIX ONE. I'LL MAKE
THAT MOTION- THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY THE TEMPERATURE CENTER
BORDERS- THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- COUNCIL WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION OKAY THIS IS SB THREE
SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR- BURKE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED REFERRED TO A
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS I'M
BURKE HI. I'M BURKE HI. PORTIS
FIVE BARGES HI CAMBIADO HI
KERRY AT ALL I DID SO NINE DID
SO I CONSULT I WANT. I
HERTZBERG. JONES JONES I
LAYERED HI LAYERED I STERN SURE
NINE STERN I Y. CASKEY NO WAY
CASKEY NO WIENER ALL RIGHT
WIENER AYE THAT'S ONE TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE SIX SEVEN EIGHT
THAT'S NINETY ONE PUT IT ON
CALL. NINE HIS WANTED NO N. ONE
ABSENT AND PLEASE PUT THIS-
THIS BILL ON CALL THANK YOU.
OKAY MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE SB SIX SIX
FIVE ALSO BY CENTER- BURKE- CAN
YOU PLEASE PERCENT. YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB SIX SIX
FIVE IT IS ALSO SIMPLE BILL
WHAT IT DOES IS IT SIMPLY
ALLOWS THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO DO
WITH THE PUBLIC SECTOR'S MABEL
TO DO. FOR A VERY LONG TIME AND
THAT'S PROVIDE A HIRING
PREFERENCE FOR VETERANS THERE
ARE SEVERAL PURPOSES TO DO SO
FIRST IS TO RECOGNIZE AND HONOR
THE SERVICE OF VETERANS
SECONDLY IS TO PROVIDE THE
PRIVATE SECTOR THE SAME.
BENEFIT IF YOU WILL AS THE
GOVERNMENT SECTOR BY BASICALLY.
PROVIDING THIS PREFERENCE TO
VETERANS. AND THIRD IT ALSO. IT
PROVIDES ESPECIALLY A INCENTIVE
FOR FOLKS TO ENTER INTO
MILITARY SERVICE AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT ONE BELIEVES THAT
SOCIETAL GOOD I DO I REALLY
RECOGNIZE SOME DON'T THAT WE
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO JOIN
MILITARY SERVICE IT'S SERVICE
THAT FUNCTION AS WELL- THERE
ARE THERE ARE. CLEARLY SOME
WRONGFUL ACTS THEY'VE BEEN DONE
BY THE MILITARY AS AN
INSTITUTION. SEGREGATION IN THE
MILITARY AS EXISTS ANYWHERE WAS
WRONG THAT WAS ABOLISHED IN THE
LATE NINETEEN FORTIES-
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST LGBTQ
INDIVIDUALS THAT WAS WRONG.
IT'S BEEN ABOLISHED
DISCRIMINATION IN BEIJING
AGAINST TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS
THAT WAS WRONG IT'S BEEN
ABOLISHED. THE QUESTION NOW IS
FOR THE TWENTY TWO YEAR OLD
SERVICE MEMBERS LEAVING SERVICE
DO WE WANT TO PROVIDE THAT
TRANSITION DO WE WANT TO
PROVIDE THAT ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY I THINK THE ANSWER
IS YES OUR MILITARY- TODAY IS
HAS AN OVER REPRESENTATION OF
CERTAIN GROUPS FOR EXAMPLE
AFRICAN AMERICANS ARE
OVERREPRESENTED AS COMPARED TO
THE GENERAL POPULATION THE SAME
THING WITH WITH LATINOS THEY'RE
OVER REPRESENTED AS COMPARED TO
THE- GENERALPOPULATION. WOMEN
COMPRISE A SMALLER PORTION OF
THE MILITARY- AS WOULD BE
TESTIFIED BY MY WIFE MILITARY
WAS NOT THE MOST WELCOME PLACE
TO WORK MOMENT FOR MANY MANY
YEARS THAT IS DIFFERENT TODAY
THAT IS DIFFERENT TODAY THE
QUESTION IS AGAIN DO WE WANT TO
PROVIDE THAT KIND OF SUPPORT TO
A VETERAN WHO'S LEAVING SERVICE
I RECOGNIZE THAT THIS WOULD%
APPLY NOT JUST TO THE TWENTY
EIGHT YEAR OLDS NOT JUST THE
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLDS. BUT TO
THOSE WHO ARE FURTHER ALONG AS
VETERANS BOB AND- SOME VETERANS
WHO ARE OLDER. REQUIRE THAT
KIND OF SUPPORT IS WELL
VETERANS HAVE A HIGHER HOMELESS
POPULATION AND THEY HAVE A
HIGHER SUICIDE RATE THAN THE
GENERAL POPULATION. AND SO AS A
SOCIETAL GOOD I THINK WE SHOULD
PROVIDE THEM THAT PREFERENCE.
IF WE DO WILL BE JOINING FORTY
OTHER STATES THAT DO SO. SO AYE
RICHER AYE VOTE I ALSO HAVE A
TWO WITNESSES WHO I HOPE YOU'RE
ON THE PHONE LINE TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT WE HAVE- MISTER
MICHAEL CALLED BERMAN AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL. FOR- SHERMAN S.
H. R. M. N. MISTER BOBBY
MCDONALD A NAVY VETERAN OR A
VETERAN AND PRESIDENT CEO OF
ORANGE COUNTY- BLACK CHAMBER.
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN CONFIRM
THESE TWO INDIVIDUALS ARE ON
THE LINE BUT FIRST IF WE MAY IF
AVAILABLE CAN WE START WITH THE
MISTER MACDONALD. HELLO MINDSET
BE OPEN YEAH. OKAY I'M GONNA MR
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES SIR. HELLO MY NAME
IS BARBIE NUMBER PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE BLACK CHAMBER OF
ORANGE COUNTY AND WE'RE
INTERNET THIRTIES YEAR. I MEAN
I THINK VIETNAM VETERAN HAVING
SERVED FROM NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
TO NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT. TO TWO
HOURS ABOARD THE USS TRIPOLI
LPH TEN FIVE SERVED AS A
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE TO THE
CALIFORNIA CULTURAL
HISTORICALLY DOMINANT BOARD AND
THE SEVENTEEN MEMBER STATE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM WHERE I HILL CREATING
CHAIRED. THE BOARD'S VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE AND ALSO
CREATE THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY.
COLLEGE VETERANS SUB. RECENTLY
CALVET ASKED ME TO BE PART OF
IT PRACTICE BETTER. WHAT MY
TOPICS OF THIS WERE.
ENTREPRENEURS RESOURCE FOR
SMALL BUSINESS. THIS IS BETTER
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE PROGRAMS
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY ACCESS KEY
INFORMATION IN THE BUSINESS
BECAUSE JUST. WHAT ARE OTHER
AVENUES THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
BETTER EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK CHAMBER
OF ORANGE COUNTY I'M HERE TO
SPEAK ON SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND I WILL SHOP HOPE THAT. IT
IS SUPPORTED BY CHAMBERS THIS I
CALIFORNIA ARE ALREADY HAS A
FOR. IN UNDER EXISTING LAW IS A
NARROW. ISN'T STATE THE
VETERANS PRESS. EXCEPT ONLY
APPLY TO BE A THERE VETERANS
MYSELF. SO S. B. SIX FIVE
EXPAND DEPRIVE EMPLOYER TO
ALLOW PRICE EMPLOYEES. EMPLOY
AN OPPORTUNITY ESTABLISH A MAKE-A WRITTEN VETERANS PREFERENCE
EMPLOYMENT. AND HIRES I READ.
TO ALL THE- OF THE BLACK
CHAMBER BEEN WORKING.
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BETTER CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ON WAYS TO SUPPORT
VETERANS AND PRIVATE BUSINESSES
WITH EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES.
BOTH CHAMBERS AGREE IT IS
IMPORTANT HELP MATCH VETERANS
TO JOBS THE CURRENT AND FUTURE
BETTER. PLANS FOR YOUR
PERMANENT VOTER SUPPORT SB SIX
SIX FIVE. AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY. THANK
YOU MISTER MACDONALD. AND NEXT
WE MR CALLED. THANK YOU CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES SIR IF YOU CAN
KEEP YOUR TO MINUTES WOULD BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED. I WILL DO
MY BEST HERE AMBER AGAIN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL ALL
HEARING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY FOR HUMAN
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT AND ITS
AFFILIATES THE SOCIETY FOR
HUMAN RESOURCE MANAGEMENT. WE
ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT SB SIX SIX FIVE.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO THANK
VETERANS FOR THEIR SERVICE. SB
SIX SIX FIVE WOULD GO BEYOND
THE VERBAL THANK YOU AND WOOD
MATERIALLY. VETERANS AND
FINDING GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
WHICH IS CRUCIAL TO THE
VETERANS LONG TERM ECONOMIC AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL BENEFITS. MANY
EMPLOYERS EXPRESSED AN INTEREST
IN ACTIVELY RECRUITING AND
HIRING VETERANS BUT ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LAWSUIT.
ACCORDINGLY AND- FIVE WOULD
ENABLE EMPLOYERS WHO WISH TO
PROVIDE A VOLUNTARY HIRING
PREFERENCE TO DO SO. PROVIDED
THEY ADHERE TO SB SIX SIX FIVE
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE IT IS
NOT DONE. AN IMPROPER MANNER. A
VOLUNTEER HIRING PREFERENCE AND
HEART LAWFUL. OVER FORTY STATE
BLUE RED AND- HAVE AN ACTIVE
SUCH PREFERENCES ALMOST ALWAYS
OVER. AND OFTEN THE- IT ALSO
CONSISTS WITH HOW. LAW WHICH
WILL HIRING PREFERENCE MCCALL
SECTOR. INDEED OR HAVE THE PRO.
FOR THE FOR EMPLOYER AND SB SIX
SIX FIVE ASSEMBLY. PREFERENCE
TO BE USED FOR VETERANS ARE SO
BE ON AFTER THE VIETNAM WAR.
BEYOND BEING LAWFUL IS.
VETERANS BRING UNIQUE THAT
RENDER THEM. FOR THE DAY THANK.
YOU IF THEIR RESUME. RESUMES
FOR LOOKING THAN THE WHO HAVE
COME TRADITIONAL. AND IS A TIE
BETWEEN. IS NOT UNFAIR FROM TO
FOR THAT HIGH IN FAVOR OF THOSE
ELECTED TO SERVE. AND THEIR
PRIVATE AND CAREERS LASTLY IS
NOT. SB SIX FIVE INCLUDES
NUMEROUS PROPOSED CHANGE CANNOT
BE USED TO IN TEN DISK AGAINST
ANY THE GROUP. SB SIX SIX
OPPONENTS WILL TRY CONCERN
ABOUT. JUST IMPACT RESPECTFULLY
THERE'S A HAVE OF THAT IN THE
FORTY SUPPORT AND HAVE FROM. OR
THE CAL PUBLIC SECTOR AND IS.
MOREOVER SECTION I'M VERY IS
UNLIKELY SINCE THE CAR NODE AND
PROBABLY MORE. OFTEN WITH
MEMBERS OF THE TECHNICAL UNLESS
AT HIGHER RATES THAN GENERAL.
SB SIX FIVE YOUR UP. TO DO WHAT
I'M EVERYONE WAS NEW MEETING
POINT THANK BETTER OR- AND IN A
MANNER THAT. FAIR AND I'M NON.
YOUR SEX REQUESTED COMMITTEES
AT SIX FIVE A AN AYE. I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
CALL- NOT SPEAK WITH SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN THE SAN GALA.
SEEING NOW MOVING ON ROOM TWO.
C. NONE. FIVE WE MOVE ON TO
SUPPORT WERE TEST FOR VIA TO MA
WE HAVE ANY IN THE QUEUE S. B.
SIX FIVE INSTEAD. WE HAVE THREE
IN Q. FOUR SUPPORT LINE NUMBER
THREE TEN PEOPLE HAD. NINE
THREE ONE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GO BACK TO THE NEXT FINE
OF THE THREE THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER ROWE ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA GOODWILL INDUSTRIES
REPORT THANK YOU. ALL. MOTORED
WE ONE MORE I. AND YET WE HAVE
ONE COMING IN RIGHT NOW- THREE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS S MIKE MADIGAN PRESIDENT
OF THE NATIONAL GUARD
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MODERATE
CAN YOU CONFIRM THERE'S NO WITH
NO OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHICH
INTENSIFIED SUPPORT. WE DO HAVE
ONE THAT IF YOU DEFINITELY
NUMBER THREE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MEDICARE
MEMBERS FORTY JENSEN MY
FERNANDO THURMOND GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSING- CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SUPPORTERS ONE OF ALL THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. MODERATE
MODERATE I BELIEVE KEVIN BAKER
WITH THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
ON THE LINE IN OPPOSITION CAN
YOU CONFIRM. HIS TEACHER I'M-
THE TEACHER NUMBERS CONNECTING
THIS IS KEVIN BAKER OF
GOVERNMENTAL. WITH ACLU
CALIFORNIA. AS YOU MAY KNOW THE
SKILLS YOU HAVE DONE A LOT OF
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF MILITARY
VETERANS OVER MANY YEARS.
INCLUDING EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AND THE PROBLEMS
OF IMMIGRANT VETERANS. I MEAN
WE APPLAUD THE AUTHORS GOAL OF
ATTACHING EMPLOYMENT. FOR
VETERANS. WITH GREAT RESPECT
FOR THE AUTHOR WE REGRETTABLY
FIND OURSELVES NEVERTHELESS
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT ITERATION. BUT APPELLEE
OUR REQUESTED AMENITIES SMALL
BUT WHAT ISN'T. WE SIMPLY ASKED
THE BILL CLEAR THAT IT IS NOT
INTENDED TO ALLOWS. AGAINST
WOMEN AND OTHERS THAT IS
CURRENTLY OUT. AND WE'RE WHO
NOTED IN OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
SOME NUMBERS. ALL OF DISCORDANT
BACK DISCRIMINATE WHICH
RECOGNIZING AGO AND HAS NEVER
REALLY. BEEN QUITE. DESPITE THE
SENATE BY THE TRUMP AND THE TO
A POLICY UNDER LAW. THE PROBLEM
WITH THE BILL IS TO PREVENT
INSTRUCTIONS. CAN'T PUT HAPPEN
TO PUT INTO AGAINST WOMEN
OTHERS HAVE BEEN. I'M NO. HE'S
CALLED HE'S TO IN VERY DESCRIBE
BUT THEY OFTEN. COM TO THIS ONE
TEN. YOU S. ECONOMY PLAN THE
TOPIC COMMISSION HAS NOTED THAT
VETERAN PREFERENCE PUBLIC ARE.
JUST ON THE BASE OF GENDER
BECAUSE ABOUT 90% OF THE GROUP
MADE UP MAIL. WHAT WOULD WHO
THAT IN PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RULE
PERMIT FEDERAL POLICY. THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THEY CAN'T BE JUST.
IT ONLY MEANS THAT THERE'S A
SCREEN TOWARDS PACKAGE. MINOR
DETAILS THEY ARE TO THE TECH.
AND THE PRO- PROBABLY ON
LARGELY NEGATED BY THE-
COUNTERVAILING TENDENCY OF
PUBLIC TO BE MORE. TO BECOME
THAT AGAINST ANOTHER CLASSES.
ONE WITH MORE ROBUST PUBLIC
OVERSIGHT OF GOVERNMENTAL.
OPENING UP VETERANS GROUP POLL
TO PRIVATE EMPLOYER LEAST TO IN
THE- OUT. ASSEMBLY SO MANY AND
ENJOY IN THE SECTOR MISTER
BAKER HUGH IF ANY COMES YES
MISTER BUSH. ARE YOUR TIME IS
UP YEAH YOU READ IT UP THANK
YOU VERY. PART OF THE TO DO I
DO BELIEVE THE ARE OTHER
TESTIFYING WITNESSES NOT BE SO
OFTEN JUST HAVE A MOMENT LONGER.
I JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT ARE
VERY FEW CAN. AGAINST FAILURE
TO HIRE WOMEN OTHER UP. GROUPS
IN PRIVATE EMPLOYMENT. THE ONE
CONSTRAINT WE HAVE THERE'S A
LAW AGAINST DISCRIMINATION. BUT
THAT MORE WILL BE A MYSTERY ON
THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL
BECAUSE IT WILL ALLOW A
COMPLETE DEFENSE AGAINST WHICH
WOULD IMPACT DISCRIMINATION.
UNLESS IT IS AMENDED TO CLOSE
OFF THAT POSSIBILITY. WE HAVE
HEARD REPRESENT OF IN HEALTH.
LGBTQ MEMBERS FROM THE NO.
INCREASED IN THE YEARS. AT IS
CERTAINLY TO THE GOOD. BUT OF
COURSE THIS IS ABOUT BETTER NOT
DO MEMBERS OF THOSE WITH
MISSION BEEN JUST. APOLLO
EMPLOYMENT. PROTECTIONS BECAUSE
THERE ARE MORE IN THE- NOW. IS
LIKE A POLICY DISC PROTECTION
WITHIN THE HEART TECH AREA
BECAUSE THERE ARE MORE WOMEN IN
COLLEGE STEM CLASSES THAN THERE
USED TO BE. FINALLY JUST
MENTION THAT DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST VETERANS IS CURRENTLY
PROHIBITED INCLUDING ANY
POLICIES THAT HAVE DISPARATE
IMPACT AGAINST VETERANS. ALL
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WHICH
SIMPLY ALLOW OTHER GROUPS TO
HAVE THE SAME PROTECTION
AGAINST DISCRIMINATION VETERANS
HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER OCCUR. I
APPRECIATE THE CALL- ARE MOVING
ON ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
SENATE GALLERY SEEING NONE ROOM
ONE TWELVE. ALSO SEEING NINE
WILL MOVE ON TO- WITNESSES
WAITING TESTIFIED VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR ANY
FOLKS WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TWO SIX SIX FIVE.
IF YOU ARE WILLING TO
OPPOSITION PLEASE. ONE ZERO.
IT'LL BE JUST ONE SECOND HERE.
OKAY AND WE HAVE A LINE- THREE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JESSICA STENDER AND I'M
PROVIDING A COMMENT ON BEHALF
OF EQUAL RIGHT THAT THE KIDS
THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON THE
BILL. HOWEVER WE APPRECIATE
THAT THE OFFICE OFFICE OF THE
GREETED ME WITH THAT THIS WEEK
TO DISCUSS THE POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS THAT ADDRESSED THE
BOARD THAT WE HAVE AND I
BELIEVE WE ALL SHARE WHICH IS
CONCERNED THAT THE BILL DOES
NOT UNINTENTIONALLY HAVE A GOOD
FOR IMPACT ON WOMEN AND
HISTORICALLY. EXCLUDED GROUPS
WE LOOK FOR. HOW MUCH. THANK
YOU MOTOR CAN YOU CAN. THERE'S
NO. ELSE THE LINE. YOU
INDIVIDUAL OR OTHERWISE THERE
ARE. YES THERE IS NOBODY IN THE
QUEUE RIGHT NOW ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE MEMBERS- WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF MIKE'S UP LET'S START WITH-
CENTER DRAWS- AND THEN CENTER
WHAT CASTING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I AM REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S-PASSION AND
COMMITMENT TO. DO EVERYTHING WE
CAN FOR VETERANS. THIS IS A
DIFFICULT BECAUSE ON THE ONE
HAND- I TRULY RESPECT AND WOULD
LIKE TO DO EVERYTHING THAT WE
CAN. SUPPORT OUR VETERANS URGE
FOR VETERANS IN MY FAMILY
STARTING WITH MY FATHER- AND I.
UNDERSTAND THIS- WHEN THE
SYSTEM THE- VETERANS THOSE WHO
HAVE SERVED IN THE ARMED
SERVICES FOR THE MOST PART ARE
WORKING CLASS- MEN AND WOMEN
THEY- MANY TIMES DIDN'T HAVE
ANOTHER OPTION DIDN'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANOTHER JOB.
WHICH IS WHY THEY SOMETIMES
THAT WAS THE REASON. THEY WERE
PUSHED AND FORCED TO DO THAT AS
AS THEIR ONLY OPTION- BUT AT
THE HEART OF IT AT THE CORE WAS
OBVIOUSLY A COMMITMENT TO THIS
COUNTRY. SO THAT OTHER HAND
I'VE SPENT MY LIFE FIGHTING
AGAINST DISCRIMINATION.
FIGHTING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE GROUPS OF. AMERICANS ARE
NOT. DO NOT CONTINUE TO BE
EXCLUDED AND DISCRIMINATED AND
PUT AT THE BOTTOM OF THE LIST
WHILE OTHERS KEEP RISING TO THE
TOP. SO IT'S- IT'S DIFFICULT-
ON THIS SO I WOULD REALLY URGE-
WORDS THE AUTHORED TO AS YOU
ARE. GOING TO MEET WITH THEM
THOSE WHO THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
CONCERNS- THAT WE DO ALL WE CAN
TO- NOT ALLOWED DISPARATE
IMPACT. ON ALL ON OTHER GROUPS-
AND THAT WE LOOK FOR WAYS OF
ADDRESSING. THAT ISSUE- IDEA I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY BUT
I REALLY WANT US TO ADDRESS
THAT- THAT'S WHAT I HAVE TO
SAY. OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR
ALSO CENTER WHAT CASKEY AND
THEN CENTER WIENER. I'M LOOKING
AROUND I THINK I'M THE ONLY
PERSON THAT IS VOTED NO ON THIS
BILL THREE TIMES SO. THERE'S
OMETHING TO BE SAID ABOUT
BEING HERE FOR A WHILE.
OPPOSITION RAISES A POINT ABOUT
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL RIGHT
NOW BEING A COMPLETE DEFENSE
AGAINST- WHAT WOULD ORDINARILY
BE UNLAWFUL DISCRIMINATION.
HAVE A COMMENT ON THAT THE
AUTHOR- AND I'VE HEARD THE
CONCERN THAT SOMEHOW THIS BILL
BE USED AS A SUBTERFUGE FOR
HIRING YOU KNOW A CERTAIN KIND
OF WHITE MALES FOR EXAMPLE IT'S
A SUBTERFUGE FOR HIRING WHITE
MALES TO THE EXTENT THERE CAN
BE LANGUAGE IT SAYS IF YOU'RE
USING THIS IN A WAY THAT THE
SUBTERFUGE TO HIRE WHITE MALES
THEN I'LL CERTAINLY
ENTERTAINING I'M NOT SURE WHAT
THAT LANGUAGE IS IF THE CONCERN
IS AN AND THE OPPONENTS SAY
LOOK AT UNTIL THE MILITARY IS
50% FEMALE 50% MALE. THAT'S NOT
ATTAINABLE GOAL FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS IS TO SIMPLY NOT
ATTAINABLE GOAL AND IF THEY'RE
SAYING THE VETERAN POPULATION
NEED BE FIFTY FIFTY THAT'S NOT
ATTAINABLE GOAL IN THE NEXT
HUNDRED YEARS OR SO BECAUSE THE
RIGHT EFFECTS THEY'RE NO LONGER
ARE THE BARS THAT ONCE EXISTED
FOR EXAMPLE FOR WOMEN WILL HAVE
A DISPARATE IMPACT IT WILL
COULD IN FACT. GIVEN THE
POPULATION THE MILITARY TODAY
IT PROBABLY HAS A DISPARATE
IMPACT IT PROBABLY IT FAVORS
LATINOS BECAUSE THE LATINOS
HAVE A LARGER PORTION OF THE
MILITARY THAN THE GENERAL
POPULATION IT FAVORS AFRICAN
AMERICANS BECAUSE AFRICAN
AMERICANS COMPRISE A LARGER
PORTION MILITARY THAN THE
GENERAL POPULATION WHICH IS
SIMPLY A FACT AND IT'S A GOOD
THING BY THE WAY I THINK IT IS
A GOOD THING THAT THAT THAT THE
MILITARY HAS A DISPROPORTIONATE
NUMBER OF LATINOS A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF
BLACKS BECAUSE IT IT EXPOSES
FOLKS TO ONE ANOTHER. MODERATE
ECONOMIC MEANS. IF YOU LOOK AT
TODAY'S MILITARY. YOU'RE GOING
TO FIND THAT PEOPLE JOIN THE
MILITARY FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS MANY MANY MANY ARE
BECAUSE OF ECONOMIC NECESSITY
YOU KNOW I STUCK AROUND FOR A
LONG TIME I COULDN'T GO TO
COLLEGE BUT FOR THE MILITARY I
SIMPLY WENT TO THE MILITARY FOR
THE EDUCATION. NOT FOR THE
REASONS LATER ON I DEVELOP SOME
OTHER PASSIONS BUT I WENT TO
THE MILITARY BECAUSE I WON A
COLLEGE EDUCATION AND YOU'RE
GOING TO FIND THAT PEOPLE IN
THE MILITARY OVERWHELMINGLY ARE
THERE BECAUSE THEY THEY- HAVE
LIMITED CHOICES NOW I THINK
MILITARY STRONG I THINK IT'S
VERY IVERSE. I THINK IT'S GOT
SOME INCREDIBLE HUMAN BEINGS.
BUT BUT IT WILL HAVE A
DISPARATE IMPACT IT WILL FAVOR
LATINOS IT WILL FAVOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS IT WILL FAVOR PEOPLE
WHO WOULD OTHERWISE NO OTHER
OPTIONS. THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT
IS. WHAT ARE THE RECORD CARE
ACT INSURANCE- I AB ARE YOU
OPENING STATEMENT I APPLAUD
THE- IDEA OF HAVING INCENTIVES
FOR PEOPLE TO GO INTO THE
MILITARY AND WE HAVE THIS CROSS
SECTION OF. LGBT AND ALLY TINOS
AND EVERYONE. THE AUTHOR AND
ARE OF A CERTAIN AGE WE
REMEMBER THAT THE REASON THAT
WE HAVE LANGUAGE IN TODAY'S LAW
WAS BECAUSE THE WAY THAT
VETERANS WERE FIFTY. PEOPLE
WERE TREATED WHEN THEY CAME
BACK FROM THE VIETNAM WAR THERE
WAS THE PREFERENCE THAT WE GAVE
FOR VIETNAM VETERANS WHOSE
BECAUSE PEOPLE SPECIFICALLY.
THEY WERE QUALIFIED THEY WERE
READY TO WIN AND THEY FOUND OUT
THAT THEY WERE THE THEY WERE
BEING DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AND
THAT WAS JUST A RECENT JUSTICE.
AT LEAST SCARE THE PRIVATE
EMPLOYEES FOR IF THEY WERE.
REGARDED THEY WERE INVOLVED IN
THAT TYPE OF ACTIVITY. THAT'S
NOT THE CASE NOW THAT'S NOT THE
CASE THAT- WERE THE EVIDENCE
THAT THERE ARE. PEOPLE FROM THE
MILITARY BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST SO THE KITTY PUBLIC
POLICY CURE FOR THE EXCEPTION
OF WE HAVE NOW WAS A REAL-
QUANTIFIABLE EVIDENCE THIS.
WHERE IS THE EVIDENCE I GUESS
IF EMPLOYERS WANT EMPLOYEES
VETERANS THEYCAN DO THAT RIGHT
NOW THERE'S NO HOME THERE IT'S
I'VE NEVER HEARD IN THE RECENT
YEARS THAT THERE'S SOME
ACTIVITY THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT
HIRING VETERANS. AT THE EXPENSE
OF OTHER. QUALIFIED FOR THE
FOLKS WHAT WOULD YOU SAY THE
NUMBER NINE THERE ARE MORE THAN
WILLING TO RESPOND TO THAT OR
ADDRESS IT YOU'RE RIGHT ALLEN'S
THIS POINT IN TIME THAT VETERAN
UNEMPLOYMENT IS PROBABLY ON PAR
AND MAYBE SLIGHTLY BETTER THAN
THE GENERAL POPULATION TODAY
BUT HISTORICALLY THAT IS NOT
THE CASE IN YOUR RIGHTS IN A
WHITE CAL SKI THINGS HAVE
CHANGED DRAMATICALLY THE FIRST
TIME I PUT ON A UNIFORM ON A
COLLEGE CAMPUS IS A SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLD SOMEONE CAME WARRANT
SPIT UPON ME. WAS A DIFFERENT
TIME WAS A DIFFERENT TIME. AS
OPPOSED TO YOU KNOW TEN YEARS
AGO COMING BACK FROM
AFGHANISTAN. WHERE PEOPLE WERE
LINED UP TO THANK YOU. A VERY
DIFFERENT TIME BUT EVEN THOUGH
FOLKS ARE LINED UP TO THANK
YOU. I WAS IN A DIFFERENT
POSITION BUT I DEALT WITH MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE. MANY YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO HAD A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
TRANSITIONING. AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS DESIGNED TO DO YES YES
WE ARE HONORING THEIR
SACRIFICE. YES WE ARE PROVIDING
AN ADDITIONAL. POINT OF
ASSISTANCE IN TERMS OF
TRANSITION AND YES IT IS A
SOCIETAL DECISION AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT WE PROVIDE THAT
INCENTIVE. IT'S IT IS I MEAN I
RECOGNIZE THAT SOME. DON'T
THINK THAT IT'S A GOOD IDEA. I
DO. ONE FINAL QUESTION THE
WHOLE MAIN OPPOSITION RAISED
THE POINT THAT IN THE PUBLIC
SECTOR WE HAVE MUCH MORE
OVERSIGHT SO THAT THAT SOMEBODY
A. D. E. D. YEARS NOT
DISCRIMINATING ABOUTTHAT BUT
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR WE HAVE
SO MANY MORE JOBS. AND THAT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MISUSE OF THIS
LAW THE INTENTION LAW IS
GREATER- AND THAT MAYBE WE
SHOULD. WELL IT IS IT'S A IT'S
A POINT THAT THEY REYES AGAINST
RESONATES WITH ME WILL WORK.
HOW DO YOU HOW DO WE DEAL WITH
THIS MORE OVERSIGHT IN THE FOR
LACK OF OVERSIGHT IN THE
DETECTOR THE SAME THE SAME
POINT IS MADE EARLIER IF
THERE'S A SUBTERFUGE IF PEOPLE
IF THERE'S A BUSINESS THAT SAYS
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE ONLY GONNA
HIRE WHITE MALES. I'M GONNA USE
THE VETERANS PREFERENCES SOME
SORT OF A SUBTERFUGE TO HIRE
ONLY WHITE MALES. THEN AGAIN. I
SUPPOSE WE CAN FIND LANGUAGE TO
INCLUDE THE BILL IF YOU FIND
THAT IS BEING USES SUBTERFUGE I
DON'T MEAN. IT PEOPLE WANT TO
GO OUT AND HIRE WHITE MALES
THEY DON'T NEED TO HIRE THEY
DON'T NEED TO FIND A VETERAN'S
PREFERENCE BAKED THEY CAN DO
IT. AND. ONE OF FALL OF OTHER
LAWS AS WELL. THE YOUR DISK.
AGAINST PROTECTED CLASSES
WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A
VETERAN'S PREFERENCE OR NOT
YOU'RE STILL VIOLATING THE LAW.
SECOND COULD YOU REMARKS OR
QUESTIONS NOT FOR TONIGHT THANK
YOU CENTER CRASKE MOVING ON TO
SENATOR- WIENER AND THEN
CABALLERO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF A DETERRENT I'M- HI. I
THOUGHT IT'S A VERY SIMILAR TO
SENATOR- TO ROSSO'S IN ON A
SUPPORT THE HE GOES ON THE BILL
TODAY AND I THINK THERE'S A
REALLY FOR A LOT OF LOCAL HERE
AND SUPPORTING. OUR VETERANS
OUT HI BUT THERE ARE RISKS OF
THE AUTHOR. THE KNOWLEDGE AS I
THINK THOSE RISKS PROBABLY WILL
GRADUALLY. SHIFT OVER TIME- BUT
IT IS. THE MILITARY IS A SLOW
MOVING- INSTITUTION
UNFORTUNATELY- AND I'M GLAD OF
THE AUTHOR THANK YOU FOR
SITTING DOWN TO MEET WITH-
ORGANIZATIONS. I THINK HAVE
BEEN RELUCTANT TO OPPOSE THE
BILL BECAUSE WE WANT TO SUPPORT
VETERANS BUT THE TWO HAVE. OUR
CONCERNS ON OPTIMISTIC THAT
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH.
THOSE ISSUES I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT- YOU KNOW IT OBVIOUSLY
VETERANS ARE VERY VERY DIVERSE.
PUTTING A DOZEN TERMS OF ERROR
LINE LIFE VERY DIVERSE SERVER
INTERNS WHO WERE DOING WHO DO
EXCEPTIONALLY WELL- I SUSPECT
THAT THEY WILL BE LESS LIKELY
TO BE THE BENEFICIARIES. OF
THIS BILL AND THAT THE
BENEFICIARIES ARE PROBABLY MORE
LIKELY TO BE VETERANS WHO MAYBE
ARE STRUGGLING. WITH EMPLOYMENT
I CAN'T SAY THAT WITH CERTAINTY
BUT THIS IS WHAT MY GUT. TELLS
ME UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE A
LOT OF. VETERANS WHO REALLY
REALLY STRUGGLE- BECAUSE OF
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
ADDICTION ISSUES AND TRAUMA-
FIFTH INABILITY TO RE
INTEGRATE- PARTICULARLY COMBAT.
VETERANS SOLDIERS SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY AND I'M
OPTIMISTIC THAT YOU'LL BE ABLE
TO WORK THROUGH THE ISSUES WITH
THE- FOLKS THAT HAVE CONCERNS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
WINNER MOVING ONTO CENTRE.
CABALLERO THAN SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I REALLY.
WANT TO SECOND WHAT- MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
HAD TO SAY I AM I AM I AM
SENSITIVE TO THE END AND
INTENDED POSSIBILITY OF
DISCRIMINATION- AT BUT I ALSO
KNOW- AND HAVE A HAD A LOT OF
INTERACTION WITH VETERANS ARE
REALLY ARE STRUGGLING AND WHO
ARE LOOKING TRYING TO FIND
THEIR PLACE IN THE ORLD COMING
BACK- SOME AFTER DIFFICULT
DEPLOYMENTS AND SO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND HOPE THAT
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THAT. WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
SEE IF THERE'S A SWEET SPOT
THERE I YOU KNOW I THERE'S A
PART OF ME THAT. THAT FEELS
LIKE YOU KNOW WE CAN'T LET THE
PERFECT BE THE ENEMY OF GOOD
AND- AND SO I'M I'M SENSITIVE
TO THAT AS WELL AND WE
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN A MINUTE SPORTED
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATE
GOVERNOR THANK YOU CENTER JONES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN CENTER
NUMBER ONE OF THANK YOU FOR
PICKING THIS UP AS IMPORTANT-
ISSUE. AS CENTER ACCOUNTS HE-
POINTED OUT THIS BILL HAS BEEN
PRESENTED THREE TIMES TO THIS
COMMITTEE- PRESENTED BY TWO-
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FROM THE
SEVENTY FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND SENT TO DIFFERENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS. FROM THE SEVENTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN SAN DIEGO-
ONE WHO HAPPENS TO BE A COMBAT
VETERAN. VIETNAM ERA VETERAN.
AND MYSELF THE SON OF A VETERAN
AND THE GRANDSON. OF A P. O. W.
VETERANS SO. I PERSONALLY
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THIS UP
AND- RECOGNIZE THAT THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS FINALLY
CATCHING UP WITH THE ASSEMBLY
THE FULL ASSEMBLY. BECAUSE ALL
THREE TIMES IT PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY- THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
CAME TO THIS COMMITTEE TO- ALL
THREE TIMES DIE IN IT
INGLORIOUS DEATH. SO I'M GOING
TO BE SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
I THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING THE
BILL AND AS A VETERAN- HONOR
YOUR SERVICE TO OUR COUNTRY
THANK YOU. AND HOPE THAT IT
WILL PASS OUT TODAY AND I
WOULD. ASK TO BE ADDED ON AS A
CO AUTHOR- IF THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO. AND I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL WHEN THERE'S NOT A TEAM OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
JOHN SAID LAYERED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR IN
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO MEET
WITH THE AUTHOR- BECAUSE OF HIS
COMMITMENT IS CLEAR. AND HIS
COMMITMENT IS TRUST IN THIS- I
THINK THAT THE A MALL LITTLE. I
THINK THE DEBATE COULD PUT A
FINER POINT ON SOME OF THESE
ISSUES IF YOU LOOK AT THE. OUR
IS A TELLING- THE AUTHOR THAT
YEARS AGO WHEN I WORKED IN
COUNTY MANAGEMENT WE HAD A
VETERANS PREFERENCE AND YES
THIS WAS AT THE TIME THAT
DIVERSITY WAS NOT WHAT IT IS
NOW IT IS IN IN THE MILITARY.
AND WE HAD A RULE OF THREE SO
WHENEVER A JOB WAS VACANT THE
TOP THREE CANDIDATES WERE SENT
BECAUSE THERE WAS A VETERANS
PREFERENCE MANY TIMES ALL THE
CANDIDATES BUNCHED TOGETHER THE
THREE THAT WERE VETERANS MOVED
TO THE TOP AT THE TIME THEY
WERE ALMOST UNIFORMLY WHITE MEN
AND WHEN WE WERE TRYING TO
DIVERSIFY THE WORK FORCE THE
VETERANS PREFERENCE WORKED
AGAINST IT. AND SO WHEN OF WE
DID A REFORM WE SAID THAT YOU
SENT TEN NAMES ON EVERY LIST
AND YOU HAVE TO INTERVIEW
EVERYBODY THAT'S ABOVE WHOEVER
YOU OFFER THE JOB TO AND AS A
RESULT WE WERE ABLE TO REACH
WOMEN BUT WERE MAKE SURE THE
VETERANS WERE GIVEN A FAIR SHOT
AND MANY TIMES THEY WERE. IN
FACT HIRED. AND SO WHEN IT IS
SAID IN THIS DEBATE THAT- IT
YOU KNOW THERE'S NO INTENTIONAL
DISCRIMINATION THAT WASN'T
INTENTIONAL THAT WAS
UNINTENTIONAL ALL THE WAY IN
ONE INCIDENT WERE MAYBE YOU
COULD PROTECT AGAINST
SUBTERFUGE THERE WAS NO
SUBTERFUGE THAT WAS CLEARLY
SOMETHING THAT WAS HAPPENING ON
THE BASIS OF HOW PEOPLE LINED
UP. AN ENORMOUS EATING AND THE
AUTHOR CAN CORRECT ME YOU SEE I
THINK THE HEART OF THE DEBATE
IS SET AT THAT TIME WE DID NOT
HAVE A DIVERSE- OF CATEGORY OR
GROUP OF VETERANS- WHILE THERE
WERE SOME PEOPLE OF COLOR. THEY
WERE OVERWHELMINGLY WHITE
THEY'RE ALMOST ENTIRELY MEN
THERE WAS NOBODY THAT WAS GAY
THAT IF YOU WERE TRYING TO HAVE
A DIVERSE WORK FORCE. VETERANS
PREFERENCE WORKED AGAINST IT.
AND YET NOW THE ARGUMENT THAT
IS BEING MADE BY THE AUTHOR. IS
THAT IF YOU LOOK WHO'S COMING
OUT OF THE MILITARY RIGHT NOW
IT'S VERY DIVERSE AND IT'S
REPRESENTED ALMOST TO WHERE THE
POPULATION IS. AND YET IF YOU
LOOK AT THE ENTIRE POOL OF
VETERANS THAT MAY APPLY THAT
DIVERSITY DOESN'T EXIST AND IN
THE IDEAL WORLD WE WOULD FIGURE
OUT A WAY. THAT WE COULD GIVE
SOME PREFERENCE TO THE PEOPLE
COMING OUT OF THE MILITARY NOW
AND WE WOULD NOT HAVE THE ISSUE
THAT WE ARE ALL TALKING ABOUT.
AND WHEN I WAS SECRETARY FOR
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WE HAVE
THE CONSERVATION CORPS WHICH
REALLY WAS HELPING PEOPLE THAT
WERE STRUGGLING WE HAVE
DEDICATED. OUR OF PIECES OF THE
CORD THAT WERE FOR TURNING
VETERANS AND AS A RESULT- WE
WERE ABLE TO HIRE OR TRAIN
PEOPLE THAT THEN WENT TO HIRE.
MANY PEOPLE THAT WERE EXACTLY
THE ONES THAT THE AUTHOR IS
TALKING ABOUT AND THAT GROUP
WAS DIVERSE AND THAT GROUP WAS
IN NEED. AND SO WITH OUR
DISADVANTAGING ANYBODY ELSE WE
COULD FIGURE OUT HOW. TO HAVE
VETERANS THAT WERE IN VETERANS
BACK TRAIL CREWS OTHER THINGS
THAT MET THAT NEED AND IT SEEMS
TO ME. THAT SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. WOULD MORE ADDRESSED THE
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE HERE. AND IT
YOU KNOW THAT AND I'M
DISAPPOINTED IN PARTS OF THE
DEBATE BECAUSE- THE SYSTEM
NOBODY EVER INTENTIONALLY.
DISCRIMINATED IT WAS ALL
UNINTENTIONAL AND YES MANY MANY
GOVERNMENTS HAVE THIS BUT MANY
GOVERNMENTS FIGURED OUT A WAY.
THAT THEY COULD STILL BE FAIR
TO THE ENTIRE POOL OF
CANDIDATES. A. N. N. SO IT
LEAVES THIS VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
I WANT TO HONOR THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS COMMITMENT WHICH IS WHICH
IS REALLY IMPRESSIVE AND S. AND
YET IF THIS BILL. MORE COME
BACK US IN THE CURRENT FORM I
COULD NOT VOTE FOR IT BECAUSE
IT DOES NOT RESOLVE. THE ISSUE
OF DISH PAIRED IMPACT IN A
PSYCH I ACTUALLY THINK IT WILL
BE TAKEN CARE OF IN TWENTY OR
THIRTY YEARS BECAUSE IF YOU
LOOK AT WHO'S COMING OUT OF THE
MILITARY NOW. AND THEY JUST GO
ONE GENERATION. I THINK IT WILL
MATCH MUCH MORE THE GENERAL
POPULATION AND SO THERE HAVE TO
BE SOME WAYS TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DEAL WITH WHO'S COMING OUT
OF THE MILITARY NOW. WHO ARE
VERY DIVERSE. AT THIS BILL
DOESN'T DO THAT SO I'M TORN
WHETHER TO NOT VOTE FOR IT. OR
FIGURE OUT. HOW THE AUTHOR
pAFTER SOME OF THESE MEETINGS
DOES IT BUT IF IT'S A
SUBTERFUGE AMENDMENT OR IT
STILL COMES BACK WITH TE SAME
KIND OF THING THAT THE LARGER
POOL THAT'S NOT THE FIRST. IS
GIVEN PREFERENCE THAT STILL
DOESN'T WORK SO A I'M STILL
TORN RIGHT NOW WHETHER TO VOTE
NO. OR IF I HAD A SENSE THAT
THERE WAS A PLACE TO GO AND I
HAVEN'T HEARD YET THERE'S A
PLACE TO GO WE VERY CLEARLY
SAID WHERE THE PROBLEM WAS. BUT
I HAVEN'T HEARD. A PLACE TO GO
THAT ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM SO
THAT'S MY CONCERN AND- I'M NOT
SURE HOW I'M GONNA VOTE AND
TELL THE ROLES CALLED BUT IT'S
OF. IT BUT I WOULDN'T EVEN IF I
END UP VOTING FOR TO GIVE THE
AUTHOR CHANCE TO FIX THIS. I'M
NOT GOING TO VOTE FOR IN ANY
FUTURE ITERATION UNLESS IT TO
REST ADDRESSES THE BASIC ISSUE.
OF THE DESPAIRED IMPACT IN A
LARGER POOL. THANK YOU CENTRAL-
MOVING ON CENTER WINNER. I
THANK YOU IS IN A CENTER AND
SALAS. I FORGOT TO- THANK YOU
SENATE IT'S ALSO THE FIRST
CLASS RECORDED. THAT'S OKAY
WE'RE MOVING ON THE CENTRE
GONZALEZ OKAY THANK YOU MR
JERRY PRITCHETT THAT AND- I
ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR FOR SPENDING TIME
WITH- WITH ME PERSONALLY
YESTERDAY AND- CERTAINLY-
UNDERSTAND- WORRIES COMING FROM
AND HIS EXPERIENCE AND THIS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL CLEARLY-
BUT I TO I JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS MY- CONCERN AS WELL FOR
THE DISPARATE- ISSUE AND
ENSURING THAT YOU KNOW WE
AREN'T. DISCRIMINATING AGAINST
OTHER- CLASSES BUT I KNOW THAT
YOU KNOW GIVEN THIS INFORMATION
AND I KNOW THAT YOU CONTINUE
WORKING WITH- THE OPPOSITION ON
THIS- AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ACTUALLY- ENSURING THAT
VETERANS DO HAVE ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH A
VERY VERY TOUGH IME- I ALSO TO
COME FROM A BIG VETERAN FAMILY
FROM MY GRANDFATHER TO MY
COUSINS TO. GET ABOUT TEN OF
THEM IN THE GONZALEZ FAMILY ARE
ALL VETERANS. AND ALL LATINO
AND I'M I'M REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATIVE THAT YOU'RE
BRINGING UP- THIS ISSUE. I CAN
SAY THOUGH THAT- IN SOME WAYS
YOU KNOW THERE COULD BE A
BUSINESS JUSTIFICATION OF
COURSE FOR THIS- IN THE SENSE
THAT YOU KNOW MILITARY
EXPERIENCE CAN GIVE YOU YOU
KNOW A LOT OF I'M GOOD
MANAGEMENT SKILLS PERFORMANCE
ON THE JOB AT CETERA ETCETERA
BUT- IT'S STILL IN MY OPINION
CAN LEAVE SO MANY PEOPLE BEHIND
IN SOME WAYS SO. ALL UP STAINED
OF FOR NOW- I KNOW YOU'LL
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS AND I
WOULD JUST LOVE TO CONTINUE-
HEARING MORE ABOUT IN THE NEXT
STEPS OF THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SIR GONZALEZ I CAN'T RECALL A
BILL WHERE EVERYONE COMMENTED
ON. DO WE WANT TO GO FOR NUMBER.
THREE SENATOR WIENER SUMMER
ONE. THE FIRST ONE A DEFERRED-
BUT ONE CARRIAGES ACTUALLY
FORGOT TO FORGET BECAUSE I
FORGOT TO MENTION. THAT IN
TERMS OF THE DISPARATE IMPACTS
ON SPECIFICALLY ON THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY. OUR COMMUNITY IS IN
A LITTLE BIT OF A UNIQUE
POSITION WITH THE MILITARY
BECAUSE WE WERE. COMPLETELY
BANS UNLIKE OTHER COMMUNITIES
BUT UNLIKE OTHER UNLIKE MOST
MOST OTHER PEOPLE- WE WERE
STILL ABLE TO SERVE BECAUSE
PEOPLE CHEST. I HID WHO THEY
WERE. AND THAT WAS THAT WAY
FOREVER SO THERE ARE ALWAYS
BEEN. ATTRIBUTED TO PEOPLE.
ABUNDANTLY IN THE MILITARY WHO
TRAGICALLY HAD TO SUPPRESS WHO
THEY WERE AND LIVE IN FEAR- AND
AT TIMES BE KICKED OUT AND HAVE
THEIR LIVES UPENDED. UNTIL THE
WHOLE POLICY WAS REPEALED. BUT
I. DID SOME LOOKING AND I THINK
THERE ARE. APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION- LGBTQ VETERANS IN THE
U. US IT MIGHT BE MORE AND
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT. BY
DEFEATED- THAT NUMBER OF US FOR
A FEW YEARS BACK SO MAYBE.
HIGHER NOW WITH A MILLION OUT
OF. I THINK ABOUT EIGHTEEN
MILLION OR THEREABOUTS VETERANS
OVERALL SO IT'S ABOUT ALMOST.
ABOUT A LITTLE MORE THAN FIVE
PERCENT- AND SO ON I DO THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF LGBTQ PEOPLE
FRANKLY CAN. BENEFIT FROM THAT
SO IT'S A UNIQUE. SITUATION
THAT OUR COMMUNITY IS AND I'M-
I'M NOT DISMISSING THE
CHALLENGES BECAUSE THE MILITARY
WAS ABSOLUTELY HORRIFIC.
TOWARDS OUR COMMUNITY FOR SO
MANY YEARS BUT I JUST WANTED TO
PUT THAT. OUT THERE IS A
CONVERSATION MOVES FORWARD. THE
YOU. I'D LIKE TO A QUESTION-
TWO TO THE AUTHOR MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY. PROGRAM THAT THE-
THAT'S CORRECT GET YOU YOU'RE
NOT FOUR STAR VETERANS ARE SO
THIS THEIR ONES AND MAKE SURE
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT THAT
THIS IS NOT PUBLIC POLICY
THROUGH A MANDATE BUT SOMETHING
THAT IS VOLUNTARY SO I THINK
THE SOCIETAL IMPACTS EVEN THOSE
ADDICTS HAVE EXPRESSED
MERITORIOUS CONCERNS WILL BE
MITIGATED TO SOME DEGREE. BONTA
MY SECOND POINT IS. I THINK
FIVE ONE OF THE APPRECIATIONS
THAT. OUR COMMUNITY HAS SHOWN
TO THOSE WHO HAVE. SACRIFICED
THEIR MILITARY SERVICE. IS
FINDING WAYS TO RE INTEGRATE
THOSE PERSON THOSE FOLKS. INTO
CIVILIAN LIFE AGAIN. I DON'T
WANT TO OVERLOOK THE FACT THAT.
THE BENEFITS THAT WE HAVE
DERIVED AS A COMMUNITY AS A
STATE AND AS A COUNTRY BECAUSE
OF THE SERVICE THAT INDIVIDUALS
HAVE PROVIDED THROUGH THE ARM
SERVICES IN THE ARMED FORCES.
AND I ALSO LOOK AT THIS AS IF
THIS IS HELPFUL TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE-
SACRIFICED OFTEN- ON THE
BATTLEFIELD THAT WE LOOK UPON
THIS AS IN ADDED A SENSE OF
APPRECIATION SO I'VE I WILL
CERTAINLY- SUPPORT THIS. NOT
TODAY IF- THE AUTHORS WILLING
I'D LIKE ALSO. VOWED TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN REQUESTING- TO BE
ADDED ON- SO WITH THAT- I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE SOME INTERESTING
DYNAMICS. THAT GO INTO THIS
ISSUE BUT I THINK YOU CLEARLY
LAID OUT. THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT GROUPS THAT WILL
ACTUALLY BENEFIT. FROM THIS IN
WAYS THAT- WE MAY NOT
NECESSARILY ANTICIPATE OR WERE
APPRECIATED A COMMON LEVEL. IS
THAT YOU KNOW YOU HAVE A
HISPANIC POPULATIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN POPULATIONS THAT
COMPRISE A LARGER SEGMENT OF
THE WORKFORCE IN THOSE IN
FINANCIAL NEED IN NEEDING. THAT
THOSE- THOSE FOR VERTICAL
OPPORTUNITIES IN SOCIETY SO I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
BE WITHOUT CONTROVERSY BUT I'D
BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT TODAY.
HOW IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THE NUMBER THANK YOU CENTER
BOARD JUST IN TWO. WELL MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO'S
COMMENTS IT. THE MILITARY WAS
WRONG AS AN INSTITUTION TO
DISCRIMINATE WASN'T JUST WRONG
WAS STUPID IT WAS ANTITHETICAL
THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
DISCRIMINATE ON IT AND I AM
HOPEFUL THAT THAT- COVERT OF.
LGBTQ VETERANS EXPANDS BECAUSE
AS PEOPLE ARE MORE COMFORTABLE
AFTER THEY'VE LEFT THE MILITARY
SERVICE AND NO LONGER FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE TO HIDE THEIR
IDENTITY THEY WILL IDENTIFY AND
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT I THINK
THAT. THIS WILL BENEFIT A
BROADER CROSS SECTION AND SOME
PEOPLE ARE EVEN AWARE TO DAY-
SADLY WE CAN'T GO BACK IN TIME
AND FIX SOME OF THOSE THINGS
AND CHANGE HOW THE MILITARY
BEHAVED TOWARDS WOMEN FORTY
YEARS AGO. IT IS DIFFERENT
TODAY THE QUESTION IS BECAUSE
THE INSTITUTION DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST AFRICAN AMERICANS FOR
EXAMPLE BEFORE NINETEEN FORTY
EIGHT- WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO
AN AFRICAN AMERICAN. SOLDIER
WHO'S LEAVING SERVICE TODAY.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO THAT
PERSON WHO'S LEAVING SERVICE IT
IS TRANSITIONING JUST LEAVING
IRAQ JUST LEAVING AFGHANISTAN
COMING BACK STRUGGLING WITH.
ALL SORTS OF THINGS- DO WE HAVE
A SOCIETAL OBLIGATION TO SAY TO
THAT PERSON LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE THAT BRIDGE I
THINK WE DO. ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU I DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON SB SIX SIX FIVE. WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR JONES- THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED IN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
MILITARY. AND VETERANS AFFAIRS.
ASSUMING THAT IS ACCURATE CHIEF
COUNSEL CAN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL HELEN IS ACCURATE- BURKE
HI. UMBERG I OR JUST SIGN.
FORGES HI COMMITTEE AT ALL HI.
I DID AWESOME HI YEAH SO I
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ NOT VOTING
HERTZBERG. JONES HI JONES I
LAYERED NO LAYERED NO STERN HI.
STERN I Y. CASKEY NO WAY CASKEY
NO WIENER WIENER I. FIVE SIX
SEVEN YOU HAVE SEVENTY TWO
RIGHT NOW BUT SOME MEMBERS ARE
HERE PLACE IT ON CALL ALL RIGHT
THE BILL IS OUT. OKAY TO ME THE
BILL BECAUSE- PUT ON CALL THING
KEVIN HAVE VOTED AFFIRMATIVELY
TO HAVE VOTED AGAINST AND WE
HAVE TO WHO WERE NOT PRESENT-
ALL RIGHT CENTER NUMBER YOU'RE
BACK IN THE HOT SEAT. THE ONE.
WHAT. ALRIGHT ONE LAST COMMENT-
THERE IS A CORRECTION FOR THE
MOTION FOR SB THREE SIX ONE
WHICH IS THE ITEM BEFORE THE
ONE WE JUST HEARD SB THREE SIX
ONE ALSO LAMBERG THE CORRECT
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. NOT
APPROPRIATIONS. LET THE RECORD
REFLECT THAT.
ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SIR BORDERS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ARE WE WE'RE GOING
TO WE ANNOUNCED SEVERAL TIMES
EARLIER THAT SENATOR RAWSON
BILL SB THREE FIFTEEN WAS GOING
TO BE DELAYED- CENTER ROTH IS
HERE SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND CALL UPON CINDER ROCK
PRESENT. SB THREE FIFTEEN SO
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE WATCHING
AND LISTENING. GET READY.
SENATE ROTH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WHO. THIS IS SENATE BILL
THREE FIFTEEN YOU KNOW FOR MANY
CALIFORNIA'S HOMEOWNERS REAL
PROPERTY IS THE ONLY ASSET THAT
THEY CAN PASS TO THEIR ERRORS
IN CALIFORNIA OF COURSE ONE WAY
TO CONVEY PROPERTY TO AN
AIRSTRIP WILL OR A TRUST. BOTH
OF WHICH REQUIRE. IN SOME IF
NOT MANY CASES COST PROHIBITIVE
PROBATE OR ESTATE PLANNING
ATTORNEY CONSULTATION. ONE OF
THE OTHER WAYS PARTICULAR TO
THE PARTICULAR THOSE WITHOUT
RESOURCES. THE RIGHT IS A
REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEED A REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON
DEATH DEED PROVIDES A- MUCH
MORE ACCESSIBLE AND AFFORDABLE
MECHANISM. OTHER THAN PROBATE.
FOR THOSE WHO MAY OTHERWISE
HAVE LIMITED OPTIONS IT'S
ANOTHER TOOL. AVAILABLE TO
THOSE WITH LIMITED OPTIONS SO
OFTEN THOSE WITH LIMITED ACCESS
ASSETS RATHER UNCOMPLICATED
HOLDINGS AND A HOME. THE
REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEED WAS CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN IT WAS AB ONE THREE
NINE. TO ALLOW OWNERS OF REAL
PROPERTY TO TRANSFER THEIR
PROPERTY UPON DEATH. I DON'T
SIDE OF THE NORMAL PROBATE
PROCEDURE. THIS PILOT PROGRAM
ORIGINALLY HAD A SUNSET DATE OF
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IT
WAS EXTENDED LAST YEAR ONE YEAR
DUE TO COVERED THIS BILL SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTEEN FURTHER
EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL BASED OFF
OF RECOMMENDATIONS FROM A
REPORT COMPLETED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION LAW REVIEW
COMMISSION. IF ADOPTED WILL
EXTEND THE REVOCABLE TRANSFER
ON DEATH DEED SUNSET DATE UNTIL
JANUARY. ONE TWENTY THIRTY TWO.
IT WILL ALLOW THE USE OF A
REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEED TO TRANSFER REAL PROPERTY
TO A PUBLIC ENTITY PRIVATE
NONPROFIT ENTITY OR TRUST IN
ADDITION TO THE OTHER
PROVISIONS. IT WILL STRENGTHEN
TRANSFER AND BENEFICIARY
PROTECTIONS SUCH AS REQUIRING
THE DEED TO BE SIGNED BY TWO
WITNESSES REQUIRING THE
BENEFICIARY TO GIVE NOTICE TO
THE TRANSFER WORSE ERRORS WHEN
THE TRANSFER OR DIES. AND IT
WILL ALLOW COURTS THE
DISCRETION TO DETERMINE A
TRANSFORMERS INTENT IF A
PARTICULAR ISSUE ARISES WITH
THE TRANSFER DOCUMENTS HE WILL
RESTRUCTURE THE RULES THAT
GOVERN THE BENEFICIARIES
LIABILITY FOR THE DECEASED
TRANSFORMERS AND SECURE DEBTS.
HE WILL GIVE THE CALIFORNIA LAW
REVISION COMMISSION ADDITIONAL
TIME TO STUDY THE EFFICACY OF
THE REVOCABLE TRANSFER ON DEATH
DEEDS EVALUATE THE EFFECTS OF
THESE NEW REFORMS AND MAKE
ADDITIONAL RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR
THE CONTINUATION OR TERMINATION
OF THIS PARTICULAR VEHICLE
ALONG WITH OTHER CLARIFYING
CHANGES. BY BRIAN HIBBARD FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION. AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER ON A
MYSTERY BEAR YOU'RE BACK WITH
US AGAIN YOU'RE ALL. YES I
NEVER LEFT. GOOD AFTERNOON-
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND SENATORS- I
AM BRIAN WEAVER I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE LAW REVISION
COMMISSION- IN THE INTERESTS OF
GRAVITY I WILL JUST SAY THAT
I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE I THINK THE
ANALYSIS FOUND SENATOR ROBERTS
DESCRIPTION THE BILL WERE QUITE
GOOD- SO I DON'T NEED TO PILE
ON ALL JUST- HANG BACK IF YOU
HAVE QUESTIONS JUST ASK. THANK
YOU- OTHERS IN SUPPORT I SEE NO
ONE IN THE GALLERY I SEE NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- IF WE COULD
TURN TO THE PHONES- MISTER
MODERATOR IF WE COULD TURN THE
PHONES. FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT.
THOSE WHO SUPPORT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NO
ONE'S IN QUEUE FOR SUPPORT ALL
RIGHT LET'S NOT TURN THE
OPPOSITION- I HAVE NO ONE
LISTED- INFORMAL OPPOSITION. IF
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE GALLERY
THERE'S NO ONE AROUND ONE
TWELVE. MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD OPEN THE PHONE LINES TO
THOSE OPPOSITION IS A PRIMARY
WITNESS THAT PERSONAL BE
ACCORDED TWO MINUTES. IF YOU
WANT TO QUEUE UP IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. TO SMOKE WE HAVE ONE
QUEUING UP.
MODERATOR. WHAT
WOULD YOU OPEN THE FILE ONE
MOMENT. BY THREE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND THERE'S NO
IN THE CUTEST TIME. ALL RIGHT-
LET'S TURN TO THE CHAMBER
QUESTIONS POSER CABALLERO. THE
BILL GLOBOSA CABALLERO IS SEE
NO OTHER MICROPHONES UP
ASSEMBLY CASKEY OKAY- CENTER
ALL CHEMICALS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU CENTER
ROTH MANAGE ACCOUNTS OF YOU
CALL THE ROLL SB THREE FIFTEEN
BY SENATOR ROTH THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE. HI.
NUMBER GUY BURGESS- IT'LL HI SO
WE HAD- I US. GET US SO I'D GO.
HI WINS I HERTZBERG. JONES HI
JONES I A LAYERED ON THEIR DIE
STERNE JOURNAL. STERN AYE WHITE
HOUSE SKI MY CASKEY AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE THAT'S- NINE TWO
ZERO. RIGHT WILL PUT THE BILL
ON CALL THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO ARE PRESENT IN
THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING AND
LISTENING. THERE IS LIGHT AT
THE END OF THE TUNNEL WE HAVE
THREE MORE BILLS LEFT TO BUY
CENTER WHITE CAL SKIN ONE BY
SENATOR WIENER. SO WHAT CAL SKI
DO YOU CARE T GO FORWARD ON SB
SIX EIGHT EIGHT THANK YOU MR.
CHAIR IN A JUDGMENT BY
CONFESSION IS ESSENTIALLY A
CLAUSE IN THE CONTRACT THAT
PERMITS A PARTY TO BYPASS THE
TRADITIONAL DUE PROCESS
HEARINGS LAW AND BASICALLY GO
TO THE REMEDY AND COLLECT AND
GO TO COLLECTIONS. YEAH IT IS
ADMITTEDLY S. S. B. S. SIX
EIGHT EIGHT WOULD DO AWAY WITH
THIS PRACTICE WHICH IS SELDOM
WE USE I CAME ACROSS IT AND
ONE. ONE CASE WHEN I WAS A
PRACTICING LAW AND IT'S REALLY
ARCANE OF PERMITTING THE
CONSUMER OR SMALL BUSINESS
PERSON TO SIGN AWAY THEIR
RIGHTS TO DUE PROCESS- AND GIVE
THE CREDIT TO THE RIGHT TO
DECIDE WHICH IF SHE THINKS THAT
THE CONTRACT HAS BEEN BREACHED
SO. AS COMMITTEE. REPORT NOTES
THERE'S NO SUPPORTERS
OPPOSITION SO THIS. I WOULD
ORGANIZATION IT'S- I WOULD URGE
AYE VOTE ONLY FOR THE DAY. ALL
RIGHT QUESTION COMMENTS WELL A
WE'LL GO TO WILL GO TO SUPPORT
POSITION FIRST- I SEE NO ONE A
GALLERY I SEE NO IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF THIS MATTER IS A ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
CENTER WHITE CAL SKIS. SB SIX
EIGHT EIGHT. YOUR IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN IF ZERO.
I DO NOT HAVE ANY ONE QUEUED UP
ALL RIGHT LET'S NOT GO TO
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE
INTERESTED IN TESTIFYING IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. NOT A
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE PREPARE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIX
EIGHT EIGHT. YOU ARE UNABLE TO
OPPOSITION AT THAT ONE AND THEN.
ZERO AND I DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT- I DON'T
SEE ANY CENTER LAYERED THE
BILL- I MOVED THE BILL AN
EARLIER MOVES A BILL I SEE NO
OTHER MICROPHONES SO WHAT
COUNTS YOU CARE TO CLOSE
EXCELLENT CLOSE THANK YOU-
TIVER RIGHT THANK YOU. MANAGING
COUNSEL IF YOU CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS SB SIX EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WHITEHOUSE GIVEN THE
MOTION BY SENATOR THERE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS I'M BURKE HI I'M
BURKE AYE BURGESS. AYE VIETTO
AYE CABRERA AYE AIDED AYE SO
DRESS SO I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG. JONES NO JONES NO
LAYERED HI LARRY. I STERN SURE.
STERN AYE WIECKOWSKI HARD BY. I
WIENER ALL RIGHTS WIENER I WENT
TO OR YOU HAVE EIGHTY ONE SO
FAR BUT THAT THE LONG CALL
THERE NOW TO BILLS LEFT CENTER
WHITE HOUSE HE'S SB EIGHT ZERO
SEVEN SENATE WHITE HOUSE
SPEAKER TO PRESENT MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WILL BE
TAKING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS IS ALKALINE IN THE-
STAFF REPORT AND- APPRECIATE
THE STAFF AND THE TEACHERS HARD
WORK ON THIS. AS WE HEARD FROM
SENATOR HERTZBERG'S BILL THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING HIS ARE THE EQUATED
TO THE FEDERAL E. O. C. N. THE
MONITOR ENFORCES CIVIL RIGHTS
LAWS. IN OUR- IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA. EIGHT YEARS AGO WE
ALLOW THE TO GO ABOUT
PROSECUTING CIVIL RIGHTS CLAIMS
A STAKEHOLDERS CITY HAVE
IDENTIFIED SECTIONS OF THE
FEAR. EMPLOYMENT HOUSING
ACTIVITY TO BE MONETIZED AND
HARM AND HARMONIZING CLARIFIED.
IN SUCH. THAT MOST OF THESE ARE
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE CODE
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF POINTS.
WERE SWITCHING FROM WRITS OF
MANDAMUS TO ACTUAL APPEAL SO
THAT WE CREATE SOME RECORD
WHICH FOR THE LAWYERS WILL KNOW
THAT IN THE TOLLING OF THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
FILING A CLAIMS. IN A CIVIL
CASE. ARE WELL ON THE MATTER OF
ORINDA INVESTIGATIONS WILL BE
TOLD- WITH THE- ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS WE HAD IN THE
ORIGINAL BILL. A SIX YEAR
PERIOD- FOR THAT THE LENGTH OF
TIME THE PEOPLE TO BRING CLAIMS
WE'RE ACCEPTING A MOMENT TO
BRING IT TO FOUR CURRENT LAW.
THAT WE PASS ALLOWS- NAMELY
HAVE. A THREE YEAR PERIOD FOR
PEOPLE TO FILE MIX- A
DISCRIMINATION CASE SO IT
HARMONIZES WITH THAT AND I DO
HAVE ONCE AGAIN MR ROMERO IS
HERE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR PAF.
FROM THE DFG H. TEN ST MARTIN
ACTION TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU SO A CASCADE MR
ROMERO WELCOME BACK AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND GOOD
EVENING KAREN BERMAN HONORABLE
MEMBERS ADAM AMERO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING THE ADMINISTRATION
IS NOT SPONSORING THIS BILL AND
IT'S NOT HAVE A POSITION ON IT
AND- YOUR TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE- I ATE IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME WRONG- AND
ANYTHING ELSE AND JUST MAKE
MYSELF AVAILABLE. TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU BILLY NOTED. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. OF THE S. B.
SIX- EXCUSE ME SB EIGHT OH
SEVEN THERE'S NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE- MISTER MATER IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE.
THE BILL THERE IS NOBODY QUEUED
UP AS OF RIGHT NOW. ALL RIGHT
LET'S TURN THE OPPOSITION- I
SEE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IN THE GALLERY NOR IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE- SO LET'S TURN TO THE
PHONE LINES META MODERATORS
ANYONE- PREPARE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE.
APPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
NINE ZERO. THIS. ONE AND I DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE QUEUING UP I
THINK RIGHT NOW. WHERE ALL
RIGHT- LET'S FREE BACK THE
CHAMBER QUESTIONS I SEE CENTER
JONES ETCETERA JONES I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING A MOMENT TO LOWER THE
TIME FRAME FROM SIX TO FOUR
YEARS SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL THANK YOU BYE. THANK YOU
SIR JOHN'S ANYONE ELSE. ALL
RIGHT- SENATE Y. CASKEY WOULD
YOU CARE TO CLOSE YOU DID A
MOMENT AGO. RESPECTFULLY YOURS
AND I VOTE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT- THERE MOTION SIR THEY'RE
ALSO MOVES THE BILL- THAT AND
SHE TELLS OF YOU CALL THE ROLL
COULD BE ENOUGH THIS IS SB
EIGHT OH SEVEN BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE GIVEN THE MOTION BY
SENATOR DID ALSO. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND THEN RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
BURKE HI AMBERG I. PORGES-
CARRY IT OUT HI THE RADIO I DID
ALSO. THAT I SO I GONZALEZ HI
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. JONES HI
JONES I LAYERED ARE THERE TO
AYE STERN. STERN I Y. CASKEY HI
MY CASKEY AYE WIENER BY. WHEN
R. I. A. YOU HAVE. SEVEN NINE
TWO ZERO SO FAR WITH MEMBERS
MISSING THANK YOU PUT THAT ON
CALL- FOR MEMBERS WHO ARE
PRESENT HERE THIS IS THE LAST
BILL AND AS MUCH AS WE LIKE
HANGING OUT WITH ONE ANOTHER
AFTER THIS BILL IS PRESENTED ON
AND PRESUMABLY VOTED UPON- WE
WILL OPEN THE ROLE AND- THEN
THE- BALL HOME. BUT AT LEAST
OUR OFFICES SO. CENTER WIENER
S. B. TWO FIVE TWO. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. HELLO AND THANK
YOU TO YOU IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS TO SP TWO FIFTY TWO
FOR CALLING SINCE LEGISLATION
WILL BAN- THE UNNECESSARY USE
OF DOGS AND CATS AND TOXICITY
TESTS CONDUCTED IN CALIFORNIA.
THE BILL DOES NOT PROHIBIT
TOXICITY TESTING THAT'S
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW AND
DOES NOT IMPACTS ON A TESTING
BEING DONE FOR MEDICAL RESEARCH
BAXEEN DEVELOPMENT PET PRODUCTS
AND MEDICAL DEVICE TESTING
TOXICITY TESTING. INCLUDES FOR
EXAMPLE FORCE FEEDING OR
INJECTING ANIMALS WITH HARMFUL
CHEMICALS OR PRODUCTS TO
EVALUATE- VIA FAX THE
DISCOVERED CHEMICALS MIGHT HAVE
ON HUMANS- SOME TESTS INVOLVE
OVERDOSING DOGS. AND
ADMINISTERING CHEMICALS OVER A
PROLONGED PERIOD CAUSING SLOW
AND HORRIFIC PAIN. ANIMALS ARE
OBSERVED FOR TOXIC SIDE EFFECTS
RANGING FROM VOMITING AND
BLEEDING TO TUMORS AND EVEN
DEATH. BY DOGS AND CATS SUFFER
GREATLY FROM THIS TOXICITY
TESTING WHICH WE ALSO NOW KNOW
IT'S LARGELY INEFFECTIVE AND
NOT SUPPORTIVE BY CURRENT
SCIENCE. A GROWING BODY OF
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT DOG STUDIES
PRODUCE HIGH LEVELS OF FALSE
NEGATIVES. WHICH OCCUR WHEN A
PRODUCT APPEARS TO BE SAFE AND
DOGS BUT IS FOUND TO BE HARMFUL
IN HUMANS. DRUG DEVELOPMENT
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT 90% OF
DRUGS FIRST TESTED ON ANIMALS
FAIL WHEN SUBSEQUENTLY TESTED
IN PEOPLE. RESEARCHERS HAVE
EVEN EQUATED PREDICTIONS OF
TOXICITY BASED ON CANINE DATA.
TO SLIGHTLY BETTER THAN TOSSING
A COIN. TOXICITY TESTS DO NOT
ENSURE HUMAN SAFETY AND
COMPLETELY DISREGARD CANINE AND
FELINE LIVES. BY THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN SPECIFICALLY TO
PROHIBIT TAXES CITY TESTING
CARRIED ON DOGS AND CATS THAT
SERVES NO REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS. COMPANIES CONDUCT
THIS TYPE OF TESTING NOT
BECAUSE THEY'RE REQUIRED TO USE
DOGS OR CATS BUT BECAUSE- THERE
IS PRECEDENT AND CONVENIENCE
WHICH FRANKLY DOES NOT JUSTIFY
THE SUFFERING ENDURED BY THESE
ANIMALS. AS TESTING IS
CONDUCTED BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
AND PRIVATE LIVES. AND THEY'RE
NOT REQUIRED TO REPORT WHAT
TESTS ARE CONDUCTING AND WHY.
FOR INSTANCE DURING THE ONE
YEAR PESTICIDE TESTS ON DOGS
RESEARCHERS FOR STOCKS TO
CONSUME PESTICIDE EVERY DAY FOR
AN ENTIRE YEAR. ALL THE DOGS
ARE KILLED AT THE END OF THE
STUDY IF THEY DO NOT DIE DURING
THE STUDY. THE EPA ELIMINATED
THIS TEST REQUIREMENT MORE THAN
A DECADE AGO YOUR COMPANY STILL
CARRY OUT THIS TASK DESPITE IT
NOT BEING REQUIRED- AND THEY
SUBMIT THE DATA AS PART OF
THEIR PESTICIDE REGISTRATION.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LEADER IN
ALTERNATIVE TESTING METHODS
WHICH REPLACE ANIMAL TESTING
WITH NEW INNOVATIVE TECHNOLOGY
EXAMPLES INCLUDE USING LAB
GROWN HUMAN TISSUE INSTEAD OF
LIVE ANIMALS AND USING COMPUTER
MODELING TO PREDICT THE IMPACT
OF A HARMFUL CHEMICAL. THEY'RE
ALREADY EFFORTS TO MAKE THE
TRANSITION TO ALTERNATIVE
TESTING ON A NATIONAL LEVEL THE
EPA HAS COMMITTED TO ELIMINATE
ALL ANIMAL TESTING FOR
PESTICIDES AND CHEMICALS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. THE FDA HAS
ALSO EMBRACED ALTERNATIVE
TESTING BY RELEASING A-
PREDICTIVE TOXICOLOGY ROADMAP
AND FORMING AN ALTERNATIVE
METHODS WORKING GROUP- WE'RE
WORKING WITH CONCERNED GROUPS
INCLUDING SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION. TO ENSURE THAT THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL IS
PERFECTLY CLEAR THAT IF THE FDA
REQUIRES- DOG CAUGHT TESTING
FOR DRUG APPROVAL BY THE WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO BAN NOT IF IT IS
REQUIRED BY THE FDA- AND SO
WE'RE GOING TO WORK TO REFINE
THE LANGUAGE. AND MAKE SURE
THAT IT IS CLEAR THIS IS A
STEP TOWARDS MORE TO ABOUT- AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
ARE COUGHING CONLEY- VICE
PRESIDENT OF ANIMAL RESEARCH
ISSUES OF HUMANE SOCIETY-
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL. AND THEN
DR BARBARA HODGES A
VETERINARIAN WITH THE HUMANE
SOCIETY VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALSO ON THE LINE IN
CASE QUESTIONS COME UP. MY
DAUGHTER JERRY BAILEY WHO IS A
RESEARCHER ON IN THIS AREA
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER LET'S START WITH
MISS CONNELLY IS MISS CONNELLY
ON THE LINE. I DO NOT FRIEDMAN
CURRENTLY ON THE LINE HERE
LET'S TURN TO DR BARBARA HODGES
AND APOS CALMLY THEN APPEARS
THAT WILL COME BACK TO HER. SO
DR HI. IS DOCTOR HODGES YET.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
THANK YOU DOCTOR HODGES OKAY
GREAT GO AHEAD GREAT. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS IS DOCTOR
BARBARA HODGES THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARIAN PRACTICING SMALL
ANIMAL MEDICINE FOR THE PAST
TWENTY YEARS AND WORKING
EXCLUSIVELY WITH DOG AND CAT
PATIENTS. TODAY I REPRESENT THE
HUMANE SOCIETY VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WITH
APPROXIMATELY NINE THOUSAND
VETERINARY MEMBERS NATIONWIDE
INCLUDING NEARLY TWO THOUSAND
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB TWO FIVE
TWO WHICH WOULD AND CRUEL AND
UNNECESSARY TOXICITY TESTING ON
DOGS AND CATS IN CALIFORNIA.
DURING THE TESTING ANIMALS ARE
EXPOSED TO DRUGS PESTICIDES AND
OTHER CHEMICALS AND ARE THEN
OBSERVED FOR HARMFUL EFFECTS.
SUCH AS VOMITING SEIZURES
DIFFICULTY BREATHING HEART
FAILURE AND EVEN DEATH. AFTER
HE STUDIED ANIMAL SUBJECTS ARE
OFTEN KILLED SO THAT THEIR
TISSUES AND ORGANS CAN BE
EXAMINED. IS IN FACT A CORE
CORRELATION BETWEEN THE RESULTS
OBTAINED FROM TESTING IN
ANIMALS AND REAL WORLD OUTCOMES
IN HUMANS SB TWO FIVE TWO
ENCOURAGES HUMAN RELEVANCE NON
ANIMAL TESTING METHODS WHILE
PROVIDING EXTENSION FOR MEDICAL
RESEARCH AND THOSE TOXICITY
TESTS. FEDERALLY MANDATED USE
ANIMAL TESTING OF MEDICATIONS
AND PRODUCT MEANT FOR DOGS AND
CATS THEMSELVES WOULD ALSO NOT
BE IMPACTED. CALIFORNIA HAS A
LONG HISTORY OF ANIMAL WELFARE
LEADERSHIP INCLUDING PASSAGE OF
THE FIRST STATEWIDE LEGISLATION
TO END THE SALE OF ANIMAL
TESTED COSMETICS IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. SB TWO FIVE TWO
ENCOURAGES THE USE OF NON
ANIMAL TOXICITY TESTING
ALTERNATIVES THAT WOULD MORE
EFFECTIVELY SAFEGUARD HUMAN
HEALTH AND SAFETY WHILE
ACKNOWLEDGING THE STRONG
EMPATHIC BOND THE CALIFORNIANS
HAVE WITH. COMPANION DOGS AND
CATS. WE URGE YOU HUMANE INTO
THIS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU DOCTOR HODGES IS MISS
CONNELLY ONLINE. I DO NOT
CURRENTLY ON THE LINE.
ACCORDING TO MY- MISTER GRIMM I
STAFF- SHE WAS TRYING TO SPEAK
BUT IT WASN'T. WORKING SHE WAS
IN HER FOR SOME REASON BUT SHE
ALSO ON IT THIS CONLEY WHY
DON'T WE TURN TO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT AND IF MISS CONNELLY
THEN. AND TESTIFY WILL EVER
TESTIFY- KILEY IS ON THE LINE-
I CAN DO STARZ ZERO AND WE CAN
GET HER NAME AND OPENED HER
LINE. THE TWO STARS. ZERO AND I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY QUEUING UP.
WELL MATTER MODERATOR LET LET'S
DO THIS LET'S TURN TO OTHER
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE OF MISS
CONNELLY THEN. HERE'S THE MORE
WILL COME BACK TO HER SO I
DON'T SEE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY I DON'T SEE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SO LET'S GO TO THE OTHER
WITNESSES THAT ARE ON THE PHONE
AND AGAIN IF THIS KILEY PEERS
WILL COME BACK TO HER. THERE IS
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT IT WOULD BE
ONE THEN ZERO. AND I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY QUEUING UP AS OF RIGHT
NOW. ALL RIGHT- WELL THEN LET'S
TURN THE OPPOSITION. HE FURTHER
THOSE ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION IS THERE IT IS A
PRINCIPAL OR PRIMARY WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION WILL PROVIDE A
PERSON TWO MINUTES. IF YOU'RE
IN OPPOSITION OF IT. THE BILL
PLEASE PUSH ONE THEN IF ZERO.
WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY PEELING UP
HERE IT'LL BE JUST ONE MOMENT.
ALL RIGHT. AND WE WILL GO TO
THE LINE OF IT THREE OH TWO
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
SENATORS MY NAME IS BEING- HILO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES ASSOCIATION.
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING LIFE SCIENCES
SECTOR. HE COMMUNITY EMPLOYING
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE STATE. I
MEAN BY TAKING YOU MISTER CHAIR
THE COMMITTEE SENATOR WIENER AN
EXTRAPOLATE YOU MIGHT PASS ON
UNITED'S. REFLECTED AND
DENOUNCES. FORTUNATELY WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO LESSEN THE
NEED FOR THE REGION'S INDICATE
INSTEAD ANALYSIS. CALIFORNIA IS
THE RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD. BUT MORE
RESEARCH DONE HERE THAN
ANYWHERE ELSE. LEAVE THAT TO
THE WAY THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN COULD BE JUMPED OUT
THROUGHOUT YOUR INDUSTRY. IN
INDIA OUR ABILITY. TO CONDUCT
THE REQUIRED RESURGENT ABOUT-
THE LAST YEAR I. STEPPED UP THE
RESEARCH THE BALLOT NINETEEN.
HUNDREDS OF VACCINES AND
THERAPIES IN DEVELOPMENT TO
COMBAT THE DEADLY PANDEMIC.
THANK ANIMAL RESEARCH FOR THAT.
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM THAT
MAKE IT TO HUMAN TRIALS ARE
FIRST TESTED IN AND OUT. YEAH
YEAH OFTEN REQUIRED TO TEST ON
RESIDENTS ANY NON READ SPECIES.
OUR MEMBERSHIP USED TO BE A.
MODEL FOR THAT DISEASE. ASIAN
IS IN COURT WITH FDA. HOWEVER
THE WAY THIS GOES WRITTEN OUR
MEMBERSHIP WILL NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO TEST ON DOGS OR CATS IN
THE STATE TO BRING A DRUG TO
MARKET. THE PROPOSAL IT SEE I
THINK MEMBERS HAVING TO DO SO
IN OTHER STATES THUS REMOVING
COVETED. RESEARCH OUT OF
CALIFORNIA. NINE A COMPANY SUED
THE FDA BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO DO ANIMAL TESTING ON
TALKS. LAST YEAR THE COURT
RULED IN FAVOR OF THE FDA. IT
WAS DECIDED THAT ANIMAL TESTING
WAS NECESSARY. ANALYSTS HAD
INVESTIGATION AND I'M ATTACHING
ON DOCKS. WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS A DIFFICULT ISSUE. BUT
WE MUST MAKE SURE THIS WILL NOT
HAVE A NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
POINTY. FOR TO CONTINUE IN%
CONVERSATION WITH THE OFFICE
DOCTOR TO ADDRESS CONDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS HELP INSURE
CALIFORNIA REMAINS THE IDEAL
PLACE FOR INNOVATION. RESEARCH
AND TECHNOLOGIES THAT SAVE
LIVES GLOBALLY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION ENGINE. THE NEXT
LINE IS THREE FORTY FOUR. AND
THAT ONE HAS DROPPED- LET'S SEE
IF WE CAN DO THIS ONE HERE IS
COMMONLY APPEARS THEN WE COULD
PUT HER ON AS WELL. OKAY WE
HAVE A COUPLE HERE QUEUING UP.
IT'LL BE JUST ONE MOMENT HERE.
OKAY THEN WE COME TO THE LINE
OF THREE FORTY SIX. PLEASE GO
AHEAD YEAH. THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING SHARON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M THE PRIMARY
TESTIMONY AND I'M SORRY THAT I
GOT DISCONNECTED EARLIER
ANIMATED DR AMANDA CARSON BANKS
FOR THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA BIOMEDICAL RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION I'M HERE WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
FOR S. B. TWO FIFTY TWO THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS MY CONCERNS. THE WAY
THIS BILL AS WRITTEN IT
SEPARATES MEDICAL RESEARCH AND
DRUG DEVELOPMENT WITH THE
CONSEQUENCE THAT IT WILL NOT
ALLOW ANY TESTING ON CATS AND
DOGS TO BRING A DRUG T MARKET
THIS IS A CRITICAL PROBLEM IS
ONE OF THE GOALS OF BIOMEDICAL
RESEARCH IS TO TRANSLATE THE
DISCOVERIES OF THE LABORATORY
BENCH SPOT THE PATIENT'S
BEDSIDE NEXIUM CRESTOR LANTIS
CELEBREX TO BRING ABOUT AND
MAKE THE NEXT THESE ARE. ALL
DRUGS THAT WERE TESTED ON DOT.
ECLINICALWORKS ANIMAL. IN THE
U. STEP BEFORE CLOSE MAKERS
TEST HUMANS. ANIMALS ARE NOT
ONLY NEEDED TO TEST THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
MEDICATIONS. THEY ALSO NEEDED
TO CHECK THE SAFETY OF PRODUCTS
THE PREVENT ANY POTENTIAL HARM.
HUMANS ARE NOT THE ONLY ONES TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS RESEARCH AND
TESTING HUNDREDS OF DRUGS AND
TREATMENTS DEVELOPING NEW
MENUS. ARE NOW WITH TEAM
LEADERS AND THAT NAY CLINICS AS
WELL HELPING ANIMALS LIVE
LONGER HEALTHIER LIVES. AS I
MENTIONED LEGALLY IN ORDER FOR
THE FDA TO ALLOW DRUG MAKERS
BEGIN TRIAL NEWMAN. IT REQUIRES
FIRST TESTING WITH THE ROAD.
AND THEN A NON ROAD TO SPECIES.
BASIC SPECIALIST ON THE
NONVOTING SPECIES ARE
CONFIDENTIAL BUT THEY ARE IN
THE INFANCY OF THE PATENT
PROCESS. AS SUCH THERE'S NO WAY
FOR A MANUFACTURED TO SHOW WHAT
THE FDA HAS RECOMMENDED. MANY
OF THESE NON RODENT SPECIES
MUST BE A DOG OR CAT AS THE
OTHER SIDE TYPICALLY BEST
SUITED MODEL. WHILE I'M
SPEAKING ABOUT RESEARCH WITH
CATS AN DOGS TODAY IT IS
IMPORTANT TO STRESS THAT 95% OF
ALL RESEARCH. CONDUCTED WITH
ANIMALS IN THE NINE STATES OF
RODENTS RATS AND MICE. DOGS AND
CATS TOGETHER ACCOUNT FOR LESS
THAN. 1% OF ALL THE SEARCH
ANIMAL. IN CLOSING NOT FOR THAT
WE'RE- IN A- CAN. FEEDBACK
THESE NEW TREATMENTS. THEY
WOULD NEVER TO PAY THAT HAD NOT
BEEN FOR A- RESEARCH. STOPPING
AND I'M RESEARCH. SSI SIGHTED
AND COULD HINDER OUR ABILITY TO
BRING OUT ABOUT LIFESAVING
PRODUCTS TO MARKET. BUT HUMAN
AND ANIMAL HEALTH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
OKAY AND THEN. YEAH WE HAVE A
LINE. THREE THIRTY TWO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JIM JACKSON VIACOM CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU A CLOSING ARGUMENT
THAT. THANK YOU. FOR OKAY AND
THEN I AM TOLD AND WE MIGHT
HAVE BUT THE KATHLEEN CONNOLLY
ON HERE YET WE WILL YES I'M
HERE CAN YOU HEAR. OKAY YEP
YOUR ARM AND YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY I'M SO SORRY ABOUT THAT
NOT SURE WHAT HAPPENED BUT
THANK YOU CARE- BURKE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL TWO FIVE TO THE
PAST. FOR THE MOMENT THE TIDY
OF THE UNITED STATES I ACTUALLY
WORK FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND A
PRIMATE BREEDING AND RESEARCH
LABORATORY BECAUSE I WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT HUMAN HEALTH
AND ANIMAL WELFARE AND I LEFT
THE LAND FOR THE SAME REASON. I
WANT TO FIRST THIS BILL DOESN'T
STOP I'LL ANIMAL TESTING AND
RESEARCH IT ONLY IMPACTS LESS
THAN 1% OF ALL ANIMALS USED IN
THE STATE AND IT'S NOT AT THE
L. BAND. ALTHOUGH DOWNTURN HAS
ARGUED FOR CODE RESEARCH OR
TESTING RELATED YEMEN I THINK
YOU FIVE U. S. SEVERAL EXCEPT
EXEMPTION IS A VERY NARROW IN
FOCUS AND ONLY PROHIBITS
TOXICITY TESTING IN CALIFORNIA
THAT IS CARRIED OUT ON DOGS AND
CATS NOT REQUIRED BY FEDERAL
LAW. AND FOR PRODUCT MEANT FOR
HUMAN. BILL DOES A TO THIRD
TALK WITH TESTS ARE. FOOD COLOR
AND IT ISN'T DRAW. PEOPLE ARE
SHOCKED WHEN THEY IMAGES OF
DOGS SUFFERING IN. AND TENTH
THEY TELL ME THEY CAN'T IT THE
LEGAL AND- RELEASED POLL THAT.
FIVE PER OF. OPPOSE TAX TO. ON
DOT. IN ADDITION THEIR- THERE
IS OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE OF THE
FAILURE OF TOXICITY TESTING ON
DONG. SAID THEY'LL YOU I'M NOT
ANIMAL ALTERNATIVES SUCH. AS
ORGAN ON CHIP TECHNOLOGIES.
SURE SOME PILOT AND MUCH MORE
IN A CROWD WORK HAPPENING CAL.
RESULTSFROM DOCTOR WILL NEVER
IMPROVE WELL THE NON ANIMAL
TECHNOLOGIES WILL ONLY CONTINUE
TO GAIN GROUND. SAVING PRECIOUS
TIME AND RESEARCH DOLLARS DR
GARY BAILEY OF THE CENTER FOR
CONTEMPORARY SCIENCES TO AND
ANALYZE DATA FROM OVER TWELVE
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THURMOND HAD DONE DONE IS ON
THE LINE IS HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
SCIENTIFIC QUESTIONS. TAXES
TODAY TESTING ON THE IS
COMPLIANCE TESTING ANIMALS
ISN'T EASY BOX TO CHECK. FOR
PRODUCT APPROVAL THERE'S ALSO
NO REAL INCENTIVE TO STOP. BUT
YOU CAN HELP WITH THAT IF YOU
VOTE IN FAVOR OF SB TWO FIVE Q.
YOU WILL PROTECT DOGS AND CATS
IN PREPAYMENT SAFETY. FOR
INNOVATION AND BE APPLAUDED BY
YOUR CONSTITUENTS THANK YOU
MISS GRAHAM. I HOPE YOUR KIDS
DID THAT THANK. YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. FROM OTHERS IN UP.
ON THE PHONE WITH YOUR HAVE ANY
ON THE AUDIO SIDE ALL RIGHT.
MEMORIES ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT IT IS ONE NINE ZERO. WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYBODY IN THE
QUEUE AS OF RIGHT NOW. ALL
RIGHT THOSE WILL BE QUEUING UP
GREAT THANKS LET'S BRING BACK
THE CHAMBER- CENTER WINTER
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU FOR
WORKING ON THIS BILL THIS IS A
VERY. COMPLEX ISSUE AT LEAST A
COMPLEX ISSUE FOR ME- THE ISSUE
IS TO IS TO WHAT'S REQUIRED
WHAT'S RECOMMENDED- WHERE WE
DRAW THE LINE. I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANYBODY IN THIS CHAMBER
WHO WISHES TO SEE A DOG OR CAT-
SUFFER UNNECESSARILY CERTAINLY-
AND MOST OF US DON'T WANT TO
SEE HUMANS SUFFER.
UNNECESSARILY AND SO WE'RE WE
DRAW A LINE THAT'S A THAT'S A
CHALLENGE FOR US. AND IT'S
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING IF IT
WAS REQUIRES YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE RAPID TESTING A RAPID
DEVELOPMENT OF A PARTICULAR.
DRUG FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S A
PANDEMIC AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT THAT DOG TESTING OR CAT
TESTING WAS A PART OF THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE VACCINE FOR
COVERT- I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE
BILL. BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S STILL WORK TO BE DONE
TO PROVIDE. A- A BETTER
DEFINITION. WITH RESPECT TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF DRUGS- WE DON'T
AGAIN WANT TO SEE UNNECESSARY
TESTING UNNECESSARY HARM TO
ANIMALS. BUT WE DO WANT TO SEE
THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
LEAD THE WAY WITH RESPECT TO
LIFE SCIENCE DEVELOPMENT SO
HAVING SAID THAT. BACK TO THE
CHAMBER OTHER QUESTIONS. CENTER
THERE ARE SO. I HAVE A-
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR SURE-
THERE IS ONE CONCERN THAT WAS
RAISED ABOUT- COMPLIANCE WITH
INTERNATIONAL REGULATORY
AUTHORITIES. SO IF YOU COULD
ARE RESPOND TO THAT- AND THE
SPECIFIC ANSWER GATE- WAS- OR A
VACCINE OF PHARMACEUTICAL HAS
BEEN LICENSED IN THE EUROPEAN
UNION- REQUIRING THE USE OF
CANINE STUDIES. TO SATISFY
EUROPEAN MEDICINES AGENCY
REQUIREMENTS. SO IN TERMS OF
AXES A TIME OF DRUGS TOPIC
SEEMS CONSTRUCTIONS- WE'RE NOT
PRECLUDING NOT WITH VACCINES-
AND BASICALLY THERE ARE THREE
CAUGHT AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THREE- IT APPROVING ENTITIES
THAT. ARE PARTICULARLY RELEVANT
AROUND THE WORLD THE U. S. THE
EUROPEAN UNION AND JAPAN- AND
SO- THE QUOTE THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY HAS
TAUGHT AS OUTSIDE YES EVEN IF
THE US DOESN'T REQUIRE THE FTA
BUT IF THE EUROPEAN UNION OR
JAPAN REQUIRES A- THEY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO DO AND CALIFORNIA-
AND ARE IN MY VIEW ON THAT IS.
THAT YOU KNOW IT'S ONE THING IF
THE FTA WERE AND HE HOOKED US
UP WILL BE A FIFTY REQUIRES
THAT BUT IF THE E. U. OR JAPAN
REQUIRES A I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE ALLOWING THE TORTURE
OF THESE DOGS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT CAN DO THE TESTING.
ELSEWHERE THINGS WILL DEVELOP
THE DRUGS HERE THIS IS NOT
GOING TO MEET WITH THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY IS
GONNA LEAVE CALIFORNIA OR STOP
WILL BRING DRUGS HERE BECAUSE
YOU USE. ARE NEEDED TO TEST ON
A DOG AND WE DON'T ALLOW YOUR
BILL I IMAGINE DO IT SOMEWHERE
ELSE IF THEY NEED TO DO THAT-
BECAUSE WHAT WE DREW THE LINE
THAT WERE OKAY WITH IF THE FDA
REQUIRES OF A NOT OF JAPANOR
OR OR EUROPE REQUIRES THAT THE
DOLLARS THAT. ISSUE AND I
UNDERSTAND THEIR POSITION I'M
NOT CRITICIZING THEIR POSITION
WITHOUT. THAT WAS A STAR TAKE
ON. HI THANK UPS CASKEY. I
RESPECT GOOD RISK- NOT SUPPORT
THIS BILL I HAVE LOTS OF LIVE
SIGN FOLKS ON THE- OF THE YEAR-
MEDICINE AGENCY THESE OTHER
INTERNATIONAL BODIES PUTTING
AND DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS FOR
WE TALK ABOUT A GLOBAL ECONOMY
THAT WE HAVE AND HOW SMALL IT
IS SO- I'LL BE PAYING CAREFUL
ATTENTION TO THE AMEND SAID
COMMAND AND THE CLARIFICATION
ON WHAT'S RECOMMENDED AND
WHAT'S REQUIRED IS THE FATHER
WORKS ON. ASSEMBLY CASKEY NO
OTHER MICROPHONES UP- SIR WE
KNOW YOU CARE CLOSE. I THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY TESTS I HAD ASSUME
WITH OF THE LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION ON FRIDAY TO HEAR
THEM AL WILL WORK WITH THEM
FIRST OF ALL TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE CLEAR ON WHAT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN ON THE BILL- THAT IF THE
FDA REQUIRES- USE ACCOUNTS OF
DOLLARS IN DRUG TESTING THE
BILL WOULD ALLOW IT AS WELL-
AND SO WILL HAVE THOSE
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY- THIS IS. AN AREA
OF RESEARCH NOT SINCE ABOUT
DRUGS BUT ALSO ALL SORTS OF
PRODUCTS THAT IS REALLY NEEDS
TO AND THAT IS INCREASINGLY
VIEWED AS NOT PARTICULARLY
USEFUL- AND- WE SHOULD PUT AN
END TO A HEARING. CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THIRTY
THANK YOU- IS THERE A MOTION.
SEVERAS ALMOST THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT MANAGE ACCOUNTS OF YOUR
CALL THE ROLL THESPIAE TWO
FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR WIENER
MOVED THE MOTION BY SENATOR DID
ALSO DO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMENDED AND THEN RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- BURKE HI AMBER
GUY BURGESS. BOARD JUST NOT
VOTING CABALLERO. HOW BAD ARE
NOT VOTING DID I SO I DRESS SO
I GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG I'D JONES.
THE LOANS NOT VOTING. BLARED HI
LAYERED I STERN STREAMLINE
STERN HIGHWAY CAL SKI NO WAY
CASKEY NO WIENER HI. WIENER AYE
YOU HAVE. ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE SIX SEVEN AND EVERYONE IS
HERE. SEVEN TWO ONE. SEVEN ALL
RIGHT THAT BILL IS ABOUT PART-
WE'RE GONNA LIVE CALLS WELL
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU ALL
MEMBERS FOR BEING SO DILIGENT
AND REMAINING HERE ALL DAY
WE'VE BEEN HERE FOR NEARLY-
LET'S SEE NEARLY SIX HOURS SO.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S LET
THE CALLS OKAY. BERMAN. SEE
WHAT- YOU HAVE TO DO IN ORDER.
ALL RIGHT LET'S LET'S OPEN THE
ROLE HERE LET'S OPEN ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FIRST AND THEN GO
THROUGH FROM THE BEGINNING ALL
RIGHT MAN CHIEF COUNSEL IF YOU
WOULD OPEN THE ROLE ON ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SB FIVE THREE
RUBIO. SORRY ONE SECOND- THIS
IS SB FIVE THIRTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR RUBIO. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE LAYERED AYE
LAYERED AYE THAT'S ELEVEN TO
ZERO THAT DILUTES OUT ELEVEN
ZERO. OUR ALL RIGHT LET'S START
AT THE TOP. THIRTY WITH ABSENT
CALENDAR ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
I'D JONES JONES I THAT'S ELEVEN
TO ZERO CONSENT CALENDARS OUT
LIVES ZERO. OKAY THE NEXT BILL
IS SB THREE FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR ALAN. FOR JESS. NOT
VOTING. HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG
AYE JONES. JONES NOT VOTING AS
WELL UNTIL MORE. THAT'S NINE
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT NINE ZERO
SIX THE NEXT ONE IS S. B. SIXTY
TWO BY SENATOR DID ALSO FORGES.
GORGEOUS NO HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG AYE JONES BILL JONES
NOTE THAT'S NINETY TWO BILLS
OUT NINETY TWO. THE NEXT BILL
IS SB FIVE OF SEVEN BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. GORGEOUS GORGEOUS HI
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
JONES HI JONES BY THAT'S A
LEVIN TWO ZERO ZERO. NEXT ONE
SB FIVE ONE SIX BY SENATOR
EGGMAN GORGEOUS. GORGEOUS I
CABALLERO HI CAMBIADO I
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
JONES HI JONES HI THAT'S ELEVEN
TWO ZERO. ZERO NEXT TO BILL SB.
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR
GLAZERS. GORGEOUS GORGEOUS HI
CARRIE AT ALL HI COMMITTEE ALL
I HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG I JONES
HI JONES HI ELEVEN TWO ZERO.
ZERO THE NEXT BILL IS SB SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY SENATE I'M
SORRY SB SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG JONES NO
JONES NOTE THAT'S NINETY TWO
BILLS OUT NINETY TWO. S. S. J.
R. TWO BY SENATOR WEST SO
GORGEOUS. FOR JUST NOT VOTING.
JONES JONES NOT VTING WIENER
HI WIENER HI THAT'S NINE TWO
ZERO AS CHAIR TO IS OUT NINE
TWO ZERO. K. NEXT WE HAVE S. B.
TWO SEVENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
LEAVE US. FORGES. NOT VOTING NO
I'M SORRY I GO BACK SORRY FOR
JUST SO GORGEOUS NO. CABALLERO
I HAVE A AT ALL I. WIENER HI
WIENER HI THAT IS TEN TO ONE.
THOSE ARE TEN TO ONE. SENATOR
MEN'S SB THREE NINETY ONE IS
NEXT. FORTUS. FIVE OR JUST AYE
THAT'S TEN TO ONE NO. TWENTY
ONE THE BILLS OUT. THE NEXT
BILL IS SB THREE SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR UMBERG. HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG FI THAT'S TEN TO ONE.
THEN TO ONE BILLS OUT. THE NEXT
BILL IS SB. SIX SIX FIVE. BY
SENATOR UMBERG- C. GONZALEZ NOT
VOTING CHU CHIN BUT EARLIER
SORRY- HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I.
THAT'S. THAT'S EIGHT TWO TWO
EIGHT TO THE BILLS OUT. THE
NEXT BILL IS SB THREE FIFTEEN
BY SENATOR ROTH PORGES. BY
SENATE THAT'S OKAY AWAY AT THAT
SB. THREE FIFTEEN BY SENATOR
ROTH. OKAY HOLD ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN ONE OUT OF ORDER. WE
CAN WAIT. RON IS ITEM EIGHTEEN
OKAY HOLD ON WHAT WAS. SB THREE
ONE FIVE BY SENATOR ROTH BORJAS.
NOT VOTING. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HI THAT IS TEN TWO ZERO. TWENTY
ZERO BILLS OUT. NEXT ONE IS SB
SIX EIGHT EIGHT BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI. GORGEOUS.
GORGEOUS NO HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE THAT'S NINETY TWO NINETY
TWO BILLS OUT K. NEXT ONE IS S.
B. EIGHT OH SEVEN BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI BOARD JESS. NOT
VOTING. HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
THAT'S TEN ZERO ZERO BILLS OUT
NEXT ONE IS S. B. SEVEN FORTY
SIX BY SENATOR SKINNER. BORJAS
NOT VOTING HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
I THAT IS I'M SORRY STERN. SURE
STERN AYE. SIX SEVEN EIGHT NINE
NINE TWO ONE. HEARD OF THAT
NINETY ONE THE BILLS OUT. AND I
THINK THAT THAT IS. THAT IT FOR
EVERYBODY I THINK THAT'S
EVERYTHING CAN YOU BLAME IT
WOULDN'T MOMENT ABOUT THE SP
TWO FIVE TWO WE HAVE COMPLETE
ROLE. WAS HERTZBERG YOUR
CURRENT.
THANK YOU ALL
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED. CALL.